e
we'll be starting the meeting in about
welcome to the committee on science
technology and energy or otherwise known
as 90% energy bills um we uh made a I
made an attempt to U emphasize energy in
our committee by changing our by
submitting a change to our name to put
energy first uh which was a good
argument as far as what the the way we
work and the bills we work on but
unfortunately the rules committee did
not agree with me so you're stuck with
Science Tech and energy being last
although it's first in our agenda here
so welcome and uh chairman Vose will be
around in a few minutes he's at a
meeting right now so I will start this
meeting with the um traditional Pledge
of Allegiance uh the honor being given
to um representative cat
McGee I
States of America to the for it stands
Nation
all okay today we are are honored to
have a
presentation by uh the office of envir
Department of Environmental Services
they have a lot to talk about today so
we've allotted uh about 90 minutes for
the presentation U I don't know how
you're going to be doing this but if
it's several people discussing several
topics perhaps at the end of each topic
or something we might break for a A or
not break but pause for questions or
something if that's okay with
everyone okay um before I start does
anyone have any questions at all before
we
start okay we're going to continue on
and uh I'm going
to introduce Department of Environmental
Services and
identify yourself and sign in
please good morning thank you for the uh
thank you to the committee for inviting
us here today to give you a presentation
uh my name is Adam crepo I'm the
assistant commissioner at the Department
of Environmental Services um I thought
we would start with a brief overview of
the department I'll probably speak for
10 or so minutes to give you a holistic
view of what the department does and and
some of the functions there and then
um the at chairman vos's request uh we
are going to present on the state of
dams in New Hampshire we're going to
talk about the air Resources Division uh
broadly and get more in depth on that
because most that's mostly what will be
coming to your committee or bills that
they deal with and then we're going to
talk about uh the regional greenhouse
gas initiative uh that's a regional
initiative that that we New Hampshire
participates in and then lastly we'll
talk about past and Air um in those
issues so uh we have a lot to get
through so I'll I'll I'll get started I
always like to start off with our
mission statement which is to help
sustain a high quality of life for all
citizens by protecting and restoring the
environment and Public Health in New
Hampshire we recognize that doing so is
is is extremely important and we take it
very seriously but we also have to
recognize that uh it goes hand inand
with a strong economy right and making
sure that we we balance all of those
things uh so as to not uh reduce uh the
quality of life but to to to enhance it
while we're enhancing our our economy um
over over time as you can imagine since
the department was start uh was
established uh we we've kind of taken
care of a lot of the low hanging fruit
right the um really really negative air
emissions you know the cleaning up our
waterways and uh remediating uh really
hazardous waste uh waste sites um and as
time has gone on uh you know things like
emerging contaminants past have become
more uh PR you know more prominent more
in the uh in view for us uh and that's
so that's something that is much more um
I think Nuance to address it's it's a
it's a more
challenging um uh threat to to Public
Health and so um there's that
so at at a high level we have uh the
commissioner's office which is um 52
staff I I uh as the assistant
commissioner I manage that that unit
which is basically has 52 staff um and
it consists of all of the internal
matters like HR legal um uh long-term
planning for the dep Department our
public information uh and Communications
unit that's uh really what they deal
with is anything that has to do with um
public engagement so that's branding for
the Department working with making sure
public hearings go uh well um you know
right to no requests things things of
that nature um and then we have the
waste management division that is headed
by uh director Mike wisat and they deal
with things such as uh ha remediating
and managing hazardous waste sites uh
Solid Waste remediation and uh Solid
Waste Management and um
permitting they deal with uh underground
and above ground storage tanks for
petroleum products uh they deal with
super fund sites brownfields um and then
they also have you know uh p in their
portfolio and what kind of goes hand
inand with that is the drinking water
groundwater trust fund which is uh an it
was established through after an mtbe
settlement uh came in and and that goes
to uh contam projects for contam
contamination drinking water projects
things things of that
nature um and that they have about 118
staff in that division then we have our
Water Division which has um it's the
largest division has 258 staff they deal
with uh Dam state owned dams and and
even uh we have we have more than 2,000
dams in the state but we have 273
state-owned dams um and you'll hear more
about that later but that is a pressing
challenge that we're trying to deal with
uh they they require a lot of care and
maintenance and uh historically we've
received Appropriations through the
capital budget to to do that but um you
know we we're really looking for a
sustainable source of funding to be able
to take care of of of the care and
maintenance of those operations and
maintenance of those facilities uh going
forward um then we have our land
resources management program that is is
uh really separated into four bureaus
that's the wetlands Bureau
Shoreland uh alteration of terrain deals
with large permitting programs uh or
large permitting projects over 100,000
square feet for the most part um then we
have watersheds uh our Watershed Bureau
think um think cyano bacteria that
sampling and making sure that we keep
our surface waters clean and and and
healthy and and alerting the public if
there's a threat there uh we have our
Wastewater uh Bureau and Wastewater
engineering Bureau and they deal with
large Wastewater projects um and the
regulations that go along with that they
uh we have the drinking water uh Bureau
which deals with um ensuring that we
provide funding whether it's through srf
or uh all the other funds I'll get to at
a later slide for drinking water
projects but also that we're uh make
that we're making sure that the Public
Water Systems uh adhere to to the
regulations whether it's federal or
state um and lastly a fun fact we have
the uh W winaki River Basin I think it's
the only state-owned wastewater
treatment plant in the country uh and it
and it uh has 10 communities that feed
into that around the Lakes Region um and
so that's I'm sure you'll hear more
about that maybe not in this committee
but out outside when you're voting on
bills if if there's anything in the
capital budget that goes toward that
eventually that goes toward that uh and
lastly uh we have the air Resources
Division which is uh headed by Craig
Wright uh he's behind me here and they
deal with the typical Smoke Stack
Industries um and regulations on those
uh mobile sources air toxics uh the
environmental health program that does
uh risk assessments Department wide so
they're not just for the air division
it's for Department wide uh for uh
Public Health threats uh environmental
threats um they also deal deal with
clean energy and and monitoring under
the federal clean uh Air
Act so this is just a slide uh of all of
our high level functions I've kind of
gone through most of those but one of
the things I didn't touch on is
emergency preparedness and response you
know think oil spills um or or hazardous
waste spills we have uh a team that
handles those uh on a on a 247 basis 24
hour 7 days a week basis uh they're on
call and so if
if an oil truck spill's over or uh
there's a there's a spill somewhere and
and they need to respond to that they
um as as I mentioned uh state owned dams
are are one of the largest challenges
facing our department right now we want
to ensure that we are keeping up and and
have them on a 50-year life cycle so
that we're getting to them at least
every 50 years and so to do that we'll
need around $155 million per year to to
sustain that type of um maintenance on
on these facilities right now I I
believe in cor Cory Clark's behind me
he'll get more in depth on this but I
believe we're on a 100-year life cycle
which uh if any of you know a lot of
these are built for 50 year for 50 years
so many of them are in poor condition
and we've done a good job with the
resources that we have of keeping uh the
most pressing uh hazards up in
addressing those but uh as as Cory will
note there's a there's quite a bit more
that could be done to ensure that we are
on a 50-year cycle to to make sure that
those are being taken care of um another
thing that we're we're working on is
improving our permitting processes you
probably heard in the governor's uh
inaugural address that we are um we're
looking at a 60-day time frame and what
does that sort of mean for the
Department of Environmental Services so
we're working very hard hard to figure
out how we can lean our processes and
make them uh better and and find a way
to especially for our land resources
management which is as I mentioned those
four bureaus that really deal with land
use
permitting um what we're doing is we're
putting those online we're making we're
creating e- permitting for those um and
as we do that we're leaning the process
we're going through lean events making
sure that um there are no duplicative
processes in place and that we are uh go
the extra mile to to meet meet our
deadlines um so there's that and then
uh L one other pressure that's on us
right now and and it's kind of winding
down is is the amount of infrastructure
funding we've gotten over the last few
years we've whether it's arpa we've
received $225 million in arpa funds over
the last uh since 2021 when that bill
was passed I believe we received more
than any other state agency uh out of
that bill
um and that really went to rehabbing and
and uh you know replacing uh state-owned
dams um drinking water projects uh for
communities addressing contamination um
and providing funding for uh
disadvantaged communities so uh we've
done we've done a lot there uh also the
bill money which is the bipartisan
infrastructure law that's something that
was passed in
2021 um we've received uh an enhanced
amount of funding through that whether
it's our s our state revolving Loan Fund
programs so those are uh low interest
loans to communities to be able to uh
replace
infrastructure um so we we've received
quite a bit of money through that and uh
and certainly the uh the IRA as well we
we've received and you'll hear more
about this later from the air Resources
Group but we receed some we're going to
receive some funding through that for
heat pump acceler a in adoption um so
that's that's a focus for us over the
next few uh few years um and of course
we're we're we're obviously always um
trying to improve how we how we handle
pasas and and contamination broadly um
that's something that I know we've
worked with various members of this
committee on uh in the past and uh you
know looking forward to uh you know
continuing those those efforts so uh I
thought just give a brief overview of
what the department does and then uh
happy to take questions I I'll stick
around for the majority of our
presentation so um if you have questions
for me that you don't think of now I
I'll be happy to come up and answer
those too so well thank you uh I'll take
the liberty of asking the first two
questions uh one is for my edification
the 273 state-owned damed dams are are
they all or primarily for flood
control uh some of them are for flood
control i i i defer maybe the Cory Clark
on that how many are for FP control and
how many are for recreation
but we have a variety of reasons why we
would have why we would have
impoundments but and there're and many
people don't realize you know Lake wiip
pasak even on on an empowerment so there
are a lot of um recreational water
bodies that we really rely on that are
held up by by a dam of some sort and so
um I think part of today but also this
year is going to be trying to educate
folks on what what water bodies are held
held up by that what happens if one of
those things fails um and just just
trying to educate folks on on why these
things are important so I don't know if
you want to thank you Corey Clark chief
engineer at the dam Bureau at New
Hampshire Department of Environmental
Services and I would say out of the 276
dams that uh the state of New Hampshire
owns and operates roughly about 10% of
those um are designed
for flood control purposes uh the state
of New Hampshire owns a uh a about a
dozen up in the baker River Valley
another dozen in the Sagan River Valley
and a couple other kind of scattered
throughout the state and a lot of those
dams were built in 1960s using Federal
money and each dam is essentially a
large earn embankment that's um has a
small impoundment but the whole purpose
of that dam is to fill up like a bathtub
during a storm event and then slowly
drain out afterwards and and so those
those dams are uh are purely for flood
control purposes the other big ones that
people usually know about hopkington
Everett um Franklin Falls the big Army
Corps sites those are operated owned and
managed by the US Army Corps of
Engineers so the state has no bearing on
those sites whatsoever thank you uh
second question
is the you mentioned the aror money that
you used to do so projects that's gone
now and so my question would be with the
budget reductions that appear to be
impending um what what you you mentioned
about reducing some bureaucratic or
speeding up some regulations or you know
processes what other areas would you be
working on and what do you think the
effects would be on your department as
we have to uh you know downsize some of
our budget and not getting some of the
AR not getting the ARA money anymore uh
which is a a a big chunk but in other
ways um what do you guys planning right
now to help with that so as far as ARA
arpa funding goes uh at the time and
this the last estimate I have I can get
a a better estimate for the committee
but at some point in 2022 I believe it
was we we had around two2 billion dollar
worth of need in the state for different
infrastructure whether it's drinking
water Wastewater uh those types of
things and so um a lot of that as you've
probably heard the go former Governor
say lot lot of the arpa money was spent
on one-time projects and the reason for
that was to ensure that uh we're not
creating programs that we won't be able
to sustain over the long term right and
so naturally a lot of I think we showed
bait through our srf programs through um
our various other programs that we
administer that we're able to because we
have the need and um there is the demand
there we're able to get this that money
out quickly and that's one of the
reasons why I think we we receive 225
million from uh gopher which is the
governor's office for Relief and
Recovery to be able to admit uh send
money out to communities for those
projects uh many of those projects are I
would say more than 95% of them are on a
reimbursement basis so you know uh phase
of the project gets done or a piece of
the project gets done we reimburse for
that on a it's depending on the project
it's a monthly or quarterly basis and so
um and we do have staff that there's
sort of a long taale that goes along
with that for compliance and auditing
purposes and making sure that the money
goes into the right spot so there is a
tail for for staff to be able to have to
uh you know monitor these these projects
over the over the long term over at
least the next few years um so there's
that we
are in terms of reductions I you know
we're still working with the governor's
office on how how we're planning to um
you know meet meet any sort of
reductions that they're they're
intending to to to request uh I know
they've sent letter they've obviously
sent letters out to all the agencies uh
over the last few weeks on that um but
we're still working on how we're going
to get there um you know I I know some
of some of the things that we're looking
at are reducing the number of position
requests that we we initially had so
that's something that we're we're
certainly able uh to do you know I think
what I've been trying to tell whether
it's legislators or other elected
officials is that you know less less
positions means we get less done right
and that's and there is a correlation
there you know so I think uh it's
important to highlight that um but
that's that's that's sort of where we're
looking right now is is requesting less
positions over last legislative session
as many of you may be aware we did
receive quite a few new uh additional
duties uh added onto the department
whether it was
monitoring um past
uh intentionally added P into into
products or um or
other food the food wasteband or other
other programs we uh we we did receive a
quite a few additional UH
responsibilities there and so we
depending on um where where those
reductions are are are targeted uh we'll
we'll have to uh compensate
appropriately with what we're able to do
um you know I've been at the department
a year and and we I would say you know
we we have staff are they they have a
lot on their plate and so that's that's
something that we're working with them
on and making sure they're prioritizing
the right things so okay thank you
questions
uh I think I saw represent kaplan's hand
first thank you Mr Mr uh Vice chair and
thank you for taking my question um the
last question was about you know sort of
short-term budget uh concerns I'm
thinking more of long term Over the
Horizon are is the department looking at
uh your needs long term in in light of
you know increased probability of
extreme weather events things like that
you
know sure we so we we certainly are you
know a lot of a lot of that funding that
comes comes for extreme we events and
things of that nature goes to our
Coastal program for resiliency and
adaptation those are things that we
typically get Federal funding for um we
we are you know obviously we we want to
be careful about Mission creep but also
you know the those things are important
too so we we try to strike a balance
between what what's the policy of the
legislature and and allocating funds for
different positions you know we have uh
35 Plus State statutes that we are
required to administer as an agency and
so it's it's really targeting what's
what's the focus of those state laws how
what do we need to administer and what
are uh sort of things outside of our
statutory role to administer and you
know depending on what the reductions
look like we we you know there are some
things that we that I would classify as
um nice to Habs and and and need to Habs
right and you know the less the less
funding we get the the more we focus on
the on the need need to have right so um
that's that's kind of where we're at as
a as an agency but um I will say we did
receive $3 million for uh establishing a
climate action plan we're focusing on uh
voluntary measures as part of that and
and we're working with different
stakeholders to get to a spot uh on that
that's going to be over the next year um
and and so I think that that may address
some the longer term uh things that
folks could do to to reduce emissions
and things things of that
nature okay uh representative Swanson I
saw your hand
up yes thank thank you Mr Vice chair uh
thank you for being here and uh the U
question I had was uh just uh to expand
a little bit on uh the the notion of
state-owned dams and there are army
controlled dams is that correct and I'm
going to ask a question out of this but
there's sub questions I have so we got
state owned you've got Army owned and
they're private owned in the state right
right but you're focused on the
state-owned ones correct so we we we are
focused on it for funding purposes we're
focused on the state-owned dams um for
making sure that there isn't a you know
some sort of event that causes a a
breach of a dam you know we have we have
different classifications we have high
Hazard which is um you
know it could destroy someone's life it
could it could hurt someone or or kill
someone or it destroys property we have
significant Hazard and then we have low
Hazard so we have different criteria for
for whether it's not based on the
condition it's more based on what could
happen if it's breached right and
so um we we're focused for funding
purposes on on state owned um although
we we do have a responsibility to work
with municipalities or whoever the owner
is to ensure that that that they that
the dam doesn't doesn't breach if that
makes sense I don't know if you want to
Corey I don't know if you wanted to come
answer I think you uh hit pretty much
all the the points there um yeah there's
roughly 2600 registered dams in the
state of New Hampshire of those 276 are
owned by the state there's another
handful I don't know the number off top
of my head owned by the federal uh
federal agencies primarily the flood
control sites and then the last
remaining portion are owned by either
municipalities or privately owned or
owned by hydropower companies uh Mr Vice
chair a follow up if I may go ahead just
a little bit more for my education so I
uh understand that there there are
categories of flood control for for dams
there's flood control Recreation correct
and electricity generation I believe
I I think the mines Falls still actually
does
generation uh is are there any other
categories and is it safe to assume that
these overlap like Recreation is done on
damps that generate electricity yeah
that that's that's a correct assumption
that you know they they certainly do
overlap the only other categories that
we have if you have a storm water
detention Basin of a certain size that
could hold a certain volume of water
those are actually classified as dams so
um quite often those those sites you
know don't have any water and them the
majority of the year except for large
rain events around um various
developments in the state so there's uh
there's those that are also um included
in that 2600 along with um certain
lagoons um septage lagoons um storage
lagoons um if they are created with an
earth berm around those uh those are
also regulated by the dam Bureau as well
thank you thank Mr chair Thomas I saw
your name up yes thank thank you Mr Vice
chair thank you for being here um always
a delight to hear from Dees um I also
heard the governor say that she was
going to push for a 60-day um time frame
for permitting for um different
Industries um and uh
building can you tell me how this would
impact public input and what protections
will be in place uh for to protect uh
public input with such an aggressive
schedule
so we're still assessing how how this
would impact the agency at large I know
we've had some uh conversations with the
uh at the time the transition team and
and now the governor's office on what
this might look like um but at this
point we're we're still establishing
what what the plan will be for that as
you may be aware of we have various uh
Federal overlays on our permit so like
for example the Army Corps of Engineers
has uh an over they have we have a
general permit with them and so that
overlays with our Wetlands permits and
there are various requirements in the
Army Corp permits that would would not
or potentially would not allow for uh
exactly a 60-day time frame but they're
you know barring that and it's really
educating folks on
what what are the requirements from the
federal government and how can we
incorporate those maybe earlier in the
process uh you know and and and then do
our state our state process and get that
to a 60-day time frame and that's what
we're really looking at is how can we
get the state of New Hampshire's process
whether that's um you know I know
fishing game is looking at their
processed with threatened endangered uh
species we're looking at how we can get
our our Wetlands process to be a little
bit more efficient uh to get that down
to a 60-day time frame or alter of
terrain we we're looking at that as well
that's as I mentioned before that's
large development projects over most of
most of the permits are for over 100,000
square feet there are some caveats to
that um but we by and large I think
we'll be able to achieve something close
to that for our state processes now as I
mentioned there's a federal overlay on
some of our permits so that that's where
it might get a little tricky uh to get
there but uh you know it's something
that I I've been passionate about over
the years and and something that I'm
hopeful that we can with maybe new
technology or uh which we're we have
already invested in with some arpa funds
um and over the next few years we'll be
coming
online and you know a relook at the at
the state requirements how how can we
get there and maybe re maybe rearrange
things you know we don't want to reduce
Environmental Protection but how do we
rearrange the process to be more
efficient for the applicant and and
easier for them to interface with the
agency and so that's something we we
we've historically done but we're we're
giving we're taking another crack at it
if you will um followup go ahead thank
you
um you didn't specifically mention
biosolids which are rearing its ugly
head in New Hampshire specifically for
PS um what kind of an impact do you see
um biosolid management be having going
forward it's certainly something that
we're looking at you know we're we're
we're assessing that at at at the
department you know we uh some states
have banned L land application for
biosolids that's that's not something
that we're looking at at this time but
we are looking at what what the
appropriate regulations would be on that
and I know that the EPA is also looking
at at that from a science science
standpoint and you know we're kind of
work we're working with them the office
of research and development to figure
out what that what that should look like
in the state of New Hampshire um you
know I think we as I mentioned before we
try to balance the needs of a strong
strong economy with with envir
Environmental Protections and making
sure that those things go hand inand so
I think we're we're really hesitant to
do uh any sort of ban but we we are
looking at it from what what are the
what's the science say the right
requirements are and so um you know we I
don't know I have rainy peler here who
was who's in our Water Division I don't
know if if you want to elaborate on that
at
all good morning for the record rainy
peler I'm the director of The Water
Division yeah biosolids is actually I
was just at a meeting with EPA and other
folks last week biosolids is clearly an
issue that we're concerned about we find
in New Hampshire a lot of people aren't
interested in land spreading anymore
just because of the liabilities so I
think this is going to have to be
something that is certainly a focal po
point on a New England wide basis you
know biosolids every Water and
Wastewater Plant generate biosolids as
you well know so there's going to have
to be some sort of strategy on a new
england-wide basis it's it's just not a
New Hampshire problem it's an every
state problem uh at this meeting I was
at New York was there as well so the
problem is you can't just ban
biosolids if you don't treat Water and
Wastewater that would be fine you
wouldn't have any biosolids so that's
going to be a major focal point in the
upcoming year because it's I know in our
Basin winaki River Basin plant our bios
sols are trucked away and the cost of
that Trucking went from 200,000 a year
to 400,000 and it was going to
Pennsylvania so when you think about
what are we going to do here in the
future and Maine doesn't accept any
biosolid so um it's going to be a real
you uh yes uh representative uh scheler
scheller thank you that's okay it's hard
to get it the first time uh thank you uh
and thank you for this presentation this
is great you had alluded to a uh $3
million to establish a climate action
plan I was just wonder is that a study
uh has that been initiated completed
where does that where are you in that
process so it's a it's an EPA Grant from
so it's a grant from EPA it's $3 million
and we are sort of in the midst of that
right we had our priority EPA had a they
kind of did this out of order they had a
priority climate action plan which was
really short-term things that we could
do we focused on you know existing
funding those those sorts of things and
that was really to get us ready to apply
for what what the under the IRA is the
uh implementation grants for for uh
initiatives that would reduce greenhouse
gas emissions and so that informed our
application for that we submitted uh
three different applications we had a
state specific one uh we had one uh
Coalition application with Hawaii and
several other states and then we
submitted a third one which was a
coalition application with the New
England all of the New England states
excluding Vermont and uh EPA announced
last year that they would be funding a
four it's a $450
million uh Grant to the the third one
for heat pump adoption in the region so
it accelerate heat pump adoption for um
whether it in it's for businesses and
for uh homeowners ERS and it's likely
going to be a mid-level incentive type
program um we're still developing a lot
of the details around that at this at
this point um New Hampshire is expected
to receive 40 to 45 million at least
from that program um and again we're
still we we're still developing those
details and so the that those are the
first two parts and then the third part
which is why I said they kind of did it
out order is now we're doing some uh
it's a long longer term plan it's called
the comprehensive climate action plan
and what we've chosen to do is focus on
voluntary measures that industry could
industry could adopt and how can we
provide some sort of technical
assistance or or assistance to those
Industries to help uh get them to that
point where they would be able to adopt
various measures um so that's that so
that's sort of the the summary of of
where we're at at this point on that and
that's slated to be submitted to EPA in
December of
2025 thank you
y representative poi
thank you Vice chair and thank you
commissioner um going with the air
resources air monitoring other than uh
the federal Clean Air Act do you do
other monitoring of heavy metals radio
isotopes and the second part do you take
in information from universities or
private organizations that do do the
monitoring on particulates thank you I'd
like to invite uh some probably CRA
Craig Wright from our area Resources
Division to answer that he's going to
have a lot more information for you on
that subject uh thank you Craig Wright
I'm the director of the air division uh
we do we operate a network of 13
monitoring sites across the state uh we
work very closely with EPA on deciding
what we monitor for and where we monitor
for it um we don't do we do monitor for
a particular matter and we do have some
filters but we don't analyze those
filters so we don't actually look at
certain things that you mentioned like
radio isotop or anything like
that okay uh is there uh do you have
other speakers coming to give up
presentation we we do so so perhaps we
should move on and we can ask questions
to those people as well so absolutely
and I'm happy to Do's always open if you
need anything uh feel free to reach out
to me directly so and I'll be here for
the majority of the presentation so okay
thank so so who's next uh I have Corey
Clark here with the dam Bureau Mr Clark
welcome
thank you community members once again
my name is Corey Clark I'm the chief
engineer at the dam Bureau at the New
Hampshire Department of Environmental
Services and while this
um this presentation I'm about to give
gives a general overview of the dam
Bureau at the State of New Hampshire
what we do uh the various sections um
you'll see sprinkled throughout there is
some um hits on hydrop power I know
Granite State hydrop power is is uh
slated on the agenda to speak after so
they'll probably get into more of the
details but I'll be focusing probably
primarily on state-owned dams that are
leased for hydrop power and how that um
how that plays into how we actually
operate so just kicking things off here
this is actually um the hydropower
generator unit at Kelly's Falls Dam
you'll see later in the presentation
this is one of the the sites in which um
we no longer have a hydr power operator
there
um because of uh Federal requirements
for fist passage at this location and so
Dees is now um operating the dam however
hydrop power is not being produced there
and so what we're trying to do is go
through various federal grants to try to
actually install fish passage at this
location but the $13 million price tag
to do so is is quite High given the
revenue that this generator would return
so um you'll see as I mentioned before
this is topic is kind of sprinkled
throughout the presentation so getting
going uh what exactly is a dam in New
Hampshire as we've kind of discussed
already uh there are various purposes
for dams however here in New Hampshire
uh generally anything over 6 feet in
height and in pounds water uh is
essentially a dam there are some nuances
such as the storm water basins um but
generally that is what we have here in
New Hampshire and as um the assistant
commissioner broke down there are high
Hazard dams those are threat of human
life significant Hazard dams uh High
Economic Consequences however likely not
a loss of life such as a state road over
topping low Hazard dams those are um
property loss uh not as high Economic
Consequences such as uh Town Road being
inundated and in damage and then we also
have non- Menace dams so the vast
majority of the 2600 dams in New
Hamshire are non- Menace dams those are
dams such that if they were to fail
generally uh they wouldn't cause any
property loss or any damage to any other
infrastructure
Downstream so the dam breau was broken
up into three different sections we have
the dam safety and inspection section
the operation and maintenance section
and the engineering construction section
and I'll go into each in a little detail
here so the dam safety and inspection
section is responsible for the
inspection and permitting of over 2600
privately and publicly owned dams in New
Hampshire so as you can see in this
figure here these are dams sprinkled all
throughout the state of New Hampshire um
and what what that Dam safety and
inspection section is they treat all
dams the same such as any public private
municipally owned dams um are all
treated the same and so even when I have
to do a uh Dam reconstruction process
that that that permitting application
still goes through the dam safety and
inspection section for permitting and we
also have to pay the annual Dam
registration fees and other things that
every other Dam owner has to do um here
in New Hampshire the state of New
Hampshire is the the largest dam owner
in the
state so we also work closely with uh
the Attorney General's office on any
enforcement actions um that come from
any delinquent Dam owners and then we
also work really closely with the
Federal Energy Regulatory Commission so
throughout the entire country hydr power
dams are regulated by uh FK and so they
they do all the the permitting
inspection and oversight of all those
structures however we work closely with
them on all their inspections so this
top photo here is actually inside the
PowerHouse in Amis in Manchester and so
we we work closely with them because
there are dams such as that Kelly's
Falls Dam in which it was regulated by
FK once the hydrop power went away FK
went away now it is regulated by the
state of New Hampshire so we we work
closely with them to make sure we know
what's going on in the state then we
move on to the operation and maintenance
section who are responsible for
operating 28 of those 276 State owners
dams those 208 are primarily made up of
dams owned by uh Department of
Environmental Services there's roughly
111 of those and then the remaining 97
are owned by New Hampshire fishing game
so we take care of all um fishing game
and Dees owned dams so that's everything
from opening the gates to let water out
pulling stop logs to let water out to uh
mowing brush cutting replacement of
gates things of that nature however that
inventory does include a lot of the big
lakes that we know in here in the state
such as lake wabaki lake winnisquam
Squam Lake Newfound lake lake sopy lake
oopi and several others all throughout
the
state the operation of Maintenance
section also provides real-time lake
level and temperature and precipitation
data at 31 Lakes throughout New
Hampshire so you can see here on this
slide we have gauging stations at many
of those Lakes including also additional
gauging data that's provided by the uh
us Geological Service that data is
pulled in and this website is a free
platform for anybody to use um
throughout the um throughout the public
so uh anybody can tap into that and take
a look to see what's happening in their
Watershed the the section is also
responsible for managing eight leases
those are dams that are leased to
hydropower entities we don't actually
operate the hydrop power portion of
those dams ourselves we actually lease
that out such as I mentioned at Kelly's
Falls you'll see in your packet it
actually says nine dams I'm sorry about
that there so um we actually that
Kelly's Falls Dam recently this summer
um transferred to us so that's that that
wasn't reflected in in your packet but
it is eight dams and then we have 26
water user agreements so Downstream
hydropower entities actually pay for a
portion of the water that's released
from those sites so amamos that I
mentioned earlier pays a portion of the
water that actually comes out of Lake
Newfound Squam Lake and lake winaki so
we get a small bit of income from that
and then the engineering construction
section is responsible for all
state-owned dams so that's 276 dams uh
throughout the state so that's managing
contracts budgets design of those re
repair projects and you can see here um
it's everywhere from right on the Sea
Coast to the Southern Tier of the state
all the way up to uh um the tip of the
state right up on the Canadian border so
we we inhouse have our own land
management section that op that oversees
all easements ownership records
everything else a lot of these dams were
built well over 100 years ago and so and
a lot of them were transferred to the
state of New Hampshire in the 1950s and
60s prior to that the state of New
Hampshire uh owned very very little uh
dams as far as a number and so a lot of
the dams the 276 were actually
transferred to the state through Public
Service of New Hampshire other uh Mills
and um they were formerly used for power
production but as they transferred into
recreational use they then transferred
to the
state so that engineering construction
section we have our own in-house
construction crew this photo here is
them working at uh cops pond in
Tuftonboro doing a repair project at a
high Hazard fishing game Dam and we also
um prepare emergency action plans for
all the high and significant Hazard dams
so the state of New Hampshire owns 64
High Hazard dams and 34 significant
Hazard dams so we are responsible for
all the emergency action plans should
there be a failure at one of those dams
knowing what would happen
Downstream so jumping over to State
owner hydr power
um like I mentioned earlier the state of
New Hampshire owned very little dams in
the in the first part of the 1900s it
was really in the 1950s and 60s that
this a lot of these dams were
transferred to the
state in absorbing such a high inventory
of dams there became challenges really
um right right as soon as those
transfers occurred and so trying to
figure out how are we actually going to
fund having all of these dams and so in
the 1970s and ' 880s there was a lot of
um there was a lot of incentives for
hydropower Redevelopment and so a lot of
hydr power is developed at that time
through Federal incentives and the state
looked at several of their own sites and
actually looked at developing hydr power
there and so um under RSA 418 we've been
leasing those sites um I'll get into uh
how those numbers have dropped but since
the see in 1980s we've been leasing
sites that's been generating Revenue
into the dam maintenance fund and that
Revenue has been used for the operation
of maintenance and repair of state-owned
dams and so this photo right here is the
hydropower Dam at Lakeport which is the
the dam at the outlet of lake winaki in
downtown
lonia so in 1993 when things were uh
when a lot of the leases were up and
running and doing well we we were
leasing 12 dams throughout the state and
it was kind of scattered throughout we
had we had several dams on the winaki
river dams on the bcat quag River um Pon
took up on the Androgen and so these
these were dams that were uh released at
that time for funding the uh repair and
maintenance of state-owned dams and at
that time it was it was able to cover
most of the needs uh of all the repairs
however since then we've actually lost
four of those so we've lost a third of
uh a third of those sites are no longer
producing hydrop power um Kelly's Falls
being the one that most recently stopped
proding hydrop power and while we've
lost amps our our income has increased
over time primarily because a lot of
these hydropower entities not only are
selling the power and their their their
revenue from sales have have been very
very stagnant since um deregulation took
place in the early 2000s however
renewable energy credits and other
incentives have helped kind of keep them
afloat and keep them going and so we
have seen we still get revenue from from
our leases
um however hasn't kept up with inflation
um since since 1993 and certainly
doesn't cover the needs that we have
today so a little bit of a breakdown of
how we are funded and so on average we
spend a little over $7 million a year
and generally it's broken down into um
Dam safety gets a A little over
$600,000 uh from Dam registration fees
and some FEMA grants uh general fund is
pretty much primarily used for all our
Dam operations so those gentlemen going
out there opening Gates making sure that
things are safe during flood that's all
general fund um positions and those so
we get about a million from that um
water user project accounts so those are
the hydr powers that hydrop power
producers that pay uh for the water
being released a little over half a
million dollars that we get from that
towards Dam operations and then uh
annually we see roughly $3 to4 million
in capital funds for Dam
reconstruction and then we have a little
less than half a million is spent on the
uh Dam maint through the dam maintenance
fund for Dam construction and then we
also have been lucky as as the assistant
commissioner pointed out we have um we
were able to tap into roughly about $30
million of arpa funds for the repair and
reconstruction of state-owned dams and
we have several projects going on right
now so we have some federal funds and
then really uh little over a million 1.1
million of General funds is used for the
administration of program so looking at
a in a whole it's about a little over $5
million is uh all general fund and
capital fund to to uh run the pro
program and then roughly over $2 million
in other F funding so that such as the
hydropower Revenue such as any other
grants is used so we're looking at about
$7.5 million needed
annually however when we look at the
actual needs of state-owned dams so we
have 64 High Hazard dams to bring all
those dams up to current standards and
put them on the 50-year cycle as the
assistant commissioner mentioned we'd be
looking at about $300 million in
expenses and then you have 34
significant Hazard dams another 54
million 80 low Hazard dams another 54
million and the 98 non- menacing exempt
dams 6 million the reason you see the
numbers the the the the cost per Dam
drop is because a non- menace Dam what
that Dam needs to meet is much much less
than a high Hazard Dam as far as
stability as far as discharge as far as
uh flood protection things of that
nature but so you're looking at roughly
about a $414 million cost to bring all
the state-owned dams up to current
standards and this was backed up by a
recent study done by the Association of
State Dam safety officials in which they
determined that it would be about $990
million to bring all dams in New
Hampshire up to current
standards so when you look at that need
and you you think about over the next 50
years trying to bring all the dams into
compliance we'd be looking at a need of
about $16 million annually in order to
meet that Target goal of making sure all
dams in New Hampshire are um being
repaired or replaced on a 50-year
interval and this project right here is
goose pond dam up in Canan this is an
ongoing project this is a 6 A5 million
project that is funded by arpa funds and
so you'll see a little bit more about
this project
throughout and as I mentioned earlier
and this actually these photos right
here are of Goose Pond the original
Construction in 1918 and then
construction recently um the average age
of state- owned dams is well over 100
years as I mentioned earlier a lot of
these dams were all built for uh either
um Mill purposes or uh or storage for
Downstream Mills such as Goose Pond this
this dam was originally built to power
uh Mills Downstream on the masoma river
all the way down through Enfield and and
Lebanon however in the 1950s the
ownership transferred to the state of
New Hampshire and so a lot of these dams
haven't been renovated in over 40 or 50
years and so we're looking at a lot of
deferred maintenance and trying to catch
up to make sure that these dams can meet
current
standards Hazard creep so 35 of the 64
High Hazard dams were reclassified over
the past 20 years
so back in uh 2004 we were looking at an
inventory of 34 um High Hazard Dam so
now we have 64 and the reason for that
is really Downstream development and
Advent computer modeling that I'll get
into a little bit more but you can see
here O Lake all those homes are actually
within the the the uh 100-year FEMA
flood plane so this is not the
inundation map of what what happen
should the damn breach but this is just
showing the number of homes that are
within the 100-year FEMA flood plane and
so it becomes a real challenge when
we're trying to discharge water
particularly like last July or I'm sorry
the July 2023 in which we had a lot of
water all throughout the state and we
had to actually hold water back at a a
lot of the Lakes because if we were
increasing discharge we would have been
flooding people out for example I know
there was one home Downstream of uh Lake
W winnisquam in which we had water up to
the basement window I think for about a
Out Mr Vice
chair can we hold our questions and this
is specific to that graph I just want to
understand it okay one short question
yeah the little yellow circles what are
those those are the homes homes okay
thank
you so as I mentioned earlier uh the
other reason for we're seeing more and
more High Hazard dams and more and more
need is because we're starting to really
dive into uh how deficient these dams
are it was one of the one of the things
that we we had with the arpa money is we
were able to spend it on a lot of
studies and really dive into our high
Hazard Dam inventory and what we found
is that a lot of these dams are
deficient in the amount of water they
can discharge so if we had an event like
what happened in North Carolina this
year a lot of those dams cannot
discharge the volume of water of an
event of that magnitude also we also
found that a lot of those dams during an
event of that magnitude would either
slide or overturn remember once again
these dams were built in the 1800s there
are dams in which we've renovated in
which we're still finding the original
Timber down at the bottom of the dam in
the foundation with granite block on top
so it doesn't take much to move these
dams when you have storms of that
magnitude so then we look at Dam removal
you know how can we lower that inventory
we certainly have a list of dams that
we're trying to get rid of but every
time we bring that up it becomes a real
challenge with the local communities
some of you may be familiar with the
challenges we've had in the in on the
bcat quag River with the towns of gtown
in Manchester the issue there is all
three of these dams that you see here
produced hydrop power in 1993 only one
of those dams now produces Hydro power
Greg's Falls the other two no longer do
we lost Kelly's Falls that the hydrop
power producer this summer because of uh
Federal requirements for fist passage
Hadley Falls Dam hasn't produced hydrop
power since 2007 that dam is just the
economics just do not work out to uh to
produce hydrop power there and also um
operate that Dam because one thing we
have the benefit of the leases is that
when it's leased out that lease e is
responsible for all the operation of
Maintenance and compliance at that Dam
so it takes the burden off the
state so over the this past summer um
the committee to study alternative for
funding and operation and maintenance
ofair of state-owned dams um convened
under uh SB 549 that was pass last year
and they looked at um these different
Revenue sources and the challenges that
we have and these are just two two
comments that came out of the committee
from this past summer in light of
Nationwide incidents in light of recent
storms and in light of imminent Revenue
challenges the committee finds a prudent
that a stable consistent mechanism to
furnish the Department of Environmental
Services with sufficient monies for the
operation maintenance and repair of
State own dams be established the
committee does not find the current
arrangement to be sustainable nor in the
best interest of local communities
recreational beneficiaries or future
budgets and so because of those findings
they they dove into you know who's who
benefits the most out of these sites um
they looked at everything from
recreational users to Downstream users
and really the committee came that the
the real beneficiaries are the people
that live around those impoundments
because if that Dam wasn't there they
would not have that Waterfront at the
level it is that they that they enjoy
certainly recre recreational uses such
as boers kayakers fishermen yes they
would be impacted if that dam was lost
but there's many other water bodies
throughout the state of New Hampshire
that don't have dams and in most cases
the dam would still be present how I
mean the the body of water would still
be present even if the dam was removed
the level of water would just drop so in
the case of Lake winaki it would drop
probably anywhere from 8 to 12 feet if
if Lakeport dam was removed and and as
far as Downstream users go certainly
those people are um are affected by the
dam Upstream but they're affected
because of the risks that that Dam poses
on their property if the dam was removed
that risk nine times out of 10 would
actually go away they would be in a
better circumstance if that Dam wasn't
there to start with so they looked at
all those different things and came up
with that $158 per linear footage sh
line so if you own property on a body of
water in which the state of New
Hampshire owns an a dam on that body of
water you'd be assessed that that fee
that fee would generate roughly $7.5
million of Revenue towards the operation
repair and maintenance of state-owned
dams and in order to actually manage
such a program we looked at what what it
would actually take and it would it
would likely take another half a million
dollar of Revenue to make sure that we
can manage that so instead of tacking
that on to the Shoreline owner the
committee chose to make the
recommendation of a $5 increase in boter
registration fees that would generate uh
roughly about half million doll in order
for the Department of Environmental
Services to manage such a
program all of that has been um put into
LSR
202-6356 committee this past summer was
you know so what if we got rid of these
dams what would it actually look like
and how would it be impacted and this
kind of goes to the shorefront uh folks
so you can see here this is mum's pond
dam this was uh actually reconstructed
partially by uh the dam Bureau in 2016
and so you can see satellite photos of
before and during Reconstruction that
dam was um the water was lowered about
20 ft during that process so you can see
the difference there and the loss of
that Shoreline and um that dam is
actually going through another
40045 million renovation using arpa
summer going back to goosepond Dam as I
mentioned before this one's currently
under construction so we have a lot of
good photos on on this this this
impoundment also has dropped about 20 ft
and it's it's it's roughly about when
it's full it's about 625 Acres there's
roughly 20 uor sorry 200 homes around
the impoundment I know there's a lot of
devel elent going on on the western
shore right now so that number will
certainly increase but through these
next couple of slides kind of
demonstrate if we either remove these
dams or if we ran into a circumstance in
which the risk was too great and we had
to lower the risk and open the gates and
let the water out that's the only way we
can reduce the risk at these dams unlike
Bridges we can't simply just close the
dam we have to actually reduce the risk
so we have to remove the water and there
are dams out there uh quite few uh quite
many that have have either wooden gates
or infrastructure that hold back the
water that really need to be renovated
you know pakway Lake for example uh has
a wooden gate that's been there for over
40 years that's 20 ft below the water
surface if that wooden gate was to fail
any day of the year that Lake would be
lost and obviously impacts to the
residents and uh pway Lake State Park so
these are the next couple photos just
showing the shoreline um when these
bodies of water are
lowered go Pond being one in which uh
the reason it was filled so high was for
that additional storage for the
purposes and you can see here some of
the original stumps that were there
prior to the impoundment actually being
filled and obviously those those
Shoreline residents have certainly been
impacted over the past of the course of
the past year and so we're doing
everything we can to try to get that
pond ref filled for them and uh and
their enjoyment so with that I know was
kind of rushed through but I will
certainly answer any questions I I I
would dearly love to and it's an
important and serious um uh uh topic but
we TimeWise um we we need to move on
right now for the our air division uh
because after all the air division is
one that's most prevalent to this
particular committee if we have time
afterwards or if you want to come back
later on I think this a really a serious
topic it would be of interest for us to
know I'm sure some of those bills may be
going through the other committee on
resources and Recreation but that was
excellent and I think it was um quite
enlightening to know the full extent of
our our our damn issues and uh so thank
you so much for that I'd like to invite
the Mr fisherald are are you next or
whoever both you okay fine please come
forward we have until 10:30 but we'll uh
we may have some leeway uh but please
brief on the probably the most prevalent
portion of the to our committee here so
thank you again uh Craig Wright I serve
as the Director at the air Resources
Division uh I've been with Dees since I
think 1988 uh all that time within the
air division so and with me is Mike
Fitzgerald it's Mike Fitzgerald I'm the
assistant director in the air division
I've been with the if since uh the late
'90s and I'm a frequent flyer here at
the committee so you'll be seeing my
face uh for a number of pieces of
legislation coming up and also with us
is Katherine beam sitting behind me to
my right here behind me and she'll be
talking about past and air I'm going to
try to save a couple minutes at the end
for her because I know that was
something you requested uh this first
slide is just who our division
leadership team I'm not going to we are
limited on time so I'm going to jump
through some of these fairly quickly uh
the bottom line here is if you need
anything from the air Resources Division
you can reach out to me or Mike or
anybody else on this
list structurally we have three bureaus
I want to go through each of those
bureaus a little bit so I'm not going to
focus too much on that right now um but
also we have within the director's
office not only do we manage the
division do the budgeting uh personel
and stuff like that uh we also do some
technical things within the director's
office and we'll hit on those as
well just a brief overview um in
addition to the state laws and I have a
list of those coming up shortly uh Ard
implements the vast majority of federal
Clean Air Act programs and one of the
most important one of them we've already
talked about earlier a little tiny bit
is uh the air monitoring program uh we
also issue all state and federal air
permits so if you need a an air permit
under the federal Clean Air Act you come
to Dees you don't have to go to EPA Ard
has 12 sets of rsas that we Implement
and we have 38 Uh current chapters of
State administrative rules and as Mike
likes to always point out we don't just
make rules up all of our rules are
founded in some State Statute or federal
requirement so uh We've also adopted
hundreds of federal what we call new
source performance standards or national
emissions hazardous air pollution
standards and emission guidelines these
are programs that EPA implements across
the country but we adopt them here in
New Hampshire and put them into our air
permits and we can enforce those Federal
standards as well Staffing wise we have
65 full-time staff we currently have
about 11 vacancies We are Never Fully St
staff I think every state agency will
tell you that uh we have a lot of
Engineers a lot of scientists uh couple
life science atmospheric science Health
Sciences and we even have a couple
attorneys on
staff this is just a list of all of the
statutes that we're involved in again I
I'm not going to hit all of these I'll
just hit a couple of the big ones RSA
125c that's where the air Resources
Division gets our general Authority our
permit program is established there our
inspections and enforcement programs are
also coming out of uh that statute I
will point out RSA 125i New Hampshire
does have a state air toxics program we
regulate over 600 different air toxics
we've established health-based standards
for those compounds EPA also regulates
air toxics but they're they do it more
from a technology standpoint they
require certain levels of controls or
types of controls depending upon the
industry whereas we are looking at
what's the health impact of those toxics
so those programs actually complement
opinion uh one thing we know about air
pollution is it knows no political
boundaries so one of the things we work
a lot is with other states around us and
the biggest group we we we interact with
is what we call nescom northeast states
coordinated air use management uh this
is the six New England states New York
New Jersey all of my counterparts and
myself we serve on the board of
directors for nescom and nescom is a
tremendous resource for the northeast
states they are incredibly technically
capable and we rely on them for a lot of
support and uh we pay a small amount of
annual fee to them uh and we certainly
uh annual dues to them and we certainly
get our money's worth out of them the
only other one I'm going to point out
here is you can read um is the ozone
transport commission that is established
under the federal Clean Air Act and that
includes States from um Maine all the
way down to Virginia and again uh
there's a board of directors for that
and we participate quite actively in the
commission again I won't go through all
these just to try to save time but uh
one thing as an agency we take great
pride in is we work a lot with other
state agencies across state government
and I think we do a great job there we
have well long-term established
relationships with these different state
agencies uh regarding different things
that we may overlap with them a little
bit on or we have common interest in so
again I'm not going to go through all
those just to save some time um but I I
I do think that New Hampshire is a small
government and I think we actually
interact really nicely with each
other in terms of funding we're heavily
reliant on fees our our fees cover about
half of our operating budget and this
includes air permit fees from our
regulated stationary sources as best as
fees and we get a small amount of mobile
Source fees uh Prime when folks get your
car inspected uh when a station issues a
inspection sticker the Resources
Division gets a quarter of that fee so
we get about
$325,000 a year so a quarter out of yes
yes yes thank you Mike we get 2 cents 25
cents per inspection sticker so that
helps support our mobile Source programs
uh including our on board diagnostics
program we're heavily Reliant also on
federal funding that's about 38% of our
funding um unfortunately this has been
largely stagnant uh Through The Years um
and what I could buy back in 1990 with a
million dollars I certainly can't buy
that today so we've actually seen the
number of positions we support with
federal funds decrease over time uh we
used to have 17 18 20 positions now
we're around 12 positions so and then
General funds we only get about uh six%
of our budget we only have four
positions that are generally funded
here's two of them right here so if
you're looking for cuts this is
obviously where you go first and
then and then we also have uh uh two
technical positions in our en
enironmental health program toxicologist
position and a health risk assessor
position and those positions were
largely created a couple years ago to
help the agency deal with the past
situation um the most important thing on
this slide I'm going to mention
is air quality is really it's it's not
just about the environment it's about
the economy as well one of the things
that EPA does is they sets air quality
standards nationally and it's up to
states to Monitor and maintain
compliance with those air quality
standards if we don't meet those
standards then we have to develop a lot
of programs to make sure we come into
compliance with those programs and that
usually means regulations on our Smoke
Stack Industries regulations uh to help
reduce emissions and we've done a really
good job balancing the need of meeting
that environmental standards but also
recognizing that there is an economic
impact to what we do go ahead
Mike again the federal Clean Air Act
that really serves as the backdrop for a
lot of what we do as an agency um EPA
one of the EPA this is the fundamental
part of our program EPA establishes what
they call National ambient air quality
standards for these pollutants listed
here historically ozone has been our
biggest pollutant of concern here in New
Hampshire um EPA is required to review
these standards every five years I will
say they don't they don't usually meet
that but uh they do they do their best
to to meet that schedule uh when they
adopt a new standard then it's up the
state has to go through a process to
demonstrate where are we in compliance
standard again the most important thing
on this slide is is this concept of
non-attainment that's when you don't
meet those Federal health-based air
quality standards right now New
Hampshire is in attainment with all of
the national ambient air quality
standards that's good for New Hampshire
but it doesn't mean we can just suddenly
let our foot off the gas pedal we're in
what we call a maintenance mode um under
the Clean Air Act is antib sliding
Provisions that basically says once you
get into attainment you need to maintain
programs in place such that you continue
to maintain your entertainment status so
that's a lot of what we're in right now
is M maintenance of of these various
meeting these
standards uh everybody every year we
come here has interest in our air
monitoring program I wish we could do
more air monitoring air monitoring is
extremely expensive cost effective wise
um it takes a lot of manpower to run we
have 13 sites across the state we
literally monitor from the top of Mount
Washington down the Connecticut River
Valley across our Southern Tier the Sea
Coast Area and up through the marac
river valley as I like to call it we
don't monitor for all those pollutants
at every one of these stations we have
to work with EPA to determine where we
Monitor and what we monitor for some of
these monitors are kind of early warning
lights for us like in Lebanon that gives
us an indication what may be coming over
the border from Vermont or coming from
our West
as we all know weather moves across the
country from the West that's where our
air pollution comes from too sometimes
so I would also note that we have a one
air monitoring station adjacent to our
office up on Hazen drive if anyone ever
wanted to come see one and also on top
of Pacman adok is an extremely uh uh
nice station to it's one of our our uh
Premier stations in terms of of all the
pollutants that we measure it's called
an incore station we're one two sites in
the country so if you're ever up on top
of Pacman adock I know representative o
is great hiker and uh we'd welcome you
to come visit us there as
well and I will just add um this is the
where we spend the bulk of our federal
money is on our air monitoring program
um we at least half of our federal
positions are dedicated to running the a
monitoring program um one of the
challenges we always face is up
upgrading and replacing equipment a lot
of our equipment is old and Antiquated
uh held together by some magic I think
sometimes
but but we've we've been investing as
best we can as a state agency uh
historically we've used a little bit of
capital funds to invest in monitoring
program um but it's always a challenge
keeping all these stations up and
running this is just some pictures of
our monitoring sites these are usually
stick built uh structures um I won't
spend much time other than uh they're
again they're neat to go to if you
really if you take a tour sometime you
you you'll be impressed with what we
have inside
this so just in terms of air quality in
New Hampshire ozone historically has
been our largest regulatory driver this
is uh summertime uh pollutant a lot of
what we deal with in New Hampshire is
the transport coming into New Hampshire
again that's why we play in some of
those clubs we do play in to help uh
regulate the transport of ozone into the
into the area fine particular matter
usually this is tradition recently been
a wintertime issue primarily in our
Valley areas Kean is always our post the
child uh Kean is perfectly seed within a
bowl and dur you get inversions in the
winter and you get wood smoke build up
but I will say we've done two wood stove
change Out programs in the keen and
Chester County area and since we've done
them we have seen an improvement in air
quality in the Kean area for find
particular matter one thing new we're
seeing and uh whether you think it's
related to the climate or not but
Canadian wildfires are becoming a big
bigger and bigger issue every year uh we
have seen impacts into Northeast United
States uh New Hampshire has not we've
made out okay we've had some impacts but
nothing like you've seen on the news
like in New York and Delaware and
Pennsylvania we were just lucky I think
that that didn't quite make it this far
east it was due to a weather pattern
believe it or not and then Regional
Hayes this is just visibility in our
class one areas New Hampshire has two uh
class one areas up in up in the northern
mountains of New Hampshire these are
special areas under the federal Clean
Air Act
and we need to work towards restoring
visibility in those those Scenic Vistas
to what they call Background conditions
by 2064 I'm pretty sure I will not be
so just real uh quickly I get asked what
is the air quality in New Hampshire and
this chart I think is the best way to
present it uh the each one of these does
our counties in New Hampshire our 10
counties and then our high elevation
sites green indicates good air quality
and we have good air quality about 90%
of the time about 10% of the time we
have what we call moderate air quality
where really really sensitive people may
start to see um some impacts from from
those pollutants and then we have a
handful of days a year five to 10
primarily ozone in the summer sometimes
PM in the winter um where we hit levels
that are called unhealthy for sensitive
groups what we saw a couple last year or
the year before with the Wildfire smoke
in New York City was actually at a level
three levels above that unhealthy for
sensitive groups so uh that's we
certainly don't want that in New
Hampshire but if it comes there's not
much we can do to stop it but we do have
plans in place we've worked with the
Department of Public Health Services to
develop uh messaging for the public if
we get into those types of
situations thankfully we haven't had to
do it so um this ozone Trends across New
Hampshire this is a a a success story in
our opinion the red line represents that
National ambient air quality quity
standard as you can see EPA does change
that on occasion as you can see it
always goes down these standards never
become less restrictive they always
become more restrictive as we understand
better understand the impacts of uh air
pollution but again as you can see uh
we've seen a long-term downward Trend in
our ozone levels across the state you
saw a real drop in 2020 2021 can you all
tell what was going on then covid right
people weren't driving as much Factory
output was down and air quality actually
saw that across the country so kind of
unique um just real quick um again I'm
going to jump really quick on some of
these we our atmospheric science and
Analysis unit this is the group that
helps support uh all of our past
modeling our permit modeling um they
also work a lot with uh required to
we're required to do periodic
inventories of all of our missions
across our various sectors and we have
to report that to EPA and this group
also runs our pams monitoring sites um
we have two of them in New Hampshire
that's very specialized monitoring that
monitors for precursors of ozone so Mike
you can change
that um Kathy runs our supplementation
planning rulemaking I can't underscore
the importance of this group to the air
Resources Division uh as I mentioned a
lot of what we do comes out of the Clean
Air Act we need to submit plans to EPA
we need to maintain those plans we need
to have approval from EPA on those plans
and this is the group that helps
accomplish all that there group overse
also oversees our state rulemaking
process and then you can see the other
things that this group does as
well our a permit program again I'm just
going to mention real quickly we have
about 700 permited sources in New
Hampshire we have just I think around 28
what they call major sources these are
Title 5 sources they're federally
required to have permits but again you
don't need to go to EPA to get those
permits you come to the Resources
Division as we maintain a fully approved
uh Title Five permit program we
typically get about 120 permit
applications a year you may recall last
year there was a bill Senate Bill 449
that changed the time frames for the
quickness of which air Resources
Division needs to issue permits uh we
had originally asked for 180 days under
that we got 120 days working with Bia uh
we're now implementing that we are
finding some challenges to meet that 120
days largely because we're so short
staff we're about half staffed in our
permit program right now due to
retirements and folks leaving for other
um I can you can skip that
one so just real quick our environmental
health program uh this is a program that
sits within the air Resources Division
but it it serves all of Dees it it does
health risk assessments it looks at
toxicology um and it helps uh support
not only the air division the Water
Division the waste Division I and we'll
you can move on from that too
Mike we can just skip over this for now
just to save time just our compliance
Bureau this is our folks out in the
field were required under uh compliance
monitoring strategy with EPA to conduct
certain numbers of inspections every
year these are the folks that are out in
the field doing those inspections we
inspect all sources at least once during
the permit term so that's once every
five years all those major sources I
mentioned we inspect them every other
year so once every two years these are
the folks also we do we witness about 80
stack tests a year uh we don't actually
do the testing but the air Resources
Division is on site for all compliance
tests in New Hampshire this is usually
the company that we're testing at would
go out and hire a third party contractor
but we oversee all of that testing and
we review all the results
so I think Mike's going to take over
from
here sure um as Craig mentioned our
Technical Services Bureau houses the air
monitoring program which we've already
discussed um we also address uh and I
have slides on number of these so I'll
go through uh mobile sources which is
air air pollution from cars trucks
anything that moves planes um
construction equipment lawn mowers
Etc um uh are all addressed we work
closely with regional planning agencies
in in the state to ensure that uh our
transportation plans are in compliance
with um uh the Clean Air Act
requirements um and we also house our
energy and climate programs and I'll get
into as the assistant commissioner crepo
mentioned the uh EPA planning and
implementation grants that we received
recently um we also work closely with
the Department of energy on implementing
the regional greenhouse gas initiative
and the renewable portfolio standards um
and every year and I don't think there's
any exception this year there are a
number of bills related to those Al I
think the Reggie bills are somewhat
limited this year but um uh we we do
work with the Department of energy in
implementing those programs um um we
also work closely with All State
agencies to try to reduce energy usage
in state agencies through a entity
called esek um uh and uh then uh we work
closely with the the p doe and pu on
energy issues energy and air pollution
generally go hand inand um and so we try
to uh work closely with them on those
programs mobile sources as I mentioned
Transportation Conformity is an EPA
program that requires that State's uh
Transportation plans not impair their
state air quality so uh we have to work
with DOT uh federal agencies Etc um this
used to be much more of a significant
problem for us but as Craig showed you
as the trends go down in New Hampshire
um we're generally able to uh address
these
requirements uh we do have the vehicle
maintenance and inspection program that
everyone loves affectionately the check
engine light on your your vehicle um
we're responsible for implementing that
through the EPA but we do work with the
Department of Safety and it's conducted
in conjunction with your uh regular
vehicle inspection and uh um as Craig
mentioned we do get a 25 cent fee for
each vehicle that's inspected to help
run that program and some of our other
mobile sources programs um we manage the
granite state Clean Cities Coalition
which is a department of energy program
to promote Alternative Energy uh fuel
usage uh in vehicles and we have about
145 stakeholders it's an extremely
successful program that we work with
mostly companies throughout the state
that have large fleets like ups and and
so on that uh and and we work with them
to help reduce their fuel usage and and
reduce demand for uh um conventional
fossil
fuels um the uh major Grant programs
that we're implementing right now in the
mobile sources group the de diesel
emission reduction act we receive about
600,000 in funding annually this is uh
program started probably 10 or 15 years
ago uh by Congress uh I think it was
intended to be sort of a short-term
one-time thing but uh it proved to be
extremely popular and they've continued
to fund it and uh and we Implement that
for replacing U uh older diesel engines
with newer cleaner um less polluting
engines and also you may have heard of
the Volkswagen uh cheat Scandal several
years ago that resulted in a major
federal settlement uh with EPA in the
state of California uh New Hampshire did
received 31 million uh in that
settlement we uh were able to uh put the
maximum allowed under that settlement
towards EV charging infrastructure 15%
of that um and we're in the process of
of putting those grants out
now um we're required to obligate 80% of
those funds by June of 2027 we're we're
well on track to do that um to date
we've committed 9 million um but we have
a number of programs that are in the way
in in process right now and we'll be
committing uh the vast majority of those
funds uh in the in the next year or two
so uh as the assistant commissioner
mentioned we did receive a $3 million
Grant from EPA for uh what's called the
climate pollution reduction grant
program uh we submit all the necessary
requirements that enabled us to apply
for the federal funding uh that that he
mentioned uh there was 4.6 billion doll
under the IRA to uh Implement uh
programs to address climate uh reducing
climate emissions we were successful in
securing the $450 million Grant um and
I'll speak about that in a moment uh
we're again as was mentioned we're in
the process of implementing the uh uh
CCAP comprehensive climate action plan
right now we held our kickoff last month
and actually today we're starting
stakeholder sessions on each of uh five
sectors that um uh you know
transportation and buildings and Etc
different different sectors that um uh
contribute to uh climate related
emissions and um so those events will be
occurring over the next few months we'll
take that in put uh and then we'll work
to to develop the uh uh plan that's
required under this and this was a
commitment uh to accept that $3 million
in funding and make us eligible for the
450 million um we're committed to to
implement this program as well uh the
heat pump accelerator program $450
million to five states uh that's a big
chunk of money and we are also getting
five states together to agree on any
thing um is pretty interesting and so
we're in the process of of doing that
coordination right now we have a very
aggressive timeline obviously we want to
get this money out the door and the uh
most significant majority of that will
go towards Midstream incentives uh for
uh heat pump installations so uh if you
wanted to buy heat pump your plumber or
your contractor or the the Home Depot or
whatever where you purchase that heat
pump they will have rebates that are
pre-applied you don't have to buy it
then uh use your money and then put in
money and so on those rebates will be
pre-applied and lower the price of of
heat pumps and U uh the intent is to uh
see over 500,000 heat pumps installed
the goal is to to incentivize over
500,000 heat pumps uh in the New England
region in the next uh next 10 years or
so um this money obviously won't pay for
all of that but um once we get it
accelerated bring the price down and um
we're hoping people start to see the
benefits and some of uh an additional
portion of the funds go into this
Innovation Hub which is uh geared toward
Advantage disadvantaged communities
low-income communities uh that that'll
be specific projects you know for
instance it might be taking a Manchester
housing authority building and and
putting heat pumps in there or something
but those would be specific targeted
projects and the resource Hub is to uh
promote education provide information to
Consumers and to share successes and how
to replicate what works very well for
instance the state of Maine has an
extremely successful program um the
numbers are actually staggering they're
one of the leaders in the country in
installation of heat pumps through an
organization called Efficiency Maine and
success um the regional Greenhouse get
representative it's just related to that
slide so I didn't want to let you get
away um so I I have been following the
heat pump the advance heat pump uh
funding and you said 500,000 heat pumps
is the goal for the region do we have a
number that we're thinking in terms of
installations that we're looking for in
New Hampshire because I know when you
look at the eia uh one of our greatest
relian in in the state of New Hampshire
is you know the housing sector for oil
and gas so heat pumps would be most
advantageous to us here I think um do do
you have a target for how many how many
we expect about 40 million uh 40 to 45
million of of that funding to flow to
the to New Hampshire yeah um and we uh
we haven't turned that into a specific
Target but if you generally
um with these type of federal programs
10% uh if if it goes to New England
we're we represent about 10% of New
England in terms of population demand
for fuel Etc and so on so of that
500,000 gold you know you know if you
just trans transpose that it would be
maybe 50,000 here in in New Hampshire uh
but again not all of those would be
funded by this program this is hopefully
this will spur Innovation and and get
people educated and and learn more about
adoption of heat pumps there's been a
lot of progress made in the technology
over the past few years and so um we're
you representative Kaplan apparently has
a
question thank you Mr chair uh and thank
you gentleman for coming in this morning
uh I'm just curious uh what your
thoughts are on you know the likelihood
of getting that money in the
implementation grants out the door and
you know what would happen if those if
that money stopped coming uh given the
the incoming administration's statements
to date yeah um uh these are funds that
came through the IRA so uh one of the
constraints obviously would be uh to to
eliminate These funds Congress would
have to act to do that um it wouldn't be
something that unilaterally the
administration would do um we've also
been working with the state of
Connecticut and they've been working
very closely with EPA one of the reasons
our timeline is so aggressive as to
actually get these funds enacted we're
very hopeful that the incoming
Administration uh you know this may not
be a high priority for them but um I I I
don't think it would be well received to
take funding away from from states that
have already got it that's going to go
there's going to be a lot of economic
incentive there's a lot of plumbers and
contractors and so on that will um
benefit from from these not just the the
homeowners that that receive them so
should generate a lot of economic
activity uh in in the region and so um
but EPA uh has been working to commit
the funds and get them uh Connecticut's
the lead Agency for the five states and
get those funds in the hands of
Connecticut and uh and then we're
working to get them out closely but uh I
I would not Hazard guess as to what what
the incoming Administration would do but
we're pretty hopeful that this will this
will continue to move forward and and it
would take an AC of Congress
representative R has a
question thank you Mr chair uh Mike you
just mentioned um the organization in in
Maine that has you said that been
extremely successful at
getting um incentivizing heat pumps out
there um efficiency main is that the
analog Main's analog to our New
Hampshire saves yeah it's actually um
actually our sist commission used to
work closely with them uh so but but I
it's it's a quasi Authority government
Authority program Vermont has a similar
program um so New Hampshire saves is is
the Consortium of the utilities but
efficiency main is actually kind of a
state agency um quasa public private
agency um and but they they receive
these funds they do receive they've been
implementing their program through the
use of regional greenhouse gas
initiative funds which I'll talk about
in a minute um so they've been around
for a while but they just happen to have
an extraordinarily successful program
and the way they manage it and and uh
and and get the funds out we we're
extremely impressed with with the work
that they've done I forget the numbers
but I think it's something on the order
of uh 20% of all heat pump water heaters
installed in the United States are in
Maine um it's it's it's staggering don't
quote me on that so M Mr chair I Mr
chair
yes I I am aware of the time as you I'm
sure you are we have about half a dozen
slides left would you like us to
continue yes solding through please
thank
you okay the regional greenhouse gas
initiative as I mentioned I don't think
there's too much legislation that we've
seen uh in the lsrs to date around the
program so we're going to give it a very
high level overview if there is
legislation we can do a lot more
detailed uh if if if anything comes up
but basically the Reggie States uh are
are the states from uh uh Maryland up to
Maine um some states have come in come
gone out uh at times and so on Virginia
uh was recently added there in
K uh limbo
status this yeah they they're facing uh
some Court decisions and so um but
basically it's the states that you see
here uh working together to reduce
greenhouse gas emissions from fossil
fueled power plants 25 megaw and greater
in the region um and this was a program
that started back in
2006 2007 um uh Governor Pataki from New
York reached out to all the New England
states and said what can we do to reduce
emissions and uh we got 10 states to do
something that um I frankly don't think
could happen happen again
today uh but uh uh we continue to to
work with them uh the way the program
works is you identify the covered
sources as I mentioned they're 25
megawatt power plants and greater um so
New Hampshire has uh four major sources
and uh you determine what the emissions
are from those plants you project what
the emissions will be in the future and
you set a cap um and that's why this is
called a cap and trade program you set a
cap on those emissions but under that
cap the facilities are free to uh buy
and sell allowances uh we create one
allowance for each ton of emissions so
if the cap is um for instance you know
10 million tons then we would create 10
million allowances among all of the
states that are participating those
allowances then for every every ton of
CO2 that that Source emits they have to
purchase one allowance and then they
have to True up um they can trade the
so facilities that emit less than they
thought they were going to can trade
them to other facilities that emitted
more um it's a much more cost effective
way it's very similar to the way um the
federal acid rain program which is
considered to be one of the most
successful environmental programs ever
it's a market-based program the sources
true up at the end of a uh of a
compliance period which is generally
three years they look at what their
emissions are they look at how many
allowances they have and they have to
surrender one allowance for each ton of
emissions
uh and the states manage this
cooperatively through an entity called
Reggie Incorporated which uh our
commissioner and the commissioner of the
Department of energy both serve on the
board of directors so that's an entity
that's managed by the states to serve
the states and run one Regional
program um and so uh the major thing to
think about with regie is the cost of
Reggie is a cost to a facility just like
the cost of fuel or any other thing that
that that facility purchases so it goes
into their cost of power so when they
sell their power to the green uh
Regional grid they are including the
cost of Reggie compliance in that so the
regional grid price for electricity
includes the cost though that those
funds are then uh allocated the the
auctions where the allowances are sold
those funds are then allocated back to
the States on a PR basis and so uh here
in New Hampshire we use those funds and
apply them back to stakeholders to the
uh uh users of energy um and uh as a as
a rebate um States many states do do
different things they run programs such
as I mentioned the efficiency main
program receiv receives some Reggie
funds and so on and um uh so the major
thing for us to remember here is it's
better for us to be in this program than
to be out because if if we're out we
still pay if we're in we get them the
money back um that offsets that cost so
um there have been a number of bills
over the years to try to remove New
Hampshire from the program but it really
isn't uh doesn't make a lot of economic
sense for us not to be in the
program so with that I'm going to turn
it over to Katherine beam um she won't
say so herself but I will say Kathy over
the past few years has become a national
expert on P
uh air related emissions due to her work
outstanding work in um establishing the
permitting and the uh controls at the St
gobain facility in in uh miramac and uh
um she's consulted from around the
country on pasas a emissions so uh I
know she wouldn't say a word about that
but uh you're talking to a real expert
here
so oh you're going to leave her I'll
stay with her
okay you have control
[Laughter]
well thank you committee for having me
here today as Mike the assistant
director mentioned I'm Kathy beam I'm an
administrator at the air Resources
Division I've been working on PS since
about 2016 and the PS issue in marac um
I'd like to just highlight two stat
statutory changes that have occurred
that affect pasas in air emissions since
the the discovery of pasas the first one
was Senate Bill 309 that was passed in
that is the one that gave the department
the authority to regulate air emissions
that cause or contribute to groundwater
or surface water s u pest violations um
it also allowed us to do rule making
associated with it and then to hire the
toxicologists and the human health
assessor and establish those ambient
groundwater quality standards and a plan
to develop surface water standards go
ahead so I just want to give you a a
status report on what the department has
been doing in relation to that Senate
bill um as you are probably very
familiar with we issued a permit to St
gobain performance Plastics in meramac
to install control equipment they did so
the controls were stack tested every
year for three years they were able to
demonstrate compliance with that
statutory change the facility closed
last year and has um pretty much been
dismantled there's no equipment there
now also under this uh Authority we've
been investigating other potential
industrial sources of pfest but thus far
haven't found uh additional sources
subject to the statute we have a very
extensive groundwater and surface water
and additional uh media uh test results
across the state and we don't see that
level of uh impact from an industrial
Source we've had some other locations
where either they've closed reformulated
or moved um but no one that's operating
today as an industrial facility we are
however developing a stack testing plan
because there are some concerns about
potential devices which would have a
feed stream that would cause potential
pasas emissions and those are are things
where you're using a waist Stream So an
incinerator um dealing with sludge and
any type of uh remediation of that past
whether it's soil or sludge and then um
also landfill gas has been identified as
a potential pasas precursor uh Source
but again that was a scientific study
down in Florida so we'd like to really
get an understanding of whether that is
really an issue here in New
Hampshire and um we're monitoring any
new devices that are proposed in the
state that might be dealing with
biosolids or any other kind of pfest
Medias to make sure that they are
complying with the
statute and then as a result of that
stack test uh plan that we're putting
together we are evaluating whether to uh
proceed with air uh emission Ru making
and then the rest of that statute as you
know we've established ambient
groundwater quality standards maximum
contam levels for drinking water uh the
four Ps are listed here as you can see
we hired the two positions and we
submitted a plan to the state
standards the other uh legislative
action that's related to pasas in air
was a house bill 1546 which passed in
2022 it amended the state statute on air
toxics that director Wright mentioned
about
um our air toxics program and it
basically required the commissioner of
the department to evaluate peer-reviewed
studies to determine if inhalation or
breathing in of P emissions would cause
a he human health uh problem since 2022
we've conducted an annual review we've
been involved in as commissioner
director Wright mentioned um we're
involved in many different programs
Across the Nation and and um listening
to different scientific studies and
results from other states um but we have
not identified inhalation exposure that
would change our assessment of the air
toxics program we do have a few
fluorinated compounds that are on our
air toxics list and those are still
being um you know enforced here in the
state that matter of fact the standard
in that in that Statute in the in the
rule from that statute um required s
gobain to reformulate way back in 2006
um but we have no uh peer-reviewed
studies that would change our evaluation
of that to date
and that pretty much covers what I was
cover any questions about
P representative Doug
Thomas thank you good presentation uh as
you are most likely aware my district is
uh profoundly affected by pasas so I'm
I'm interested the um the the question I
have is the um the standards the uh the
New Hampshire preest standards that that
you list here I assume as they as they
apply to water um are they in line with
EPA so the standards you see there are
for groundwater um for drinking water
standards as well as for groundwater
remediation standards um I'm not an
expert on the water side of things but I
would say that these are the standards
that we have in place today EPA has come
up with proposed lower standards um we
have not adopted them to yet to date
because of the process in which that has
to go through litigation and and then
the process of adopting them in the
state of New Hampshire
so follow up uh yeah and could you relay
to us what those proposals might be well
I know that poo is proposed to be 0.004
parts per trillion as opposed to our 12
um I don't know the other ones off top
of my head apologize for that
um representative Wendy Thomas has a
question thank you Mr chair um as you're
well aware we monitor Four Past
chemicals in New Hampshire however there
are tens of thousands of past
chemicals what is the timeline on
increasing uh observance of those
them do you want to handle sort of well
if you're referring to water regulation
that's um that's not our Arena as as was
mentioned epa's proposed new standards
um yes there are thousands of pest
chemicals and the evaluation of which
ones are are uh contributing to to
health impacts um is
currently you know a significant area of
of research um but as New Hampshire we
we are required to submit a report to
the legislature every year to review the
the the uh literature scientific
literature and make recommendations as
to whether these should be revised or
new standards established and so on um
we'll be submitting that report shortly
if if we didn't just recently um and uh
uh so we continue to monitor those and
uh also to watch work closely with EPA
obviously having a federal standard um
you know we'd want to coordinate closely
with them on on what what they do in
that Arena um I don't know I I would
just I would just add that we did do the
review this year and the department did
submit our report for this year we made
no recommendation to change our current
standards largely because we're tracking
what EPA is doing right now if and when
those EPA standards need to be
implemented New Hampshire plans to
follow along with those standards at
this point in time
followup followup thank you um this
actually has to do specifically with the
air quality um I'm I looked at at the
agencies that you worked with um do you
link arms with the observatory Folks up
at Mount Washington and all of the um
weather research they're
doing uh rather closely my brother's on
the board of directors
so uh um but uh we we have not had uh a
tremendous amount of communication with
them on this issue in particular um we
do we do do some coordination we have a
uh uh hay cam up in the White Mountains
and and so on but um this has not been
an an area that I'm aware of that we've
done any particular uh I'm I'm not aware
of research that they're doing on on
this uh topic but uh uh I will call my
brother tonight
and pl plant a plant a seed I do just
want to say this is a very unique
situation from an air perspective
because it's an air pollutant that
causes
groundwater uh problems and so when we
determine what emissions are applicable
we first look at the groundwater and
back that back to the stack through very
sophisticated modeling and so on and
then say okay this is what we can allow
out of the stack so as to prevent
contributing to a groundwater violation
we don't do that with any other
pollutant um this is and obviously the
situation in Southern New Hampshire is
unprecedented um and we've never run
into this before so we're feeling our
way Along on on this topic obviously and
I think we're a national leader and
Kathy certainly is a nationally known
resource on this
issue representative schneller has a
question thank you chairman uh if I
could just back up um prior to PS we did
talk about Reggie a little bit and if if
I understand this um for my edification
also for the public so choser keeps
coming to mind the partner tale um so if
if we don't participate in this we pay
anyway so effectively we have to buy
indulgences if if I might use the choser
uh reference and we pay regardless yeah
those the cost the costs of compliance
with Reggie is embedded in the wholesale
cost of
electricity so when a facility sells
their electricity into the grid and they
get uh and that electricity gets
bought um and ultimately that cost gets
charged to you the rate payer um but
when New Hampshire sells those
allowances our portion of the allowances
we get those those monies come back the
sale of the allowance um that that cost
is is comes back to us and so the money
goes in when you pay the electricity
bill it comes back out to the state and
then the state distributes that back to
rate payers so um if we're in we we get
the money back and if we're out we just
pay and get nothing
back thank you very
much all right I'd like to thank uh all
of you for being here today giving us an
excellent presentation on the role of
Dees in our state and I'd like to
apologize to the Granite State Hydro
power folks um we're a little bit late
but um you're up next so come on down
and we'll look forward to hearing from
you I'll let you introduce yourselves
rather than try to introduce you myself
even though I know both of you well
welcome
hopefully there are enough of those
handouts but if not um I'm happy to
provide more to the committee um so good
morning uh Mr chairman and members of
the committee um for the record my name
is Heidi croll um I work at J Grimble
strategic Solutions um you may know my
colleagues uh jod grimus and Adam
Schmidt um if you don't know them
already hopefully you'll be able to meet
them soon um so I represent the granite
state Hydro Power Association um which
goes by the acronym of gsh
um meline Mano is with me um here today
she works with Essex Hydro um which is a
member of gsha um and she is very
knowledgeable on um all things Hydro so
you'll hear from her in a bit um gsha is
a voluntary um nonprofit trade
Association for the smallscale Hydro
power plants in New Hampshire um gsha
Members Own and operate and manage more
than 55 hydroelectric facilities um
located in 40 towns um throughout the
state and totaling approximately 57
megawatts so gsha member facilities tend
to be 5 megawatts or less um and many of
their members have facilities that are
below one megawatt um I'll also mention
that I um also represent madn paper
mills um which is located in Bennington
New Hampshire um they are actually a
member of gsha and they have three Hydro
facilities on site that Supply about um
half of the Mills electricity needs um I
have two other Hydro clients as well um
I represent Brookfield Renewable Energy
which operates eight um hydroelectric
facilities in New Hampshire um all of
them are on the anders scrin River uh
they they total approximately 45
megawatts um six are located in uh
Berlin and Goram um one is in uh dummer
and one is in AOL and finally I
represent um Great River hydro which has
um the larger hydros along the
Connecticut River um they own and
operate six um Hydro stations and two
storage reservoirs in New Hampshire um
their facilities in New Hampshire total
503 megaw so those are larger facilities
um if any of you or the committee as a
whole is interested in touring um any of
these facilities small large or
somewhere in between um please let me
know we'd be happy to um host you for a
tour um we've provided you with a few
handouts today uh there's some
background on gsha in there um as well
as Great River Hydro um and there are
two articles about the importance of
hydro in terms of uh um reliability and
grid stability um in addition to being a
clean and local uh renewable resource so
uh before I turn it over to mine I just
wanted to quickly mention some of the
benefits of New Hampshire's Hydro
facilities um at the state and local
level um as well as benefits to the grid
so um first these um facilities um they
are part of New Hampshire's business
Community they pay um state and local
property taxes uh they pay business
taxes lease payments to Dees um if they
are operating at a state-owned dam as
you heard earlier this morning um from
the DS presentation uh and occasionally
some water user fees um associated with
certain um State impoundments um they
employ local residents um in well-paying
jobs uh they contract with local
businesses for goods and services um
everything from parts for equipment um
to engineers and accountants they remove
hundreds of tons of debris and trash um
from New Hampshire's Rivers every year
uh with their trash rakes which
essentially prevent the debris from
going into the um into the generators
they maintain public recreational
facilities including boat ramps uh
Portage facilities and picnic areas and
they provide a sign significant uh
Public Safety benefit by monitoring uh
on a regular basis the water flows and
maintaining the dam infrastructure at no
expense to taxpayers so as you heard
heard from De Dees this morning um New
Hampshire owns a significant number of
dams many of which are uh in need of
repairs and um I believe you'll you know
you'll be seeing legislation in the
session looking at options for how the
state uh you know can try to fund um
millions of dollars in repairs and mine
will walk through this um more uh talk
about this more but with private
ownership um the ongoing and significant
cost of maintaining the dam
infrastructure as well as the generating
equipment is warned by the private Hydro
um owner and not by the
taxpayers um and finally in terms of
benefits to the grid um Hydro power is
very reliable um if it's a run-of River
facility it is generally running
247 um except during periods of drought
or or when the facility needs to be um
shut down for maintenance uh so it's
operating um similar to a Basel load um
Power
Plant um if it's associated with sto a
storage Reservoir um like some of the
DRS along the Connecticut River um then
it's not only running 247 but it also H
can function as a peaking unit by
ramping up production um if needed by
drawing um additional water from the
reservoir uh so essentially the
reservoir in those situations acts like
a natural battery um and it's not
limited to the kind of two to four hours
um like some of the lithium um battery
technologies that you your committee
heard about yesterday um during your
discussions um Hy hyro power can also
serve as a quick start resource um and
in the case of a few of the Great River
Hydro facilities um they are Black start
capable which means that um they don't
need to draw um power from the grid to
turn on and this capability is um and is
very critical for restoration of the
grid if there's a blackout and in fact
has served in that capacity um for for
New England um on a couple of occasions
so uh critical resource in that respect
um um so all of these features mean that
Hydro can actually be a good complement
to intermittent
Renewables um and finally Hydro tends to
be relatively affordable um places where
Hydro is the primary um source of
generation like the Pacific Northwest or
uh Quebec um those tend to be um lowcost
electricity
areas um so with that I'll turn it over
to madin uh she's going to discuss some
of the challenges for hydr power um some
of the public policies here in New
Hampshire that are important uh to Hydro
power like RPS and net metering um and
conditions of the dams and fish passages
which I know are two of the topics um
that the chairman um uh had asked us to
cover so with that I'll turn it over to
meline and happy to take any questions
and look forward to presenting to you
today thank you thank you Heidi um as
Heidi mentioned my name is mamino and
I'm Chief Operating Officer of Essex
Hydro we own and operate 12 hydr power
plants in Vermont New Hampshire and
Maine and operate an additional to in
New Hampshire as contract operators so
day-to-day we're running 14 hydropower
plants uh here in Northern New
England um some of the industry
challenges and I don't I don't want to
be pessimistic I think we have a strong
thriving industry um but we do face
challenges just like every industry um
one of the main ones is is regulatory
oversight and requirements um all hydr
power plants are federally licensed or
have an exemption from license but an
exemption doesn't mean you're not
overseen you're still very much overseen
by firk um that Come Those licenses are
good for 30 to 50 years there is a large
wave of relicensing going on currently
relicensing a hydr power project is a
many years and very expensive process um
we as the project owner have to
undertake many many scientific studies
so state federal agencies get to request
any studies that they would like us to
do at our cost during the relicensing
process that can be everything from fish
passage to water quality to archaeology
and historic resources and things like
that so it's it's pretty broad scope of
things that we look at while we are
relicensing a project to be able to keep
it
online um one of the directions that we
see as regulatory directives is
unfortunately to take away some of the
flexibility and really focusing on the
run-of river operation mode um some
Hydro projects have some capacity
currently in their licenses to store and
release water which makes them really
valuable resources as Heidi mentioned it
pretty much allows them to have buil-in
energy storage and dispatch um at will
when needed however um to minimize
environmental impacts of reservoir
fluctuations there is um very much um a
direction when a project is relicensing
to either reduce or eliminate their
capacity to store and release
water we're very much seeing um droughts
and extreme precipitation events and
managing those is um challenging for us
um we love water but we love a nice
consistent flow of water um we had a
very dry fall this year that was um
challenging for us some of our projects
were offline because they didn't have
enough water to generate in October and
November which is unusual we usually
have really nice consistent water at
that time of year um it it comes and
goes but I have colleagues that have
been in this industry for decades and
they say they very much have seen a
change in the frequency of droughts and
the frequency of very extreme sudden
precipitation events um that we have to
manage um and then I'll talk in more
detail about the cost of maintaining
large infrastructure like dams um as
well as fish Passage um costs so some of
the policies that are very important to
our Small industry here in New Hampshire
is group nit metering the vast majority
of gsha members at this point which are
all under 5 megawatts are acting as
group net metering hosts that means that
we've gone out and recruited a group of
electric member accounts for the smaller
projects up to one megawatts that can be
private businesses for the larger
projects up to 5 megawatts acting as
Municipal hosts those all have to be
public entities like schools
municipalities um so we participate as
group hosts that means that we are
returning savings to those group members
every month um as we collect credit
Revenue we are then passing on some
savings directly to those
members um another important uh policy
is the renewable portfolio standard the
renewable portfolio standard is the
divided up into different classes class
4 was dedicated specifically to
supporting small Hydro in New Hampshire
um so that's very important there is
some gsha members that also have class
one um qualification that means they
added additional New Generation that
does happen at some projects they'll be
able to put in an additional small
turban for minimum flow for example um
or things like
that so we were asked to speak
specifically to fish passage and Dam
conditions um fish passage can be a
really big part of what we do and that
doesn't really affect any other forms of
electric generation but it ends up being
um a pretty big undertaking at a lot of
our projects in New Hampshire in the 80s
when a lot of these projects were um
developed the focus was on Atlantic
salmon and Atlantic salmon restoration
that has now been abandoned so a lot of
those projects invested tremendous funds
to build fish passage for Atlantic
salmon um either salmon that were
actually returning from the ocean or
salmon that were being stocked in the
headwaters by the agencies and um since
that Pro restoration program has been
abandoned a lot of those fish passages
are now having to be
retrofitted redesigned upgraded because
the focus species for fish passage are
now River Herring American shad and
American eel
which have very different needs than a
salmon so having a fish ladder is not
sort of you check a box and you're good
um as needs for different Focus
restoration species change um sometimes
we have to completely redesign and
rebuild a fish passage for example that
comes up a lot in relicensing so there's
a lot of focus in relicensing on fish
passages um I mentioned one of the focus
species is American eel
um Downstream passage for eel is
extremely challenging currently a lot of
the hydros will just shut down at night
during Downstream eel passage season
either after certain precipitation
events or um because there's currently
no better way at those facilities to be
able to make sure that eels migrate
Downstream they migrate at night
preferably after precipitation events so
some facilities for three nights after
it rains they have to shut down their
operations completely so that the eels
can pass safely without going into the
turbines in relicensing we are looking
at very narrow trash racks so trash
racks are the metal bars in front of our
intakes that prevent usually debris from
going into the turbine but it also
prevents fish from going into the
turbine for eels the spacing between the
bars has to be 3/4 inch which is then
extremely challenging for us to manage
having that not get clogged up with
debris
just preventing the water flow so in
several instances we're having to
completely redesign the intake of the
hydro project so that we can accommodate
these very narrow racks to direct the
eels away from the intake to a safe
Downstream
passage
um the relensing process itself um is
costly as I mentioned um but in order to
agree to come to an agreement with the
agencies and so when I talk about
agencies I'm talking about uh several
federal agencies are involved us fish
and wildlife uh Noah Marine fishery
Service as well as our local fishing
game uh
agency so in order to get them to agree
that a Hydro power project will get a
new license we often have to agree to
Future fish passage improvements um so
I'm currently relicensing our three
projects on the kukuk river here in
Penacook at our Penacook la Falls for
example we're looking at an roughly $1
million investment in future fish
passage so that will mean completely
redesigning the intake for Downstream
eel passage as well as eventually once
the projects on the marac can pass
Upstream fish we'll have to put Upstream
fish passage there as well we're
fortunate that with those three projects
we're able to sort of group The
Investments at one of the project to
avoid Investments at the other projects
because they're extremely close together
in two miles of river so we're currently
planning to do what's called trap and
truck at the downstream pass Downstream
project where we will pass the fish but
put them in a truck and literally drive
them to the Upstream um project so The
Upfront in infrastructure Investments
are one thing but the ongoing operation
and maintenance cost of fish passages
are a whole other thing So currently at
our at some of our other projects that
where we run fish passages we have to
hire additional seasonal staff to run
our fish
passages exclusively so we hire
additional staff just to do that um so
it is a significant
cost um unfortunately some fish passage
costs in relicensing have led to hydr
power owners abandoning projects um
that's happened at one of the state hone
dams on the Sagan River um a very small
project obviously only Mak so much
revenue and at some point there's no
economy of scale and the costs can be so
big to relicense the project that they
the project owner says it will never
make economic sense for me to put in
this fish passage which is really
unfortunate because I think it's very
important to keep these resources that
we currently have it's very challenging
to site and interconnect new electricity
generating resources so keeping the
resources we currently have on online
and available um is really important and
then if a hydrop power project owner
abandons the project relinquishes the
license that environmental Improvement
of fish passage won't get done because
there's no longer a regulatory Avenue to
require it and the dam probably won't be
maintained as well as it used to so it's
it's not a win-win for
anyone um so that's fish passage and
then as far as dam condition I know you
heard from the dam Bureau earlier
um dams that have operating hydr power
tend to be much better maintained than
then dams that may be only there for
recreation or they used to have a
purpose for a mill but they're no longer
there there's a present owner there are
operators and there is also a source of
Revenue to support the infrastructure
needs for that Dam um but dams are a
major infrastructure and they are in
water and they need to be maintained um
we take that responsibility very
seriously they have to be maintained in
good uh condition for public safety
reasons we um we have staff available
247 to respond to emergencies we have a
lot of sensors and alarms and monitors
at all of our projects that monitor
conditions both of the power generating
equipment but as well as water levels um
and things like that so we also under
regular inspections with fate state and
federal agencies to make sure that the
dams are safe and well maintained and
there's also a lot of annual tests so we
have to show that our gates can open and
close and we have to document that and
certify that um as well as having lots
of emergency plans uh in case of any
kind of emergency situation that may uh
arise um you know there are some dams
that are very old that require major
maintenance but even more modern dams
require uh regular upkeep uh regular
maintenance that we've done to our dams
for example can be relining a pen stock
a pen stock is the big pipe that brings
water from the intake to the turbine uh
some are very short but some can be half
a mile long so we're talking about uh a
really big pipe that can be really
expensive
um uh refacing spillways most dams are
made out of concrete concrete degrades
over time we uh we have a good concrete
contractor and we keep them in business
let me tell you um replacing or
upgrading Gates so there are all sorts
of different types of gates that can
bypass water um in order when we get
those flows that are more water than we
can put through our power generating
equipment we have to bypass that water
that can be done through Gates sometimes
it's through spillways so um we have to
maintain that equipment and because it's
in water a lot of times steel rusts and
wood degrades and so it has to be
maintained and replaced on a regular
basis there is an increased concern
about extreme storms and flood events um
certainly from The Regulators and that's
driving a lot of requirements and
oversight to be able to
bypass more uh larger flood capacities
so dams are built to be able to safely
pass a certain uh magnitude of flood
flows and and as we are you know
updating data and looking at different
um more recent precipitation events and
flood events there is definitely a push
to move to beefing up our dams to be
able to pass more flows safely and that
can be extremely costly um there was
recently a round of federal grants
through the bipartisan infrastructure
law that was implemented through uh the
US doe lots of gsha members got some of
those grants we were fortunate to get
two of them um and those are extremely
helpful one there was three topics that
those grants funded one was fish one was
environmental improvements which most of
the applicants and grants are going to
fish passage one was um Dam safety and
infrastructure and so that was also
extremely helpful to get some of those
grants to fund some of those projects
the grants fund a third of the project
cost and so we are certainly still
putting in quite a bit of our own
funding that's everything that I had yep
and I was just going to add before we go
to questions um Mr chairman um I think
we heard this morning um that the
state-owned facility I think it's Kelly
Falls um that um where there had been a
it's a state owned Dam a hydro facility
there that was being leased um The
Entity that was leasing um has uh exited
the lease at at its expiration and I
think we heard this morning that the
fish passage there was is a $13 million
price tag to that
um and I think mine mentioned this but I
just wanted to emphasize it too that
with the fist passages not only do you
have these additional costs both for the
initial investment and the operation and
maintenance but it it can require
passing less water through the facility
to and so a reduction in the ability to
generate power um in terms of
relicensing um manad paper mills for
example relicensed its three facilities
uh a couple of
probably at this point maybe four or
five years ago that was a seven-year
process for them um another one um Great
River Hydro is going through some
relicensing I think they're in year 11
um so these are not short Endeavors um
and as mine said you know there's
millions and millions of dollars that
are spent um on Experts and consultants
and attorneys um not to mention staff
time and resources um the final thing I
wanted to add um with respect to net
metering um under the municipal host or
Municipal group net metering is that the
state um Can is a participant or is now
allowed to uh be um an end user in that
Arrangement and um I we do know that
there are a number of state agencies
that are actually taking advantage of
that and so the state and state
taxpayers are seeing the benefits of net
metering with some local hydro which is
really good to see
so okay well thank you very much to both
of you
M Mano I was particularly intrigued by
your discussion of reservoirs and the
potential for using those almost like
battery
storage now we know that lithium ion
battery storage is very expensive
something on the order of half a million
dollars a megawatt
hour is there any way to
calculate what Reservoir storage might
cost or might be worth and is there any
way to monetize it it it doesn't cost
anything so the the Regulatory Agencies
would just have to tell us so currently
in our licenses for example at our local
projects here it says we must maintain
our impoundment at a steady level and we
must only generate with the water that
comes to us as it comes to us at one of
our uh we have a series of projects in
Maine and at there we control the water
in a lake and we have a 1ot level within
which we can keep that lake level so
that allows us the ability to store up
to a foot of water over the entire area
of the reservoir and then we discharge
the water when it's needed or when we
want and then we own four hydros
Downstream of that Reservoir and so we
effectively can decide when to release
the water and when to not release it and
it's still quite controlled of you know
maintaining within a foot there's a lot
of properties on that Reservoir and um
they keep a very close eye on us and if
you know they're very unhappy if we
change it too much but um similarly um
you know the the projects on the
Connecticut River have had some of that
flexibility and it's been a challenge in
relicensing to maintain some of it
they've been very creative to be able to
so it doesn't cost anything
the reason why Regulatory Agencies don't
like it some of it is the the residents
on those reservoirs are annoyed when the
water level changes regularly but some
of it is the environmental impact of
having the water level changing in an
unnatural manner so is there any way to
value that foot of water in terms of
megawatt hour potential yeah I can't
tell you off the top of my head but for
example it would allow us instead of
generating at night when power is not
really needed and really cheap we could
generate at maximum power you know
instead of generating at half power 247
we could pause operations at night and
then generate at full power between 400
p.m. and 8:00 P.M when that demand when
solar is going down and that demand is
ramping up so that price differential
between
um nighttime generation and peak time
generation is a value as well as the
price suppression of having additional
Supply during those times of peak
demand but I don't know the value off
the top of my head but it's quite
valuable I think it would be Mr chairman
I can um check with Great River hydro
and see if they have any additional
information that might help respond to
your question I I don't know any I don't
have an answer off the top of my head
but I will
ask okay thank you further questions
from the committee representative Corman
has one thank you Mr chairman and thank
you both for coming here I'm just
curious um when when a dam is actually
um getting uh I guess a a a bid or
something like that are you typically in
the day ahead Market I guess that's what
I'm looking for day ahead Market
long-term contracts spot market and also
can you give me some sort of ballpark as
to what you get per megawatt hour so as
I mentioned a lot of of gsha members are
group nit metering hosts so in that case
they're getting whichever the host
utilities default service rate is just
the energy and so new prices just came
out for February 1st in Unitil territory
we're talking about 7.8 cents for the
next six months I mentioned however that
we have group members and we're
returning savings to the those group
members so we're not keeping the whole
7.8 cents we're then giving a contracted
amount back to those members it could be
a percentage it could be a flat amount
whatever that is for the electricity
that they represent in our group um
certainly some members are on power
purchase agreement as far as gsha
members the very small
ones
not as far as I'm aware I don't think
any of them are in the spot Market or
wholesale Market markets they either
have power purchase agreements or our
group net metering
hosts
followup yes follow um how about the
really big ones like Mor and
cumerford I'll have to get back to you
on that question um I suspect it's
probably a mix of contracts and
participating in the spot Market but let
me
check representative McGee has a
question thank you Mr chairman and nice
to see you again mine
um uh thank you both for being here this
morning um my question has to do with
you know we have quite a few bills
coming through this year that relate to
um that influence the market and uh it
sounds to me and I've always felt that
the small Hydro in New Hampshire is um
is um a major benefit and we certainly
don't want to lose um what we have and
you've given examples here this morning
of folks going under based on not being
able to meet a margin that's reasonable
to keep them in business so can you
speak to we we definitely even have a
bill to consider phasing out the RPS and
so I'm curious if you could speak to us
about uh what role the RPS plays in your
margins that that would be the question
sure um so the New Hampshire RPS as I
mentioned class four is specifically for
small Hydro there are very specific
requirements to qualify so if you're
over a megawatt for example you have to
have upstream and downstream fish
passage regardless of what your license
requires which does not make a lot of
sense so for example our our facilities
in Penacook are not class 4 qualified
because our licenses don't say they have
to have Upstream fish passage yet so we
would not put in fish passage just to
qualify for New Hampshire class fours um
they are qualified other states um but
for the the facilities that do qualify
and the smaller facilities um it's an
additional two to three cents a kilowatt
hour of Revenue or 20 to $30 a megawatt
hour of Revenue so if you're a group net
metering host or you have a PPA if you
have a PPA you can either bundle the Rex
with the energy and sell that to the
buying entity some
some buyers want those resources to be
bundles so Rex are a commodity that is
additional and separate from the
electricity the kilowatt hours
themselves um and then if you're a group
net metering host you can sell the Rex
on the market um separately the price
varies depending on supply and demand um
and so we're not guaranteed a certain
amount of Revenue we are competing
against other wreck generating entities
for um selling our wrecks to buyers but
it is I'd say on average an
additional two to three cents a kilowatt
hour of Revenue which is very helpful to
you know help in the margins or recover
some of these Investments that I
mentioned that we have to
make followup so the other thing I'm
curious about is um the default rate
that you mentioned that you're
getting when when you're net metering um
and that you're splitting that with your
you know your group customers as a group
host so I have heard a lot of different
things about the value of um of of the
net metering so I I wonder if you could
speak to that a little bit to educate us
a little bit more on how that works um I
guess specifically what I'm trying to
figure out is again
whether uh the value you mentioned that
all that's included is the cost of the
power so what else could be your in your
opinion should be included there because
I think we should understand that yeah
um so I'll say we are
um huge fans of the group nit metering
program um we are happy with status quo
we've been very you know there's been a
docket at the puc over the last two to
three years and G's position has been
status quo is working for us we would
like to maintain status quo it is very
important for us to have um stability
and so the currently participating
projects are grandfathered in the
program we would like to see that you
know secured um we do feel like there is
a lot of uncertainty because it feels
like it is a constantly reevaluated
program both at the Pu and at the
legislature um we were about some of the
currently participating programs be uh
projects being affected by retrospective
changes when things are considered at
the Pu and at the legislature we see it
as a win-win because we have stable
Revenue at least in six-month increments
and as I said we group member customers
and then give them discounts on their
bill and so for example for an
industrial customer they can go out and
get the best offer they can from a
competitive supplier and then we will
give them additional discount for
participating in our net metering group
so it's helping our business and it's
helping their
business and I'll I'll just add to that
representative Wendy Thomas has a
question Mr chairman can I just add to
the answer to that question um I just
want to also point out that with with
Hydro because they are registered at ISO
New England the energy and capacity
payments that those hydros would
otherwise earn are retained by the
utility eversource Unitil whatever the
utility is and so those are an offset to
the credit that the um that the hydro
owners are earning as their net metering
credit so I just wanted to mention that
because that for other um Renewables
that may not be registered in ISO that
um that offset is not
there so because we were Market
participants before we parti became
group hosts the the way that it's done
in in every New England State where we
participate in at metering in every New
England state that I'm aware of at least
um we continue to participate in the
wholesale and capacity markets however
we don't receive any of that Revenue we
transfer it to the host utility so to
use really broad generalizations if the
default service is 8
cents but right now the power's pretty
high right and so if we're um we're
selling electricity into the wholesale
market and getting capacity payments
that's going to the host utility to
offset what they are paying us as a net
metering credit so at times they may
even get more than they're paying us at
times they're getting less but if on
average over the six months electricity
and capacity added up to 6 cents a
kilowatt
hour that offsets the 8 cent per
kilowatt hour that they're paying us and
then we're taking some of that and
giving it to the
members okay now representative Wendy
Thomas thank you very much um thank you
for being here interesting um
information that you've given on this
flyer right here um on the back it it
makes a notation about um that most fa
facilities are eligible to be on the
national register of historic places um
however if a facility or building is put
on that list it limits modifications and
Renovations um which could impact cost
and efficiency so is that simply a
Charming note or is that your intent to
get these facilities on that
list I'll say this is Great River
hydra's handout so I can't speak to
their facilities but we have 100y old
facilities and we do not voluntarily put
them on that list typically during
relicensing because we have to do a his
historic study they'll say this has
tremendous historical value we want it
to be listed and that comes with a lot
of requirements so for example at one of
our facilities that is gorgeous it looks
like a castle there's these huge wooden
doors and we currently are my operators
are begging me to replace it with a
garage door because it would be so much
more practical for their dayto day job
but we can't just do that we would have
to go to the state historic office
and make a case that it is absolutely
necessary and there's no in replacement
and we'd have to do the documentation
and all of that so that's an example of
some of these Hydro power facilities
have tremendous historic value but as a
day-to-day operator and someone that's
trying to do their job in a practical
way it would be great sometimes to be
able to update that to Modern standards
as far as Windows and Doors and things
like that but we can't always do that
thank
you represent Ros has a
question thank you Mr chair um yeah I
wanted to return to the topic uh of
the
importance uh and the mechanics I guess
of the the group net metering for the
for the hydro industry I think it would
be really helpful for this all the
members of this committee to understand
more as best we can uh and to you know
to
appreciate um the value that's
created and I was wondering if I I guess
I more of a request to in followup to
this presentation if you could share
with this
committee uh you know with a Precision
up to the Precision that you're
comfortable um you know the revenue
streams that you know the operators are
earning from group net group net
metering that's how many are selling
their p
into the grid but also in particular the
group net metering and the municipal
host you know
how those policy instruments that this
legislature has passed has enacted in
the past are now are sharing the
benefits
benefiting local businesses
municipalities you even mentioned um as
SC State agencies are now earning
Revenue by being part of the
of the
group um we would I think that would be
super valuable for this committee to to
have and you know like I say you've got
contracts it's it's finances but if you
could figure it out like what level
you're you're comfortable with sharing
uh so maybe some is
aggregated um I think it would just be
real helpful for
us sure let me just jump in here and say
that uh representative rolds
may want to get together with you
individually and personally to uh learn
more about this program and then he can
share what he learns with the rest of us
yeah how would that be yeah some of the
challenges are that it's a contract
between the host and the members and so
I know what I agree to with my members I
don't know what other hosts agree to and
there is a a bit of a competitiveness
there so but we could talk in in
generalizations representative schneller
has a
question thank you chairman uh I have
127 questions but I I suspect I will not
be indulged to that effect um so I I'll
I mean this is fascinating thank you
very much for your time um I total sort
of $25 million or so in in current fish
pass uh needs for Just Two facilities so
I suspect there's substantially more
than that um um and I I'll get to my
question really again tremendously
fascinating I'm just wondering is there
a standard capital structure for any one
facility or they or are they all sort of
custom uh structured then bonded
together and then is there a bond sorry
sorry for the multiple questions is
there a standard bond that gets issued
to finance Hydro in this state
uh and have there been any defaults on
those bonds if that the answer to the
first question is yes there isn't a
standard so unfortunately each you know
I have a I have a portfolio of hydro
projects I visit a lot of other Hydro
projects they're all unique because of
they were custom built for that specific
location in that specific River and so
when we're designing fish passages
there's not sort of an off-the-shelf
cookie cutter you know fish lift or fish
ladder that we can put into there that
would save a lot of of money if there
was but because each site is different
um pretty much we have to design an
engineer from scratch a specific
solution for that specific location um
there is more hope in the industry for
what's called fish friendly turbin so we
may be able to replace the actual
turbine Hub the propeller like blades to
um actually not have to worry about the
fish going through the turban and being
able to survive there's one company that
has something more promising than we've
seen so far so that would be very
helpful um for the downstream passage
for the Upstream passage you're still
going to have to sort of design custom
and as far as a bond most of these are
private businesses and so you know for
example we we are either using our own
capital or we would be borrowing from
lenders to be able to finance fish
passage projects so we're not but we're
not at the scale where we would be you
know issuing a bond or anything like
that I'm not aware of any defaults if
there are thank you representative
Kaplan has a
question thank you Mr chair and uh thank
you for coming in uh this is a similar
question but instead of fish passages
this is about spillways and I'm uh
concerned about extreme weather events
and the likelihood of increased
precipitation in in the coming years so
because it's a topic of a bill that I'm
going to be presenting later this
afternoon so um we heard from the the
dam Bureau that there's a $900 million
cost just to bring the dams up to up to
scratch so to speak uh so and you
mentioned that that the the the need to
beef up your spillways is an extremely
high uh you know extremely expensive
Endeavor so I'm I'm kind of wondering
similarly to representative schneller uh
what uh funding mechanis what funding
mechanisms you have in place or in mind
um to to meet those
needs it's just us having to pay for it
as I said it's either Capital that we've
set aside or we have to borrow and then
pay down that debt
um we are overseen mostly by firk at the
federal level um and so they have
slightly different regulations than the
state Dam Bureau but um
we really we regularly you know in
relicensing or regular Dam safety
inspections all dams have a certain
Hazard rating so they can be if they're
high Hazard they're held to a very high
standard they're inspected annually they
have to also be inspected every five
years by an independent engineer um
there's lots and lots of oversight there
and then there's you know everything
down to low Hazard where it may be in a
more you know isolated area if the Dam
failed it it's not perceived that there
would be loss of life or damage to
infrastructure or damage to any
properties Downstream so those have a
different standards but certainly if a
dam is seen to be insufficient to be
able to pass a certain level of expected
flood flows the improvements that we're
talking about usually involve almost
entirely rebuilding the dam so either
building much taller walls on the sides
expanding a Spillway or adding
additional bypass Gates which you know
essentially you're rebuilding the whole
Dam so we're talking about very
significant
infrastructure
question thank you Mr chair and thank
you for being here uh this is very
exciting because there's so much that my
system has in common with things that
you've been talking about so uh my whole
H solar system captures and stores
energy from nature and uh now storage uh
it's impractical to impractical to put a
hydropower Dam in my garage so I bought
a battery and store it that way but uh I
use net metering m i get Rec's renewable
energy credits
uh my question is this that if
I if I don't get those credits it's not
going to be you know the end of the line
for me as far as I would continue doing
what I'm doing I wouldn't get some cost
offsets but I'm not heavily vested and
don't have a essential business interest
if the Rec's went
away how would that impact the ability
to continue to be VI
from an electric generation standpoint
for hydr
power um I mean as I said it it's not an
insignificant source of Revenue
currently um and it it is very helpful
to our bottom line it you know it's two
to three cents a kilowatt hour is is a a
good amount so certainly I I can't speak
for all the gsha members but um it is a
policy that is extremely important to
our industry here in New Hampshire um
and if you have bills on group net
metering or the RPS you will likely see
us to tell you the importance of this
policy for for our industry so it it may
be maker break for for certain
facilities that are on the margins as I
said especially some of the really you
know gsha includes some of the really
small hydros like they may be 250
KW that's pretty small but they still
have to maintain a dam and they still
have to um fall under all of these
Regulatory and Licensing requirements so
they they probably really need um that
extra revenue from the Rex thank you
right the economies of scale definitely
are a factor um and I was around when we
were negotiating and working on the RPS
and and putting it on the books um
and partly why class 4 which is H
existing Hydro
um there's a number of reasons why 5
megawatts is kind of a magic number if
you will but one of the um pieces of
thinking was that um uh making sure that
the renewable energy certificates um
would really be helping these uh smaller
ones that really don't have necessarily
the economies of scale that some um some
other larger facilities
do I will say we generally as a business
try to manage our business risk so if
it's at all possible to cross qualify
one of our projects in multiple States
we do do that because there's
uncertainty in policy in every state and
so we try to to manage our business Risk
by cross qualifying in multiple States
so that if one State's RPS goes away we
hopefully can continue to participate in
other states
RPS well I want to thank you both for
being here I know we have a longstanding
invitation
from Granite State hydr power to visit a
hydr power facility and we will take you
up on that offer this spring once the uh
hectic uh legislative battles are behind
us and we have a little more time we
will arrange a committee visit to one of
your facilities we'll look forward to
that and we'll have a lot of time to
talk to you and others uh about the
operation of your facilities so that we
can augment our knowledge uh even
greater than than what we've learned
here today so thank you again and uh if
any members have any further questions
see these ladies uh after we end our
session here thank before we go to lunch
I want to bring you up to date on a
couple of things I learned at a meeting
earlier this
morning for those of you who are
new excuse me the speaker holds weekly
meetings with chairs and Vice chairs of
committees to discuss various issues and
the clerk is always at those meetings
and he answers questions and this
morning I learned the following we
discussed this yesterday and had some
questions if you are the prime sponsor
the prime sponsor of a bill you can
bring an amendment to a committee public
hearing you must bring sufficient
quantities of that Amendment text to
distribute to all members of the
committee if you are not the prime
sponsor of a bill the only way you can
suggest Amendment language in your
public hearing testimony is via your
written
testimony so that is the important
distinction Prime sponsors can enter
offer an
amendment non-prime sponsors have to put
Amendment suggested Amendment text in
their written
testimony representative reels in
elucidation there
instance that suggested amendment in the
text of testimony would require
essentially another proceeding later to
be translated into an actual amendment
that could be considered by the
committee exactly remember the committee
owns the the bill and it's up to the
committee to decide if they want to
amend the bill or not so others can
suggest amendments but only the
committee can actually make an amendment
or offer an
amendment the other thing I learned this
morning is that the rule change that we
made on Wednesday last
week does allow the calling of an
executive session at any time at the
uh discretion of the
chair but it has to be noticed in the
calendar first so if a public hearing
calls for let's say five public hearings
in the course of a day and then
underneath that there is language that
says executive sessions may be called at
any time then that means that the chair
could call an executive session at any
time and the reason for that change is
let's say you scheduled a public hearing
for 2 hours because you thought a lot of
people were going to come and
testify and then the the hearing opens
the sponsor introduces the bill and
nobody signed up to testify and the
hearing's over in 20 minutes now you've
got almost two hours of time to kill
before your next public hearing so if
you had
bills that you had already heard heard
in public hearing the chair could call
an executive committee to make valuable
use of your time here in the state house
to dispose of those those bills so
that's the the rationale behind
using the ability to call an executive
session at any time as long as it's
noticed ahead of
time so I wanted to bring you guys up to
date on on that representative Kaplan
yeah just just a further clarification
on that last Point Mr chair I mean uh
does that ability extend beyond the you
know sort of unofficial closing time at
five o'clock say could you keep us here
after everything's done and say we're
going to have an executive session only
if I obtained permission from the
speaker because that requires staff to
be kept Beyond 5:00 which puts them on
overtime and the speaker has to approve
overtime uh so it the answer is yes it
can be done but not
easily and not not if the speaker says
no okay we're off to lunch everybody
back here at 1:00 to hear from ISO New
England that'll be an exciting
you
e
okay everyone please take your seats
okay welcome back to the afternoon
session of science technology and
energy on uh Tuesday the 14th of January
we have two presentations this afternoon
the first one will be in just a moment
by ISO New England and then after their
presentation and Q&A we will move to a
presentation by The Joint util i ities
eversource unit till Liberty and New
Hampshire Electric
Co-op that has a hard stop time of 3:30
because at 3:30 we're going to have a
public hearing on House Bill
106 so with that introduction Davis if
you could turn on the screen over here
for us please we're set to go with a
presentation from ISO new New England so
gentlemen welcome the floor is yours
very
much press it press the
button good good afternoon my name is
Eric Johnson I'm the executive director
of external Affairs for ISO New England
and with me is uh Nathan rake who's a
member of the external Affairs team and
a liaison to the folks here in New
Hampshire thanks for the invite uh we're
going to share a presentation that is a
bit of a uh information resource packet
we won't go through this in detail and
we happy to take questions along the way
and as time permits uh at the
end so if we start thinking about the
mission and vision of our organization
our mission describes what we do and our
mission is defined in uh rules that have
been approved by the Federal Energy
Regulatory Commission or firk so I'll
try to spell out acronyms raise your
hand if I say something that you don't
recognize and our mission uh dates back
to the um the beginning of the iso in
the late 1990s and we are responsible
for planning the transmission system
administering wholesale
markets and operating the bulk power
system uh in real
time aspirationally we've adopted a
vision statement that we think aligns
with the direction of the New England
states and recognizes that there's a lot
of new technologies that are coming
online uh the vision state is adopted by
the iso did not require approval by firk
and just gives you two dimensions of the
scope of our work and what we do and I'm
going to turn it over to Nathan to talk
a little bit about more on the
organizational
side so the iso has more than two
decades of experience ad ministering and
the Region's restructured Electric
System as Eric mentioned we are
regulated by the Federal Energy
Regulatory Commission or furk we also
serve as the reliability coordinator for
New England under the North American
reliability Corporation or nerk and O as
an entity the iso is independent of all
the companies that participate in the
can I just interrupt real quick Nathan
really quick for the benefit of our new
people here uh they may not know what
ISO means oh independent system
operator thank
you so the i in the iso is for
independent which means we are
independent of all company that are
participate in the marketplace and
neutral on technology that comes into
the
market we have three critical roles that
were facilitated facilitated To Us by
firk this includes grid operation Market
planning there are five key areas that
we do not touch on we do not handle
retail electricity own any of the grid
infrastructure have stake in companies
that own grid infrastructure have
jurisdiction over fuel or have any
sighting there are numerous entities
that uh provide oversight and oversight
and input into the iso predominantly we
focus on the New England states through
our work with the Committees but also
through the consumer Advocates Attorneys
General policy makers such as yourselves
as well as
uh the puc's doe Dees from on occasion
as
well you can think of the iso as part of
a wider Regional organ uh body that is
known as the Eastern interconnection we
are tied directly to Quebec through DC
transmission ties and this stems out of
regulatory adjustments made after the
2003 blackout in the Greater Cleveland
area
I want to emphasize that about 133% of
the Region's energy needs are met by
imports from uh Quebec and this is
through our thae lines our DC Tha lines
but also through imports from New York
lines currently the New England system
is a summer peaking system however as we
transition through electrification we
anticipate this becoming more of a
system this provides a quick snapshot of
what the of the resource mix today we
are a predominantly a natural gas
operated uh system but we have seen a
growth of Renewables at over the last
several
years which is more emphasized by this
by this chart so we used to have a
system that was had an increased mix of
coal and oil but that has been
supplanted by natural gas to the point
where coal and oil no longer provide a a
resource and then generally overall
markets have the price electricity has
been coming down as markets have been
driving the the facilitation of cost
competitive electricity to the
region with that I'll turn it back over
to
Eric if we think about the resource mix
uh solar has been a pretty fast growing
resource uh in New England but for the
most part the iso doesn't see solar if
you have solar facilities on the rooftop
of a house or even a small array for the
iso and the control room operators it
really looks like a reduction in demand
on the bulk power system because now the
customers's power supply is coming from
an attached resource if it's if it's
solar we are starting to see larger grid
scale solar facilities uh most of them
are in uh the region in Maine um but
this slide gives you an indication of
the the number of
installations there's more than 300,000
uh across the region and we have about
6,500 megawatts of uh capacity that
could be produced by uh those solar
facilities so that's today if you think
back to the 2010 time frame uh there was
almost no solar operating on the system
our operators wouldn't see any change in
the load because of solar but it's grown
pretty rapidly and most of this growth
we attribute to the incentives that have
been provided by uh the New England
states and Mr chair I'll defer to you on
questions representative Ros thank you
Mr chair just a clarifying question here
numbers behind the meter solar or uh
larger scale solar that is
supplying the grid directly when you
show these numbers so this forecast
includes both and so the the the fine
print at the bottom will specify that
out
yeah representative Kaplan thank yeah I
have I have a question about what you
just mentioned which is the the
distributed solar that you don't see uh
on the iso does that uh because it does
lower Demand on the on the iso system
does that you know distributed solar
resource and you know it's penetration
into the grid does that represent a
value that gets translated into the
market at all why don't we go to the
next slide and we'll give you sort of a
illustration of what solar looks like on
the bulk power system so the line here
is a single day in New England it
happens to be a a spring day and the
leftand side is midnight and it goes for
24 hours and historically the iso would
turn on resources to meet the demand for
power which was the top line which
includes the dash line and so you could
see that the peak in New England
typically was in the early afternoon as
you've added a lot of solar it reduces
that demand uh on the system and so most
of those resources are not in the market
we will see newer large scale resources
that could participate in the market
Market but an individual customer um on
the solar side is more likely
participating in some type of a net
metering program that is regulated and
level representative rols thank you Mr
chair so that's a a huge uh Delta there
reduced Demand on the grid from all the
since majority of Generation Um on the
grid and especially the majority of uh
dispatchable generation on the grid are
the natural gas plants is it possible to
think
of that big yellow area every day as
reduced uh consumption reduced demand
for natural
gas yes in effect because the gas
resources typically are the marginal
resources on the system and we would
dispatch them down if we don't need them
and as the solar penetration grows we
need less gas at that point and so it
does directly impact gas quick followup
Mr chair followup yes and so
um does that reduced demand for natural
gas by the by the fleet of power plants
throughout New England does that
translate
into value for all rate
payers uh and value for consumers of
natural gas I mean that much reduction
in demand for natural gas if you think
about the uh the wintertime scenario
when the natural gas infrastructure is
constrained we can't serve all the power
generation that uses gas and the local
Distribution Company uh demand for
natural gas so in the winter time as uh
solar is operating at least when it's on
a sunny day it is freeing up in effect
uh natural gas on the system that would
go to uh other resources but it wasn't
designed particularly to reduce the
natural gas use in the region but it's
effect Vice chair Thomas thank you Mr
chair thanks for taking my question so
this chart obviously is for a uh a nice
uh full Sunny spring day when the
temperatures are very temperate um uh so
my question would be is that do you have
a graph that
shows overall the average through an
entire year what this graph might might
look like well it wouldn't look like a
load profile for 24 hours but we do have
that data and I'm happy to follow up uh
with a committee to share that it' be
representative parall you chair v a
quick question and thank you for being
here um I'm looking at what I always
believed was a traditional peak time of
around 4:30 and I'm seeing on this chart
it actually uh there's a dip there in
your estimated demand without BTM well
estimated
demand um on April 9th was there not
that typical what what I always thought
was a typical peak time between four and
six approximately yeah that's changed
completely as you add all of this solar
onto the system so if you go back uh a
decade pre- solar the system would have
peaked in the
afternoon and here at uh 4:30 we're
actually using
less uh Power on the bulk power system
than we are in the middle of the
night because the solar is displacing
all of that energy but then of course it
comes back on quickly this shows a
pretty steep ramp in the afternoon you
need to have resources that have the
flexibility to chase that demand as it
comes back as the solar is going
offline well
um followup thank you so much for the
followup um I just want to make sure I'm
getting the chart right though I can see
that the the effect that solar is having
but um your estimated demand without
solar BT M solar uh the dotted line as
it were um that dotted line is a
prediction of when our uh also where our
Peak would be right if we didn't let's
say it's today's a cloudy day right so
you're not going to get the same output
so this this load profile would look
more like the typical load profile on a
day when you don't have solar production
so it look more like the dashed
line okay thank you yes
thank
you so can you speak uh briefly
about the effect on the bulk power
system particularly the gas
operators of ramping down their
production and then ramping it back up
steeply in the afternoon what do that
what kind of cost impact does that have
system So currently the gas Fleet is a
very um
efficient Fleet they're very flexible
and they have that ability uh to ramp uh
they can go down uh on clear dispatch
instructions from the iso and they can
ramp back up um they're not the fastest
resources the pump storage Hydro
resources are um are much faster in
terms of their responding and then
batteries of course could discharge in
um to the grid instantly um but what
it's effectively doing is it's telling
the marginal resource which tends to be
gas right now we're going to take less
power from you in the times when you
have Sun but we're going to need you at
the end of the day when the Sun goes
down and people aren't changing their
use of electricity just because they put
solar on the system so we still have to
figure out where the power is going to
come from if the solar is not operating
so I mentioned at the beginning solar is
not a a resource that's putting power
onto the grid but we have to forecast
each day and we do this on a uh an
hourly basis as well trying to figure
out knowing how much solar is out there
what could it produce in terms of
electricity and then we have to take
that into account in our operating plan
so the control room and the forecasters
are looking at is it going to be cloudy
today um what what time does the Sun
come up what time to the sunset uh we
used to think about the weather a lot in
terms of temperature but now we're
thinking a lot more in terms of the the
system uh this is a snapshot of one of
the responsibilities Nathan talked about
uh planning the power system so we are
responsible as the grid operator to
study every proposal for new resources
that want to connect to the grid again
the bulk power system system uh we call
that the generator interconnection uh
study process and we use the term Q
which is like the British term for you
get in line so this is a snapshot of
everything that has come to us for
application to connect to the grid and
on the right hand side of this doughnut
chart you can see wind is about a little
over
40% battery storage is almost uh half of
what's in the queue we're starting to
see grid scale solar here show up uh at
about
8% the most noticeable difference here
and it's not on this slide is if you
looked at this chart back in 2017 gas
was the dominant resource and now gas
hardle shows up so um over time we've
seen the Q change as the states in uh
New England particularly the southern
New England states have provide uh
strong incentives for uh procurement of
offshore wind uh in particular so what's
in the queue is is really driven by uh
State policy for the most part in the
region now when I'll make one more point
on the Queue I'm happy to take a
question on it uh the iso doesn't uh
decide that this is what the resource
mix should be we're simply looking at
the interconnection of a project to the
grid and making sure that it wouldn't
have an adverse impact on the system or
anybody else connected to the system um
and we also don't look at the permeating
inciting it's really just an engineering
assessment on the system and the
developer needs to find financing they
need to secure their approvals um we're
just making sure that it's not going to
adversely impact uh the rest of the grid
so that's that's a snapshot of the queue
it's public information and on the right
hand side you can see the Breakout by by
state representative Swanson has a
question thank you Mr chair just to
clarify um so these are proposals
clearly don't
reflect the way things are right now but
this is part of some vision is their uh
time Horizon associated with these
proposals so uh each project uh comes
into the queue and we do a series of uh
meetings with a developer and they need
to make a financial commitment for us to
do the study work um and depending on
which uh studies they choose to do
there's um sort of an an initial kick
the tires study we'll give them a an
indication of what would be required to
connect to the system but there are much
more detailed uh engineering studies uh
called system impact studies and those
studies can take um a couple of years to
complete so the developer would have to
go through the complete study process
get a sign off from the iso and the
interconnecting utility for that project
to go forward um we report to our
regulator firk regularly on the um the
turnover time for projects in the queue
and I'm happy to share that with the
followup question Mr chair followup so
this so This the pie chart here
represents the sum of the proposals
right now that's correct thank
you representative Corman you had a
question no okay representative Vice
chair Thomas thank you Mr chair so I I
recall in previous briefings in the past
that uh you or someone would have
already would have also provided an a
slide
that would
show information that was kind of sort
of on this slide but also would show uh
during the tame the same time period the
uh base loads we have and what the the
mega wattage for base loads might be in
the future just to see uh where the
balance was I don't see that here is
that another slide that you might want
to provide to us to show what what might
be there we don't have that in that deck
but I'm happy to put that on as a
followup to share with the committee
right thank you that looks at the the
makeup of existing resources on Sy and
and and what it projects to be during
the same timeline to to see where you
know you know where we're headed because
I would assume that you might be
concerned if uh if there aren't many
projects being listed um that might
affect Basel load and if you only have
these being listed uh I'm not sure if
there is a concern for the future of the
balance of the of of the grid okay
represent happy to look for some
additional information representative
McGee has a question thank you Mr
chairman and thank you both for being
here today um so the thing that strikes
me about the chart is the the proposed
battery storage at 48% or close to
18,000 megawatts which the question
really is if that much battery storage
came online in New England to be used in
terms of managing Peak and all that
would that be a game Cher in terms of
your job of um being able to manage
those peak times it it seems like that's
an awful lot of battery it it is and it
it kind of Grew From nothing to it was
then part of the miscellaneous category
and now it's by far the largest of
what's in there most of this is uh short
duration uh energy energy storage uh
lithium ion technology so you're talking
about a resource that can hold a charge
and discharge but over maybe two to four
hours so it it'll help in a small window
it's not going to be a game Cher in
terms of meeting the long duration
energy storage needs that we see
especially in the winter so um I think
we're moving in the direction of having
additional storage capability on the
system um but what's what's proposed
here is also speculative we're not
expecting 18,000 megawatts of batteries
or wind or solar to come online uh and
and
inevitably uh some developers may have
multiple projects that are in this and
this doesn't capture some significant
changes that FK has made that's going to
put additional requirements on projects
before they can get into the queue so
they're going to set the bar higher the
the cost of admission to the queue is
going to be uh higher and so I think
you're going to see a ShakeOut of how
many projects are really serious
although I expect that the makeup will
still be uh wind battery storage and
solar for the most part but that that
hasn't affected this queue
yet representative Matson has a question
thank you Mr chair um I'm just wondering
where reliability fits into this um this
is all renewable battery backup two
hours so if we need just in time energy
where does it come
from so right now that's coming from the
fleet of existing resources so this is
not a picture of the future this is
layering on existing resources that we
have today Nathan showed that um about
half of our electricity comes from
natural gas fire generation so we're
assuming that those resources continue
we also have uh two large nuclear plants
including one here in New Hampshire so
those are part of providing uh
continuous power supply to the region we
have Imports that we can bring in from
our neighbors and we have pump storage
Hydra so there's a lot of resources that
provide reliability services in addition
to what you see here representative
Bernardi has a question I'm following up
on the same theme I I you know we've got
the base load that you talked about uh
from gas and or
nuclear those will age out there's
nothing here in this chart indicating uh
replacement of those as they get old uh
if if this is the future this to me says
we're headed for blackouts yeah yeah so
this is not the future by itself this is
the future of what developers have
proposed uh we expect the nuclear plants
could run for many years they're in for
relicensing um the natural gas Fleet is
a very modern Fleet very efficient we
expect that they can operate for many
years into the future so the question
might be well when are we going to see
other types of resources come in uh to
this queue it's possible that somebody
could propose
uh small uh nuclear reactors um the
modular resource they're not probably um
economic to do in New England but that
is a type of resource that we could see
show up in this resource mix uh sometime
in the future there's a lot more
activity on that um in Canada than we're
seeing here in New England but it does
have potential to add um other types of
capability to the Future resource
mix representative
Summers thank you Mr chairman and thank
you for taking my question um so
yesterday we had a discussion we met
with the Department of energy here in
the state of New Hampshire and they
explained to us that while New Hampshire
um consumes 10% of the load of
electricity that we produce 177% of the
electricity now looking at the chart and
knowing that ISO New England is part of
a conglomerate of Six States us and fisc
speaking uh known as be like the purple
island in the middle of a big blue donut
um looking at fiscally knowing that uh
um I want to understand being a part of
iso New England how is the state of New
Hampshire now I understand we had the
lowest rates of all the other Six States
but how are we affected by the policies
procedures of the other five states
conglomeration if you think about
what's proposed here for wind as one
example um New Hampshire has not signed
up to do procurements of offshore wind
it's been pretty clear that that's not
their priority but the other states have
and they've chosen to make a commitment
to develop projects and they've
committed their rate pairs so
Connecticut has done that Rhode Island
has done that and Massachusetts has done
that they're buying wind power they're
paying for the projects to be developed
and they're buying the output of those
plants uh into the future so that choice
does not affect uh New Hampshire rirs
directly because they're not committing
you for the purchase of those uh
resources so that's you know one example
now if the other New England states are
making Investments it will shift the
resource mix and over time we could see
displacement of uh older fossil fuel
plants uh we we've seen retirement of
most of the coal the one remaining coal
is here in New Hampshire and they've
announced plans to retire so we know
that the retirement of that part of the
fleet is
inevitable um but we do expect the gas
Fleet is going to run uh for a very long
time in the system and so maybe that
Fleet shifts from providing more uh base
load to more ramping Services um you
know that that could be an effect of
what's happening on the system uh but as
um representative mentioned as you
displace natural gas
for uh the grid with solar it does free
up gas for other purposes so I mean
every state has the potential to impact
what's happening uh with the resource
mix and the bulk power system but I I
would say for the most part the other
New England states Massachusetts
Connecticut Rhode Island are are
committing their own Rays based on the
procurements that that they're doing uh
for the resources that we're seeing in
this list I used wind as an example
they're doing the same thing with
battery
storage representative reos has a
question thank you Mr chair um yeah just
so again so clarifying question on on
this
Slide the interconnection queue just as
your earlier slide was headed markets
select the most cost eff efficient
resources to meet current and and future
electricity demands it says this is a
snapshot of what Market actors private
Capital are bringing
forward to build new generation in the
region right and certainly markets
shaped by policy as you said State
policies but the these are this is not
any but it's not your plan it's not
you're not soliciting this stuff this is
just what the market is bringing forward
yeah and when I when we talk about the
market we're talking about actors which
could be private companies investing or
it could be the states directing their
utilities to enter into agreements to
develop resources so yeah but the Q has
always been influenced by you know
policy to some extent for many years it
it was rational for uh developers to
want to build natural gas fire
generation because it was more efficient
um it was cleaner than the resources
that are operating before them coal and
you all
right so we just talked about the cue of
resources that we're looking at on the
supply side we also look at proposals to
connect to the system where the resource
itself might be outside of New England
and so developer would build
transmission uh from a neighboring area
into New England and all of those go
through the same uh study as well we
don't look at it from the perspective of
would this project have a benefit to New
England do we like where it's
interconnecting it's really just looking
at the reliability of it so uh currently
the New England clean energy connect
project would bring power from uh Quebec
uh down into Maine and that was largely
uh developed with support from uh
Massachusetts so again the iso is not
planning this but we're looking at the
reliability of the system as these
projects TI to try to interconnect and
so there's there's always been multiples
of those transmission projects uh under
study it all really all comes down to
can the developer get financing and
citing and permitting approval and it's
it's not an easy task to develop any
kind of energy infrastructure in New
England we could have a whole
conversation about that but whether
you're talking about transmission for
reliability transmission for Renewables
generation that's renewable all of these
projects face uh lots of challenges and
coming
online so speaking of transmission one
of our responsibilities is to look 5 to
10 years into the future make sure that
the transmission system can serve what
we forecast to be the demand for power
so there's 15 million of us here in New
England uh we make choices every day
about our energy use and so our job is
to forecast well what's that going to
look like
in the future so we do uh an annual
forecast we take all the latest economic
data we look at the policies from the
states we look at the weather and we
look out to say what we would use for
electricity uh this year next year and
every year for for 10 years uh that
drives a lot of the transmission
planning so for a number of years we saw
a growth in Peak demand of one to 2% so
we had to plan transmission to keep up
with that uh for about a decade we've
seen
investments in Energy Efficiency and
that slowed the growth in electricity
demand and we haven't seen as much
transmission needed for liability uh as
we'll get to in a moment we're now
seeing a big shift where the states have
said they want to drive the future
transmission needs to meet public policy
and and we'll talk about that in a
moment so the transmission planning
process is open uh we have a stakeholder
process that um is open to the public
there are restrictions around
information that is accessible because
we do deal with critical energy
infrastructure information so we don't
want to put a blueprint out into the um
public domain for people who might want
to sabotage the grid but we do try to do
planning in a an open process where
people can see um what's under study and
every couple years we put together a a
report which wraps up uh many of the
transmission planning studies and we
refer to that as our regional system
plan or RSP we did that 2023 we're going
to do that again in
2025 so I mentioned our planning Horizon
goes out 5 to 10 years and we didn't
have authorization from our regulator FK
to look beyond that and it does get
challenging to predict what the future
is going to be Beyond uh 10 years um but
we do know that this um many of the
states in the region have goals on the
electrification side and the
decarbonization side out to 2035 2040
and 2050
so we've had to go to firk get approval
to start looking longer term and and
we've gotten F's approval for that the
New England states developed in uh 2020
a renewable uh energy Vision uh this was
through the New England states committee
on
electricity uh all the states were a
part of that uh New Hampshire was was a
part of that uh process uh to some
degree and so the state said ISO we want
to look at scenarios for transmission to
support the electric electrification uh
of Transportation primarily and heating
in the wintertime so we did a big study
called the 2050 transmission study first
really long-term uh plan and Nathan if
you'll Jump Ahead uh to the
Chart uh this is showing uh really two
things what is our summer peak in yellow
and our winter peak in blue and 2023
it's pretty clear that we were as Nathan
said a summer peaking system we do have
a winter Peak but it's lower than the
summer but over time if we in fact do
see electrification of Transportation in
buildings and by buildings I mean
instead of using fossil fuels natural
gas uh heating oil for buildings you
have heat pumps and other electrified
Technologies um so then you're going to
see significant growth so the 2050 study
asked what would the transmission system
need to look like in order to
serve uh those higher electrification de
demands and so if you step back from
this chart the the demand on the grid is
in a sense going to double so it's a
it's a big uh big increase uh but it's
over a number of years out to
2050 um and we would shift to being a
winter peaking system so um Nathan if
you just back
up on the longer term transmission
planning side the 2050 study was not a
plan it didn't commit anybody to build
transmission uh the states and the iso
have since gone to firk and got approval
for a process where the states could in
fact uh identify transmission they
wanted to build and develop uh to meet
those longer term goals and we are
currently uh working to develop an RFP
request for proposals for
transmission and this is in close
coordination with States through the New
England um States committee on
electricity uh or Nesco um and new
hampsh is a is a is a member of Nesco
and is is part of uh those conversations
so the 2050 study is available it's
complete and there's a a short fact
sheet we've linked to the presentation
if anybody wants a little bit more
that and Mr chair I'll take a cue from
you on time we have a few more slides to
cover on some different study
work yes please continue okay so another
area that we've looked at is um not a
reliability study necessarily but uh an
economic planning study for the region
uh this one has the title economic
planning for the clean energy transition
so it's it's not just looking at uh the
load growth but it's looking at the
policies that the states have
set and most of the states and I'm very
mindful of where I'm at uh here in
conquer but most of the states are
looking for deep reductions in carbon
emissions so we have to model the system
based on what that would look like so we
take the existing Fleet of
Generation Um we take uh proposals that
have gone through the queue and have
been approved and then we figure out how
much new resource capability would we
need in New England to develop a
resource mix that meets those State
policy goals uh the report took a couple
of years again it was done through an
open process and all the results are
public but it really makes you think
about
balancing three uh different uh factors
one is the
economics uh second is uh the
carbon uh the carbon profile and the
third is
reliability um and so it's like a
three-legged stool in in some respect
and our job as Nathan said at the
beginning is thinking about the
reliability of the system and our vision
is as the States move to a system system
that has a uh clean uh
decarbonized uh Energy Mix we want to
make sure that we can keep the lights on
throughout the duration of uh of this
journey so this study gave us some uh
insights into what would what are some
of the challenges that New England
including the iso will face
um these are some of the key findings
I'll I'll highlight these
so we're going to see very sign
significant variabil in both the supply
and the
demand what does that mean
well depending on what the weather's
like uh in the winter if you Electrify
buildings for heating purposes if you
have a really cold winter that means
that year the demand's going to be
really high if you have a mild witer the
demand's going to be pretty low so
you're going to have to build a system
to meet the higher demand but some of
those resources are going to be idle in
in uh in years when it's milder um now
nobody wants to build a resource and
then be idle um they want to run and so
if there's more generation than we need
to meet demand then we would actually
curtail those resources but it does
present an opportunity to charge
batteries for example so if you develop
a bunch of offshore wind and it's
producing more than you have um needs
for electricity maybe that's when
somebody is going to be uh charging or
there's discussion about looking at
um hydrogen and it's a very energy
intensive to produce uh clean hydrogen
so maybe the Surplus um offshore wind as
one example could be used uh for that
purpose but from a planning perspective
we could see big swings and what the
demand would be year to year as we're
now tying heating to what's happening on
the electric
grid um the second finding is related uh
to emissions and well I know that
there's a desire to decarbonize the grid
and there's a desire to decarbonize the
economy um it's going to be hard to do
that completely and so there will be
times when we can probably decarbonize
fully in the spring and the fall when
you have lots of um renewable uh
production and the demand is a little
bit lower it's going to be harder to
decarbonize in the winter when you've
got really high demand and uh I don't
know if do we show that in I we don't
show that in this chart but there's um
some exhibits within the upset report
which will show we're going to get to a
decarbonized state in this 2050 time
frame uh for most of the year but it's
going to be really hard to get fully
decarbonized uh in the winter so that's
on the emission side um when we think
about the renewable
buildout and I think some of you have
kind of sensed this if you have a 100
megawatt uh wind farm that wind farm is
not going to produce 100 megawatts all
the time um a an existing gas fired
plant or a nuclear plant they provide a
pretty steady output or they're
dispatchable whenever we need them so if
you're really going to build a system
Around clean and renewable energy you're
going to have to build more than you
would
need because the output of those wind
facilities is not going to be 100% all
the time they might have a name plate
rating but their actual output is
dependent on what's happening with the
weather so I noticed you use the word
vast in the bullet renewable only build
outs may be vast is the word vast going
to be applied to the cost of these of
this
buildout um it it's going to cost a a
lot of money to develop new resources in
New England whether you're talking about
wind whether you're talking
about um new types of nuclear technology
uh none of these Technologies are cheap
um so this epet resport epet report is
not looking at like the cost allocation
who's going to pay for all this or how's
it going to be allocated among the
states it's really just looking at what
what would the system look like in order
to meet those decarbonization goals and
to give you a frame of reference for
vast the New England power grid today
has about 30,00
megawatts of generation Our Peak demand
is about 28,000 so we're kind of Surplus
on paper for Our
Generation Um the epet report identified
that we would need to add about uh 97
gws or
97,000 megawatts on a system that's
already 30,000 so when we say vast you
need to develop a lot of resources to
get all of your energy from wind and
solar and batteries are a part of the
study as well so the last point in the
study is you're still going to need
resources that are dispatchable that's
very important to the iso because we
don't
want to disconnect anybody from the
system because you know the demand is
really high in any given day from from
July 1 1997 we've been focused on
keeping the lights on uh in the region
so we're going to need resources that
can ramp up and down today that's
natural gas uh there may be
Technologies uh smrs in the future that
could provide uh that capability and and
things that aren't even commercial at
that point we're going to be counting
them but you're going to need
dispatchable resources and lots of them
in a system where you're using lots of
resources and that's representative
Bernardi would like to ask a
question so considering the need for
dispatchable resources have you looked
gas so New England's pretty constrained
it's it's it's not a secret and in years
past the iso has talked about uh natural
gas um gas fired power plants being
constrained in the winter particularly
it's not an issue so much in the
summertime because there's no heating
demand that's drawing on natural gas um
but the region is effectively said no
they're not going to develop more
natural gas infrastructure and one of
the first slides Nathan talked about is
what we don't do we don't plan the fuel
side of the system we spent a lot of
time thinking about it because Gas and
Electric are closely
interrelated um but a decision to
develop fuel infrastructure would have
iso representative uh schneller has a
question thank you chairman Vose uh
you've referenced zero carbon
decarbonization several
times is that a baseline assumption for
everything we're talking about is there
a study that leads you to all of these I
I guess these are conclusions and and
you're basing your planning
on decarbonization is is there a study
that we could reference
um that you're basing all of these
assumptions on in other words is there
another direction to go
yeah you could think of the study I was
just talking about the epet study as um
a scenario analysis we're not saying the
region should or will develop the
resources that are identified in this
plan but it was based on the
decarbonization and the electrification
goal
of most of the states in New England
that's what's driving it and we could go
in another direction we could we could
see uh different Technologies come
forward
um but the the primary policy direction
from most New England is they want to uh
shut down older fossil plants uh
eventually most of the fossil Fleet and
have a system that is um
renewable and you know by state
definition clean I mean clean is not a
technical term that comes from the iso
but could we go in a different direction
yes but that's the really the
prerogative of policy makers like you
and your colleagues in the other
states thank you Vice chair
Thomas thank you thanks for taking my
question so I just want to clarify a
statement that you made involving you
don't get involved with the fuels um
so am I right to understand then what
you meant was you can put out a
report that shows the projections of
what's coming down line and let's say
you are aware of we're we're not going
to have enough base load but you can't
put out
a an indication that hey we need to put
some fuel plants in some areas here to
make sure that we have enough in the
future you you are are you implying that
you just you put out the info of what's
out there or what's coming and you hope
that either the some private entity or
some State comes over and says hey we're
going to build something well I think it
comes back to what's our Authority under
the federal power act and Authority that
FK has given to us uh it is only for the
Electric System so we do a lot of
analysis uh that looks at the fuel
system but we really rely on the markets
to drive incentives for investment in
resources
so let's assume that we're not going to
see more gas pipeline into the region to
support Power Generation Well the other
option is that a gas fired generator
could develop on-site fuel oil
capability as a backup resource so if
they can't pull fuel from the pipelines
they could use uh inventory on site or
they could contract for l G to be
imported into New England through Boston
or New Brunswick so yeah we're
identifying what the I guess some of the
the risks are uh for the system but we
we couldn't do an RFP for gas pipeline
for example um the developers of the new
resources have to figure out how they're
going to get their fuel um I mean wind
is a resource that has no has no fuel
but of course the capital costs are
substantial so they have to figure out
how to get Capital to develop those
resources I noticed that none of the
charts that you've shown us here today
talk about net Imports but when I look
at the iso to go app I frequently see
that net Imports are supplying a
substantial amount of our electricity
like right now it's 211% I just
looked where does that electricity
typically come from is that from Canada
typically yeah so I think Nathan showed
it in one of the earlier slides um
annually over the past decade between 13
and 19% of our electricity needs in New
England come from Imports um most of it
is from Quebec and you can think of uh
Hydro Quebec as 98% you know Hydro um we
can import power from New Brunswick that
could be whatever is operating on their
system but they have the Point lepro
Nuclear facility they have wind as well
um the primary flow is north to south so
from Canada into New England and then
out to New York um based on the
economics so Canada wants to sell to us
because it's a attractive market for
them as a seller and New York has high
demands so they typically want to buy
Power from New England uh as well but
what you're seeing on the app is a
snapshot which is going to change you
know minute to minute but on an annual
basis you you know it's in the teens the
amount of electricity that comes from
Imports representative Wendy Thomas
thank you uh Mr chair um thank you for
being here it's good to see you guys
again
um we know that our climate is becoming
unpredictable um we've got more winds
we've got more flooding and we have more
storms um I saw the predictions of the
charts for everything that's in the
queue and I saw the the slide you didn't
cover it but the one with the pill
and I'm wondering if uh climate
resiliency is in your
purview not explicitly but we've started
to do some uh probabilistic studies of
uh extreme
weather and so that's uh through a new
tool that we've developed probabilistic
energy adequacy tool Pete and uh that
gives us a sense of um can we operate
the system on the really
extreme uh weather that we've seen if
you go back to like 1970 there are times
when there's pretty extreme weather it's
hard to forecast like when is that
extreme weather going to show up again
right um but we do have some new tools
and the states and when I I've used the
states a number of times but when I talk
about the states It's usually the public
utility commissions and the folks from
Nesco who are sort of looking long-term
at the resource mix and so they've said
ISO can you help us sort of gauge what
are some of the risks of extreme weather
so we now have those tools uh we
developed that for this winter we use
that new uh model uh it showed us that
we have adequate resources for uh this
winter but if you take a number of
Legacy resources off the system add a
bunch of the resources that are in the
queue that's going to change um how the
systems going to operate and that tool
lets us do a Refresh on an at least an
annual basis or more often to figure out
how do how do we plan for that extreme
weather and at some point New England
may decide we need to hedge against some
of these risks um and so there's a
process that's underway right now uh
that's looking at what we call Regional
energy uh shortfall
threshold and the states are involved uh
in that so the I think of the iso as a
entity that can provide a lot of
technical analysis to the states that
individually they not might not possess
and then helps them figure out you know
which transmission projects do they want
to build uh which um you know resources
for reliability what might we need to uh
think differently about
so so not explicitly but we try to
provide some analysis to inform policy
makers about that excellent thank you
very much representative
Kaplan yeah thank you Mr chair and then
thank you gentlemen for coming in uh
today uh is that for two questions is
that that Pete publicly accessible and
secondly uh just an engineering question
uh about the Imports coming in from
Quebec and New York state or mainly
about Quebec I guess because that's
coming through New Hampshire that
transmission line uh is any of that
electricity are those electrons ever
flowing into New Hampshire or are they
going straight to Southern New England I
I'm just curious about that so on the
first question yes everything related to
the Pete tool is public it's on our
website if if we don't have a link to it
in the presentation Nathan will follow
and make that uh available
um does the imports
from Quebec flow into New
Hampshire
um I I would say yes but it's really
flowing into the entire New England pool
when you come to the iso and look at the
big board and we'd love to have you come
down you're not going to see the state
of New Hampshire the boundaries of the
state or any other state it's it's the
electric transmission system and
electrons don't really respect State
Bound
um so you could probably uh quantify
that but it's really coming into the
system as a whole and then that the
amount of transmission you have will
determine where that power
flows representative Corman thank you Mr
chairman and thank you for being here uh
I looked through the slides I don't you
haven't talked about and there isn't
anything in the slides about the uh the
auctions the day ahead and spot Market
auctions that that ISO operates and I'm
just wondering um money's coming in
money's going out ultimately it's going
to uh I would imagine the the actual
generators uh how much of it is actually
flowing through ISO or or are you just
conducting an auction and and not
handling the money and a related
question where does your funding come
from okay good question so I'll take the
last one first so there's a um what we
call a tariff which is a document that
we file with FK to recover our cost
and because we're we didn't say this but
we're a nonprofit so we can't make any
profit on what's happening in the in the
wholesale market so we do a forecast of
what our Revenue requirements are would
be for the year and we develop a budget
and then we collect a essentially a fee
from all the participants in the market
so larger participants are going to
contribute more to that uh smaller
resources would contribute less uh at
the end of the year we have to do a true
up so if we collect more Revenue than we
need we don't keep it it goes into the
adjustment for the following year um we
file a budget with firk we meet with all
the states uh each year to discuss the
budget uh verk approves it it's on a
calendary year so usually goes in uh
October they approve it by December and
it's effective uh January one uh the
budget for the iso is about uh $200
million and that's for all the
operations in western Mass and then we
have a redundant facility in Connecticut
so that's all we own just those two
properties nothing out in the field um
terms of the auctions we run a lot of
auctions we run auctions on a daily
basis for the energy market and we run
auctions on a forward basis for uh
capacity although we've we've paused on
that uh we have a project that's
examining how we do procurements for
capacity instead of looking three years
into the future we propose that we do
those auctions on a uh on an annual
basis um with some different products
but the I think what you're getting to
is the the auctions for energy on a
daily basis so uh every resource is
offering to sell Power into the market
you mentioned generators but it could be
uh suppliers they might not own power
plants but they have arrangements with
other resources somebody might be lining
up power from Quebec or in New York and
so we look at what's the demand and we
select the lowest price resources on the
system and when those things come into
balance then that sets the clearing
price uh for the
market that money will flow through the
iso for um for the system what we what
we don't uh control
is um outof Market agreements or
purchase power
agreements um that's not regulated or
under uh our jurisdiction so
yeah we would collect essentially
payments from load or utilities or
suppliers and make payments to the
resources that provided the power uh for
those auction periods and we've got a
one-day class if you want to learn about
that it's just for public officials and
Regulators you might be a great
candidate for
that representative Summers has your
question thank you Mr chairman and thank
you for taking my question last term we
had a uh if I remember correctly
Christmas Eve where we had a a cold snap
here in New England and uh where on the
rates on even on your site where
kilowatt per hour went up to close to
$3,000 per kilowatt temporarily because
of the um because of that and um with
the with the risk of rolling blackouts
near in the uh North North part of New
Hampshire um and with that at that same
time I believe if correct me if I'm
wrong I believe Mystic was shut down
temporarily at that time so um the
firing up of the B the bow coal plant
had to be had to take effect for that
and um now with Mystic being shut down
permanently uh how what how are we
protected or how's what's the remedy for
if this happens again where we have a
cold snap like this and the price of the
is this where the um snapshot pricing
comes into effect yeah you can see
pricing in real time the mobile app has
it the iso website has it
um we were not in New England England uh
close to Rolling blackouts on Christmas
Eve other parts of the country were in a
very deep freeze they had some serious
reliability uh challenges some parts of
the country were doing controlled
outages or load shedding um we
instituted some very low-level
procedures uh capacity deficiency
procedures um but we did not get
anywhere near the edge of uh reliability
risks on on Christmas Eve um but the
Mystic plants two large gas fired plants
are now retired um and so what that
means is every other resource in the
system then becomes uh a candidate to
replace that energy so maybe a resource
that didn't get called on because the
Mystic was running would now be called
on and it could be one of
the one of the coal plants uh
potentially but we know they're going to
retire at some point
so you're going to have new Supply
coming down from Quebec from the New
so we we can't keep plants that are
online from retiring I mean the Mystic
plant we we held them for two years
under a very controversial arrangement
with um the owners it had to go to FK
for approval people did not like it um
but the iso doesn't have the ability to
say you should build this plant or you
can't retire this plant we're kind of
dealt with the uh we deal with the cards
were dealt in that respect but other
resources have to make up that that Gap
Vice chair Thomas has a question thank
you Mr chair um along that line of last
questioning I recall I think it was a
couple of years ago might have been
three I'm not sure that that ISO put out
a notice primarily to the utilities to
effectively brush up on their uh
emergency blackout procedures because uh
the notice effectively said that there
was increased risk in the next few years
depending on how severe the winter
weather was of potential to have rolling
blackouts um so along that line um I
think one part of your emission that we
haven't heard too much here is uh one of
your major portions of your mission is
to actually manage the grid we have a
couple of we have several new members
here could you could you go into a short
description of how your control room
managed the grid and what happens and
how they tell utilities when to turn on
when to turn off turn off and so forth
here a little brief overview because
that is a major part of of your mission
yeah so um let's imagine that everybody
in this room at the table uh owns some
type of generation okay um
representative Kaplan uh owns a resource
that's really
expensive and representative Plaza
PL right he owns the
resource that's uh relatively
inexpensive and so we're going to stack
up all these resources from highest
price to lowest price um the the amount
of resources that we call on is only
based on what we expect to be used and
it usually lands somewhere in the middle
all right so that means all of these
resources are going to get picked all
these resources would not get picked
that day they don't run they don't get
paid uh but if the were to go up we
might have to go a little further into
that resource mix and maybe a resource
that didn't get picked and the previous
hour gets picked in the next hour so the
iso is doing that um continuously
throughout the day turning resources on
and off to meet the demand or ramping uh
up and down that's our reliability
function and we've done that since uh 19
uh
97 the utilities don't own generation
for the most part uh in New England so
it's not the utilities that are offering
to sell Power it's private companies
that that are doing that but if we get
into an
emergency uh we'll call on every
resource that's available uh we'll go
all the way up the supply stack no
matter how expensive it is if we need it
to keep the lights on but there might be
a point where the demand goes past the
resources that we have and maybe our
neighbors don't have any more power to
send to us so we do have emergency
procedures where we'd reach out to the
utilities to say they need to take
demand off the system uh we've never had
to do that uh but we to representative
Thomas's um point we have talked to you
utilities and make sure that if we got
to that state that they could respond
why would we do that well people might
say well that's terrible why would the
iso order the utilities to cut people's
power because we're trying to keep the
whole grid operating and if you let
demand go past what you have for Supply
the grid becomes unstable and instead of
a few customers losing power the whole
grid can come down it's never happened
so we have emergency procedures to deal
with that we take that very seriously
and we want to know if we tell the
utilities they need to take 5% of the
demand on the system off or 10% uh they
need to do that we can give them that
that instruction and under requirements
by the North American Electric
reliability Corporation they need to act
within minutes to make that happen so um
it's a very important part of the
responsibility now we don't live on the
edge like that but you do need to have
those procedures in effect thank you
that was an excellent description of how
your resource stacking Works using this
horseshoe okay well done representative
Swanson has a
question thank you Mr chair uh thank you
gentlemen for being here and the
information I find it very insightful to
flip between slide 10 and slide
15 and uh I you know slide 10 being
representative of
2023 and slide 15 being representative
of the basket of proposals that you've
received for what I would perceive as
proposed
Investments and uh uh what I'm not
surprised that the proposals don't
include natural gas but I am surprised
that they don't include nuclear
uh can you ex do you have any insight as
to why nobody's proposing any
nuclear I mean an otally only we haven't
seen proposals for new nuclear in uh
decades we have seen the existing
nuclear plants make some improvements at
their sites where they can get some
additional megawatts out of those plants
and so we've captured that and studied
it uh in the queue
it it again Falls outside of what we can
control but the economics of building
nuclear are um pretty significant the
the last nuclear plant to come online
down in uh down in the South was the
cost overruns were
massive um and so the question is well
who's going to take the risk that they
can build that plant and get that power
online um within a budget so down south
and and they're not operating in a
market system where they're putting
private Capital At Risk the rate payers
basically bore the cost of that
um those overruns so I would be
surprised if you saw another Seabrook or
Millstone plant developed in New England
but you could see somebody say we have a
potential for developing small modular
reactors uh I we think that's uh that's
probably part of the future there's also
a a strong nimi sense around nuclear I
mean there's people who would say it's
clean energy it's dispatchable it has a
lot of attributes that we think are
valuable our epet study showed that but
you still have to convince a community
to become a host for one of these
facilities thank
you okay why don't you guys give us your
your final wrap up because we need to
move on okay uh it's been an excellent
presentation and we thank you for being
here uh we'll give you the last word and
then um let you get back down to uh
Massachusetts well why don't we leave
with a invite we'd love to have the
committee come and visit you've been
down before uh we'll show you the
operations center uh we'll dive a little
bit deeper into some of these topics and
um I think it's always been a valuable
opportunity for you and for us to learn
about what's on your mind and show you
show you the operation that you're a
part of thank you for that invitation U
many of us have made multiple trips down
to ISO New England it's always a
pleasure to visit there and this being a
budget year if we can squeeze that into
our schedule we we will attempt to do so
it contact information Nathan's going to
follow up with the committee to provide
both of our contact
information and you going to provide
those two extra charts we talked about
yeah I think one of them actually I
found it in the presentation but we'll
uh follow maybe i y
okay time to move along so we have
another presentation next up on the
docket and that is a presentation by New
Hampshire's joint
utilities The Joint utilities are
comprised of eversource Unitil Liberty
and the New Hampshire Electric
Co-op and I have
asked Griffin robarge of ever source to
organize the joint utilities
presentation and so I'm going to turn
over
to to Griffin in just a
moment um the floor and he will lead us
presentation it looks like maybe he's
going to pass something out so maybe Mr
Lata you could um give us an opening
introduction good morning everybody uh
for the record Michael Lata uh with
eversource energy really appreciate the
opportunity to come uh before you today
uh as the chair said we kind of
organized uh The Joint utilities
together so uh we have one presentation
deck that you're all receiving paper
copies of uh we'll each kind of take
turns coming to the microphone to to
present about our individual companies
and different topics um with me today is
uh Griffin Roberge I'm uh the director
of government and community relations
for eversource here in New Hampshire uh
Griffin is our manager of government
Affairs uh for eversource we have a
handful of slides to go through um
cognizant of the time we'll try to move
through those quickly um you know if
it's if it's okay with the chair we'd be
happy to take questions as we move along
um but I would just say Griffin and I
are are here a lot uh and so if you
don't catch us or we don't have time to
answer your question you can either ask
us later today you can call us email us
or I'm quite certain we'll be here next
after so thank you Mike uh again I think
this committee is uh aware of me Griffin
robers manager of government Affairs at
eversource now um I wanted to obviously
following up on what Mike said Thank you
for allowing us to uh present today and
congratulations to each of you on your
elections or re-elections um as Mike
mentioned we'll be here regularly so
feel free to reach out if you have any
questions or constituent issues uh and
that type of thing happy to assist where
we can can um so a little bit about
eversource um we provide electric gas
and water service to our customers
across three states in New England
that's New Hampshire Connecticut and
Massachusetts all told across those
three states eversource serves about 4.4
million customers in New Hampshire Alone
um eversource provides about um sorry
provides electric service to about
550,000 retail customers as well as
about 184,000 wholesale cust customers
these These are customers who tend to be
served by other utilities like unitel
Municipal Utilities the co-op um but
they may utilize our infrastructure to
serve their customers in their
territories um we here in the state
eversource has we have about 1,500
employees who do anything from Line work
Energy Efficiency customer service or
government Affairs um these employees
operate out of uh different offices
across the state uh our headquarters is
here in New Hampshire is located in
Manchester uh called Energy Park and our
employees also work out of any one of
the 15 area work centers uh across the
state such as in Nashua Lancaster Kean
Rochester number of them across the
state and so many of our line Crews tend
to operate out of these locations doing
various things on our on our system such
as pole replacement vegetation
management installing new service for
customers those types of things um we
are also responsible as the large as the
largest electric utility in the state
State um for uh we're responsible for
1,000 miles of transmission
infrastructure as well as 14,000 Mi of
distribution line um so we continually
strive to ensure the resiliency of our
system of our infrastructure um and
provide customers with safe and reliable
service to continue to meet or exceed
their expectations so I'll turn it back
over to Mike to give a little bit more
of an overview on how the brid works
thanks Griffin um just one quick note
here uh folks uh are familiar with the
the name uh PSNH Public Service of New
Hampshire I would just note that still
is our legal name uh we are public
service in New Hampshire doing business
as eversource en as eversource energy uh
one of the reasons for that is PSNH is
referenced in many many uh State
statutes and so in order to affect that
change we would have to come to you to
change many of those State
statutes uh so I I know you saw a
variation of this slide yesterday with
the Department of energy I just want to
spend a minute or two on it because I
think it is um helpful to Define sort of
what companies like uh eversource own
what third parties own so uh starting
with Generation Um I know you got a
presentation from NEP yesterday so in
2015 uh eversource PSNH uh did divest of
all of our power plants so we are
strictly a a poles and wires company uh
at this time so so uh generation is
owned by Third parties uh and we do
procure that power on behalf of our
customers uh which is known as default
Service uh but that is not something
that the the company owns uh
anymore uh in terms of what we do own
and what we do operate uh we do own uh
the transmission system or part of the
transmission system in New Hampshire uh
these are the the larger higher voltage
wires that tend to run uh off-road
rights of way
uh those interconnect with substations
which is a critical piece of the
Electric System uh those substation step
down voltages uh and then that feeds
into the distribution system you could
also have a distribution sub substation
where you have multiple circuits that
all tie together and then the
distribution system which are the poles
and wires you largely see uh roadside
that provide service um to customers uh
and use customers whether they're
residential or or business and I I would
just note one thing on um this graphic
which it shows kind of the traditional
um construction of the electricity
Network where you have a large power
plant transmission set down to
distribution uh certainly as as folks
are aware uh the power grid has been and
continues to be in a state of change
where we have customers who are
generating uh on site we have multiple
uh flows of power and so you know this
is sort of a a very crude kind of
traditional uh graphic just to to sort
components uh and speaking of of
components I find it's always helpful to
to do a little bit of a review of
customers bills and the electric rates
that they pay again I know uh the
department of energy presented um a pie
chart on this yesterday I think they
used 650 kilowatt hours uh we used 6 100
uh so if you see slightly different
numbers uh that might might uh explain
it but just to tick through the
different components of the bill and and
this is effective as of today as has
been mentioned our uh default service
rate is scheduled to change uh in in
February it will go down to uh 8.9 cents
8.9 to9 I believe um but starting with
default Service uh that is uh a product
that we purchase on on behalf of our
customers from the uh regional market so
uh the way that this used to work it was
a little bit simpler every six months we
would issue uh rfps for customer load uh
we would get responses back from the
marketplace we would select the lowest
cost bidder and that was sort of the
fixed charge uh that that customers
would pay uh this is a direct pass
through uh the company does not make any
uh money on this whatever we pay is what
our customers uh pay pay uh as
commissioner chattai discussed yesterday
there was a recent change in that where
we were directed by the Public Utilities
Commission to go direct to the market uh
he termed it self-supply so I believe
it's around 30% of our um default
service procurement now uh bypasses that
RFP and we're purchasing direct from the
market and he I in the interest of time
I won't go into the reasons behind that
thought he did a nice job of explaining
the commission's uh thought process
there uh default Services where you also
see um sort of the charges for uh the
renewable portfolio standard are
compliance with with that state law
manifest as well as sort of the what I
would call embedded costs of Reggie
which I know um was discussed this
morning about how Regional power plants
sort of build that cost of compliance
into uh into their products so that's
all contained within the uh default
service rate which is the largest single
component of the
bill uh moving down the distribution
charge is really separated into two
separate uh charges one is a fixed
charge the customer charge this is some
kind also called the meter charge it
really pays for um the the metering the
billing systems kind of that back office
that every customer uh relies on
regardless of the amount of usage and
then we have the volumetric uh
distribution charge and that is uh an
area that that is regulated by the New
Hampshire Public Utilities Commission
those rates are set um every few years
when a utility files are rate case those
are fairly significant undertakings uh
we are currently have a rate case before
the Public Utilities Commission right
now uh so that is uh how those rates are
Set uh next we have the transmission
charge which again is uh pays for that
uh bulk kind of transmission system uh
that is as the ISO
uh just discussed regulated by the
Federal Energy Regulatory Commission and
that rate is really set by each utility
uh customers share of usage during
certain peak times so if you imagine the
entirety of the cost of of uh the
regional transmission system or the
local transmission system uh the rate is
based upon uh essentially the share of
usage during peak time so if someone's
uh one utility is using a lot more uh at
that time they would pay a greater share
versus a smaller share uh and then
finally we have a number of other
charges normally I'd group these
together but I was asked to kind of
explain what each one of these little uh
smaller charges is um so one the systems
benefits charge I think folks are
generally familiar with this pays for
both the uh Energy Efficiency programs
the New Hampshire saves programs uh that
rate has been set into law by this
legislature uh just a few years years
ago um the the budgets uh for the Energy
Efficiency programs and then also the uh
electric energy assistance program EAP
is contained within the systems benefits
charge the SCRC or stranded cost
recovery charge uh is is now actually
more than just stranded costs but that
uh pays for past uh Investments that the
utility has made uh that we need to get
cost recovery for as well as uh certain
purchase power agree payments uh net
metering costs are recovered through the
stranded cost recovery charge as well so
it's the uh payments that we make to uh
to those customers who are exporting uh
and participating in the net metering
program uh for example the Burgess
biomass uh purchase power agreement the
costs associated with that uh flow
through the SCC although you know that
has come to an end the the agreement uh
the ppam because we don't have enough
acronis acronyms is the pole plant
adjustment mechanism uh this is uh
specific to
eversource back in 2023 uh we purchased
uh Consolidated Communications utility
polls and this is uh the cost associated
with that purchase and be happy to go
into a deeper dive at a future time if
folks have questions about why we
purchase those polls uh and then finally
the
r is uh um regulatory reconciliation
adjustment uh this is a product of our
last rate case where certain charges um
including uh some net metering charges
uh consultant charges are are flowed
through this actually negative right now
so it's actually a credit to customers
it's a very very small charge but it
does show up on customers bills yes sir
say the um Acron regulatory what
regulatory uh reconciliation
problem yes we can do questions now did
you have did somebody have one
representative Wendy Thomas thank you Mr
chair um just you mentioned the rate
setting um just curious how that works
do you go in with a high level hoping to
negotiate it down to something else or
do you have to go in with an actual
number that it's proven by statistics
how does that work yeah thank you for
the question so uh utilities set rates
um I'll say every few years based upon
their earnings so uh the way that it it
essentially works is uh we have a test
year and during that test year we are
looking at all of our our costs our
expenses our Capital SP spending uh and
clearly documenting that although uh our
Regulators look at our actual spending
that goes beyond that and so we have an
allowed uh rate of return that we're
allowed to achieve and just to be very
clear that's a ceiling not a floor uh a
lot of times it gets described as a
guaranteed rate of return it is not um
so you know our allowed rate of return
currently is up to 9.3 3% that was out
of our last rate case which was in 2019
so we had a test year in 2018 where we
sort of documented all of our spending
we went to the commission and I believe
we were under earning at the time and
said these are all all of our spending
this is what we've invested in these are
our capital projects and they quite
frankly look through the receipts uh and
then we would say you know we are not
earning near our allowed rate of return
We would like to adjust our rate upward
uh in order to allow for the spending
that we need uh to continue the safe and
reliable service of of the grid uh so it
really is uh it's a voluminous document
uh it's a series of voluminous documents
quite frankly um and they go through all
of our Capital spending all of our our
expenses there are many rounds of
Discovery where they question and prod
and ask questions um and so uh it is
very much uh based upon our our true
costs follow up follow up and is the
result either a yes or no or is it a
compromise at times uh so there there
can be compromise throughout uh so we
might uh you know we'll hire experts who
say our allowed rate of return should be
X and the different parties will hire
Consultants who say it should be why
there are lots of different components
uh within uh within this
uh about how the cost of recovery is it
how much is in the volumetric charge
versus the fixed charge you know it's it
can get complicated fast as you might
imagine Vice chair Thomas uh thank you
Mr chair thanks for taking my question
really quick just to clarify so I I have
an understanding and for our new members
too the um the items you just listed
under the um the one from from New
Hampshire laws and policies if you were
to add up those
costs and times your 600 kilow that
would be like about
month I you know I'm a polyi major and I
always make a point not to do math on
the fly but that sounds close Yes sounds
yeah well that that sounds pretty close
to my non-mathematical Mone I just want
to make sure that we were doing it
correctly on this I I I think this is a
I would be more than happy to to send
information but I think it's around 140
or so dollars uh for a customer using uh
600 kilowatt hours in
total per month you mean for the entire
chart yes oh yeah I was just talking
about yeah so so 7% of that $111 that
sounds about right I see yeah you went
oh you went that way thank you right
again non-mathematical mind might be
doing it the wrong way representative
nter has a question
thank you if we didn't have the
divesture would the energy cost be less
for rate payers
today so the goal of divesture was to
actually save customers money uh so
those uh our Fleet uh our Our Generation
portfolio uh was was older um we were
seeing that it was less and less we'll
say uh competitive with the marketplace
and the goal of devest was to
essentially remove customers from being
um uh required to continue to uh uh
invest in those plants and so that was
was the goal of
it did you have a
succeed uh so
I I'll have to give you a more Fuller
answer I know the projections at the
time were that it would save customers
million representative Corman has a
question thank you Mr chairman and thank
you both for being here always a
pleasure to see both of you um you said
that the stranded costs included net
metering uh that doesn't include like if
I'm if I'm an eversource customer and
I'm net metering and I'm getting so much
per kilowatt hour I'm putting back onto
the
grid that's not coming out of the
stranded cost is it what what you're
paying me that's not coming out of the
stranded costs is it yes that's correct
it is we we used to recover that from
the default service charge uh but since
all customers are eligible to to be uh
net metered it's a state program
um several years ago it was shifted to
the stranded cost recovery charge so the
compensation for customers exports flows
through the stranded cost recovery
charge it is not a stranded cost uh but
it is a that is the non- bypassable
mechanism that uh we utilize to recover
to recover those costs followup so it it
it's not reflected in just a lower
demand uh for electricity that you're
buying on the market so reductions in
demand associated with uh exports are
reflected uh through our load settlement
project process so essentially we need
too and and I know there's legislation
on this uh so it might be better to do a
deeper dive at that point uh but
essentially we have to account for all
the electrons coming into our system uh
and so it is accounted for uh through
that and any reductions in in that
customers let's keep moving here great
um so moving on and just taking a a at
my watch because I know we have the
other utilities uh to go uh this is a
very busy slide I'm going to move
through it really quickly um
so the Investments the the money that we
have have spent that we just talked
about our rates uh really our our focus
is providing reliable and safe uh
service to our customers so uh we have
seen um significant uh benefits in terms
of reliability that our customers are
currently uh currently seeing due to
those Investments so uh the first chart
is uh MBI that's uh months between
Interruption and the short answer here
is you want a higher number there so you
can see the trend line uh that our
customers are now uh 18.1 months uh
between Interruption that excludes major
storms uh the next Slide the next chart
is uh is KD that's customer average
disruption index uh that really is on a
customer basis how long it takes for us
to restore you if you do have an average
and we want that number to be um uh to
be lower so the lower is the better
there uh and you can see that's a little
bit leveled off but we did have uh make
some progress on that um in
2024 uh and then the last one sad uh is
the the system average disruption index
uh and that's really looking at as a
system basis the duration of of our
outages uh again a lower number here is
better uh and you can see a good trend
line uh there uh and then the bar chart
at the bottom uh each one of those bars
represents a year uh and really I I want
to call folks attention to um uh the
first uh which is showing how many
customers when we do have an outage
we're able to
restore almost immediately Within 1 to 5
minutes so that's without having to roll
a truck without having to have a crew on
site uh making repairs and 51% of our
outages uh last year we were able to
restore within five minutes uh and so
customers you know might have seen a
flicker they might have SE seen a blip
I'm sure everyone in the room sorry
Griffin uh ex probably experienced that
that is you know what we would call uh
our smart switches our reclosers the the
selfhealing grid where you know a tree
branch hits on a line uh and we're able
to to the switch will come out but it'll
come back in once the branch clears as
opposed to the fuse staying out we got
to roll a truck so uh really focusing on
on customer experience uh and meeting
customer expectations which we'll talk
about in a minute uh the other uh bar
charts at the bottom there uh we want
lower because so those are are you know
how long it takes for us to resp respond
when we do have to go out uh and make
repairs and so obviously we're seeing
there representative Corman so uh the
the two that are for an with an index I
mean I don't know what the index is it's
relative to
what so so you're looking at um we're
talking about minutes uh we're talking
about you know in terms of the months um
you know I'd be happy to give you a more
Fuller explanation of Katie and and safy
S excuse me follow up so I mean for for
example the the green one the leftmost
number is 100.9 that's not minutes
that's relative to
something I'll defer to I'll be happy to
you great okay two more slides awesome
um so just oh there we go just to give a
little bit more insight on onto our
restoration process I think Mike queued
it up well you know we have eversource
has continued to make investments in
infrastructure to you know continue to
meet growing customer expectations and
to ensure the reliability and resiliency
of our system even in the face of those
uh major weather events that Mike had
referenced um you know when major
weather outages occur from weather or
other events you know we do have a very
robust restoration process that focuses
on customer communication and restoring
customers as quickly as possible
I think the slide you see before you you
know there's some text it kind of gives
some step byep on how we restore but I
just going to focus more on the
communication portion of it so you know
starting in the committee room here you
know we offer regular Communications to
State elected officials when major
weather events occur so you'll often see
an email most likely from Mike or ey you
know describing whatever sources planned
response will be uh prep work is for a
major weather event where things stand
as the uh storm progresses and kind of
give you some resolution toward uh the
end when when everybody else is restored
so you know that's an Avenue for you
folks if there's something that comes up
in your neck of the woods you really
need to you know communicate with us
Mike and I are you guys you know feel
free to reach out to us there um going
down to your local communities you know
before storms occur a lot of our
community Liaisons work directly with
Municipal officials to identify
important local infrastructure that is a
priority for that community so it could
be a senior living facility a fire
department or I'm sorry a fire station a
police station those types of things um
to really identify those as the
important local infrastructure resources
for a community as well as to identify
important contacts when uh emergencies
occur you know whether that's a Town
Administrator a mayor a road agent Etc
um so we work very closely with that uh
we also offer training with local
officials with our staff to to learn
what to do in the event of an outage if
say a wire goes down a pole is broken
those types of things we also uh created
and run a portal for municipal officials
called the munih Hub um this is a portal
that Municipal officials can use to
directly interact with us and report a
priority issue so that it gets to the
top of our list and we can address it as
quickly as possible um moving on you
know a little bit further down to um
residential customers you know we notify
them regularly through email and text
Communications when outages occur we
encourage them to communicate with us
you know if issues arise if a poll goes
down near their house if there's a wire
down that type of thing and give them
estimated times for uh restoration so
with that I think it's a good uh segue
into you know frequent and more historic
storms that we're seeing so I'll kick
that back over the mic thanks Griffin
and this is our our last slide and uh
really what we wanted to show here was
um The increased frequency and severity
of the storms uh quite frankly that
we're encountering uh on an annual basis
and is you can see this is uh data that
we uh that we pulled from the New
Hampshire Department of energy of the
the top 10 storms uh most impactful
storms uh up until uh last year the ice
storm in '08 which I'm sure many of us
remember was number one uh the spring
nor Easter last year which dumped uh
very very heavy wet snow on the central
part of the State uh eclipsed that uh so
that is now we have a new number one uh
we've seen really over the past uh two
years uh for storms that are now in the
top 10 and have moved other storms down
and so um you know these are very
challenging storms they're extremely
damaging uh to our our system and I
would just say the the backdrop uh or
the challenge we face as a utility is
increasing customer expectations for us
to get the power back on um so again
that spring nor Easter uh we were able
to get uh substantial restoration within
4 days uh and we had the you know solar
eclipse uh that you know a day later and
there was a lot of pressure to to get
that done because a lot of people were
coming up north uh to view that you know
compared to the 2008 I storm which took
14 days uh I I think if uh you know we
went 14 days uh now people would be
lining up with torches outside of of
energy Park uh so the backdrop is you
know really increasing customer
expectations that the lights will come
back on quicker while we're seeing these
more frequent more damaging uh storms
that we have to deal with so that's a
16-year period that this table covers
and uh what period did you compare that
to to come up with the conclusion that
there were more frequent and more
damaging storms so this data is again
from the New Hampshire Department of
energy uh I believe they go back further
it's just that the top 10 stops in
2012 uh it's data obviously they get
from the utilities and uh our our view
uh is that we have had four of the top
10 most damaging storms uh in the past
two years uh we you know continue to see
uh an increase in these uh
events okay thank you so we have roughly
40 minutes left is we have a hard stop
at
3:30 and uh so 40 minutes divided by
three more utilities that's going to
give uh each of you about no more than
20 minutes right 15 minutes yeah let's
say 15 minutes
so as a public service announcement if
there is anybody in the room who plans
to testify at the public hearing of
House Bill 106 at 3 3:30 please visit
the table under the clock by the door
over there and get a pink card fill that
out and pass it up my
way um and now we can return to our
regularly schedule
program thank you all okay thank you
set so next up is
Unitil good afternoon good afternoon I
will do the very best I can with the 15
minutes I have thank you for that uh for
those of you that I have not gotten the
chance to meet yet I'd like to introduce
myself uh my name is Alec omera I am the
director of external Affairs at Unitil
uh my team manages government Affairs as
well as media relations our Municipal
relations with our Community Partners as
well as our community giving uh I have
been with Unitil for a number of years
though I'm new to this particular room
you may have seen me as part of my uh
media relations responsibilities as I've
been uh representing Unitil on that
front for a number of years and have
often been the front person with a
number of our storms and when we've had
storm modes I've been the Chief
Information officer on second shifts
ensuring that good information gets out
to all of our stakeholders including
yourselves what I'm going to talk about
a little bit today I'm going to give you
a high level overview of Unitil I'm also
going to get into some of the same
things that that Mike and Griffin talked
about in terms of Bill components and
storm response but I'm going to talk
about those a little bit more from the
perspective of the customer and how we
communicate some of the thorniest pieces
of both of those topics we recognize
that those are sort of topics number one
and number two for many of our customers
we want to make sure they have good
understanding on those so I'm going to
get into a little bit about what that
means as for Unitil itself this is our
footprint in New Hampshire we have
approximate 78,000 electric customers
and 37,000 natural gas customers Unitil
is a natural gas and electric utility we
serve three states in New England we
have about half of our total customers
are here in New Hampshire our
headquarters is here in New Hampshire in
fact Unitil I believe is the only
publicly traded company that is
incorporated here in New Hampshire which
is something that is a small point of
Pride for us our electric service is in
two non-contiguous territories in the
state we serve the greater conquered
area with our head of operations in
conquered in the city itself as well as
our call center that serves all of our
operations we have our corporate
headquarters in Hampton New Hampshire
all of our Natural Gas Service runs
along the coastal area it kind of runs
around the horn of the southeast state
line all the way from Salem kind of up
around the corner and up Route 16 to
Rochester uh our second electric service
territory is in the Sea Coast area as
well you can see uh the lined area is
where gas and electric service overlaps
that's the Hampton exitor down into
Atkinson plastow area if we were to zoom
out from this you would see that we have
uh gas and electric service in north
central Massachusetts as well covering
about six towns there and we have
natural gas service that runs up the
coast in Maine all the way up to
Portland then juts North up into the
Leon Atkinson area uh significant piece
of news for Unitil is that last year we
did announce plans to purchase Bangor
natural gas which would increase our
total natural gas uh customer base by
approximately 8,000 more customers in
the state of Maine that would bring us
about all total to about 108,000
electric customers and about 88,000 uh
customers if you were to go to any of
our operations centers you'd find this
big blue wall in just about any of them
this wall represents our mission vision
and values I know the folks from ISO New
England mentioned they have a vision and
mission two separate statements as well
um ours did not have to be approved by
FK for which I am thankful but we were
able to kind of have the same dichotomy
that they were talking about our mission
represents what we have to do every day
to serve our customers we know that
every day when we get up in the morning
we need to make sure that we're
providing that electric service it needs
to be done safely and reliably and we
need to do that in an afford able manner
without doing that we really can't do
much of anything else so we know we have
to have the mission taken care of every
day before we can look at the vision at
the same time you have to have a vision
you have to know where you're going to
be going and our vision is all about
ensuring that our customers have the
resources they need they need to know
they have their evolving energy needs
met and what do we mean by that we know
that as we've gone forward there are
folks using energy in increasingly
diverse ways we have a number of
customers that are interested in using
uh you know in terms of rooftop solar
what does that mean making sure we have
a two-way system that accommodates that
making sure we have the rate structures
that are going to be accommodating a
variety of different uses time of use
rates folks looking at electric vehicles
these are all things we're constantly
looking at and ensuring we're going to
be incorporating them into our system in
a manner that still ensures that we're
meeting that mission which means that
energy remains affordable for all and
reliable for all
we kind of measure that by looking at
customer service and when we talk about
customer service we're not just talking
about our call center we know that
customer service represents basically
all touch points that our customers have
with us as we're providing them service
that includes what we're doing during
storms how we're communicating with them
across all of those channels making sure
anybody that that person is talking to
is getting that experience we need and
we measure that through a third party
service and currently as part of our
2024 results of that third-party survey
we have a 90% overall customer service
rating with our customers which
represents first overall in the Eastern
us and in the Northeast generally
speaking they separate out East versus
West and Northeast versus the rest of
the company country rather because we
have unique challenges in the East and
in the Northeast this is typically areas
of the country where you have more
severe storms constantly occurring
that's something that can impact uh
overall customer experience as well as
of course affordability those are two
factors which is why highlighting those
specific areas is important uh we look
past that and we want to see where on
terms of customer service and surveying
what are the areas that we're
highlighting and and we like the things
that we're seeing as part of that the
areas where we seem to be uh among the
top of our peers involves things like uh
are we reliable uh do our customers find
that we're knowledgeable are we
presenting that information in a
friendly way that's sort of the key
basis of
okay we we're doing something correct
here in terms of how we're informing our
customers and making sure they're
understanding these complex topics
because energy is an incredibly complex
thing some folks just want to know that
their power is going to be on and and
when that's going to happen and how they
can pay their bills some people want to
understand why you know why what's going
on with Supply costs why are they going
up right now why are they coming down
right now what are my options in terms
of suppliers we try and build all of our
Communications to make sure we're doing
a good job of explaining and informing
these particular topics so in terms of
our bill uh I know that Mike and Griffin
had a very similar uh slide to this
these are in fact the breakdown of the
terms on the Unitil Bill itself I did a
quick text to make sure I knew exactly
where it was the delivery charge
specifically the external delivery
charge is where net metering uh
so-called additional costs and credits
that's where they live within the Unitil
bill I made a quick check with our
regulatory folks to confirm that so that
is where that lives um in terms of the
overall Bill understanding these
different components specifically
understanding the difference between
Supply and distribution because Unitil
is just a distribution company is at the
Forefront of many of our our
Communications with customers we ended
up really in the two approximately two
years ago I think is when we saw that
very significant Spike across supply
cost throughout uh the entirety of New
England and New Hampshire specifically
and we saw that coming as part probably
about in that summer we were getting
indicators that we were potentially
going to be seeing very high Supply
rates for that coming winter so we
looked at how can we use our existing
tools to make sure customers understood
what was going on with Supply costs but
also what options were available to them
in terms of supply cost as we know all
customers have the option to sort of
become their own broker uh Community
aggregation hadn't quite cut on yet in
the state of New Hampshire as it had now
but there were still a number of
suppliers that were available to our
customers so we had to make sure how are
we able to convey to our customers that
these options were available to them and
that they were not competitors with
Unitil I think that was a huge uh
question mark that we had for a lot of
us so yes we're able to do some of that
through media it was certainly a big
Topic at the time we were answering
those questions as they came in but we
were able to use our website to build
out resources that allowed you know just
basically what is supply how do you get
it where are the suppliers that are
available what are the sort of things
that you need to think about if you're
looking at one of these contractors just
like any other long-term contract that a
person might be interested in getting
into you want to make sure you know what
the fine print are how long does it last
what happens if you want to get out of
it these were the kinds of communication
points that we were trying to bring out
on this particular Topic at the time and
we found that very helpful going forward
so as we've continued to see Supply be a
a point of emphasis among our customer
base we've kind of built this resource
and this toolkit to be able to talk
about these things on the Storm side uh
we have a very similar structure as to
what eversource was talking about we use
the incident command system in our uh
company that's why I have my storm role
which has historically been Chief
Information officer I'm going to take on
a more specialized role going forward
I'm going to be working specifically
with our our liaison and elected
officials making sure you get good
information in terms of what's going on
on our overall system but uh everyone in
the company has a storm roll our our
folks in accounting they make sure you
know they'll go out and they'll on our
drills they'll practice getting cones
down making sure our staging areas are
going to be managed in terms of traffic
we're you know about 500 employees all
together about 390 of which are here in
New Hampshire so when we have a big
event come through we use all of our
hands to make sure we're helping our
customers and get that done uh the
number one question that we get as a
storm rolls through generally as I
assume everyone here would know it would
be when is that power coming back on
more importantly why can't you tell me
when the power is coming back on yet
often times in the first you know 12 to
24 hours of these storms that people
want to know well when is it coming on
and you say well we're still assessing
that damage and then the obvious
follow-up question is is well what does
assessing mean what does that mean
you're doing and what it means is quite
literally we're assessing sometimes that
means that the storm isn't even over yet
uh we'll get questions about when we're
going to restore power within the first
hour 90 minutes of a storm that maybe
has just begun and we're expecting
hazardous conditions for another 12 to
18 hours that's not uncommon especially
with high wind events where it might
knock power out very very quickly but we
know there's going to be issues that
we're not even going to know what the
extent of the damage is for another 12
18 hours so that's one of the things we
know we need to communicate to our
customers once we know that the storm is
passed and we know all the damage that
we're going to see is complete that's
when our operations folks begin the
process of trying to figure out exactly
how much damage there is on the system
as a whole they're taking all those
different things every broken Pole every
Transformer that's going to need getting
fixed every single wires down issue
that's out there we're able to take a
look once we're able to get our arms
around all the damage that's out there
we can figure out the man hours of work
that needs to get done and then we can
divide that by the number of Crews that
we have available once you get to that
point it's a very simple math equation
it's just simply man-hours versus
workers that you have to do the job but
that takes time to get done and that's
why we wait and we say we're assessing
the damage before we're able to provide
that global estimated restoration time
we want to make sure we have that work
complete we have a clear picture of the
total damage on the system and then once
we have that information we're able to
share when we're going to be able to get
power restored at that time uh over the
past several events we've had uh a nice
combination of good planning and good
fortune I think in the past 2 three
years uh We've managed to restore power
to about 99% of our customers from Peak
about either 48 or 72 hours from the
so while we're managing that mission we
know we have that Vision work to do as
well and I have a picture here from our
groundbreaking ceremony and I see a
couple folks that were here that I got
to meet uh at that particular event that
was a major event for us as a company uh
for those that may not be aware here uh
we officially broke ground last year on
the first utility owned solar array in
the state of New Hampshire once it's
complete later this year it will be
among the largest uh arrays of its kind
in in the state if not the largest at
approximately 5 megaw uh we're able to
build that through a statute in the
state that says that a utility May build
distributed generation of approximately
6% of its peak load for Unitil that
rounds up to about 18 megawatts this is
5 megaw uh we gained approval and we're
able to build construction and I think
the key point I want to make on a
project like this is Unitil believes in
finding these types of solutions and
going forward them with them when we're
able to uh clearly identify the cost
benefits to our customers as part of the
building of this solar array we were
able to prove to the Department of
energy that the net effect for our
customers in terms of building this
array and the energy would produce would
in fact be an offset decrease to our
customers over time that's why we
pursued this and that's why we're able
to build it and as it gets complete and
we get that data come in that proves
that out uh we would be more than
excited to be able to continue to pursue
that forward but first we want to see
that data come in and confirm what we've
been sharing before we pursue another
array like this um outside of that it's
about our customers and figuring out
what we can do for them we know our
customers want to make sure they have
rates that make sense we have time of
use rates and EV rates our Energy
Efficiency programs are tremendous
resource for our customers to be able to
keep energy affordable for them and we
need to make sure that we're we're just
keeping our system up to speed as folks
look for these new things as more load
comes onto the system as folks explore
alternative sources for heating or
electrification or electric vehicles we
need to make sure our infrastructure is
keeping up so that's what our
engineering team is working on they want
to make sure that we're continuing to
maintain that
pace finally as both a gas and electric
utility we represent and recognize that
gas has a clear role to play as part of
New England's overall energy structure
uh Natural Gas Service uh in New
Hampshire uh we are cast iron free we
have no cast iron pipe that
differentiates our system from those in
Massachusetts or Connecticut or other
areas uh that still have cast iron that
they're working to remove from our
system that means our system is among
the tightest in the region uh We've made
a commitment as a company to reduce our
scope one emissions that is emissions
that are released to Atmosphere as part
of our overall gas operations to reduce
those by 50% by 2030 and 100% by 2050
did I say 2030 that's not a real date
2030 and 2050 uh we're going to go about
that not only because we have that work
going done on our overall infrastructure
and get rid of cast iron but also we're
continuing to move forward from that
we're doing Advanced Leak Detection this
is not the standard Leak Detection
that's looking for leaks on a safety
purpose this is Advanced looking at
parts per billion as opposed to parts
per million what we're looking to do
there is identify these points in the
gas system that are simply releasing gas
that are never a safety concern but are
where emissions are going out we want to
make sure we're getting in in advanced
in front of those but also because we
discovered as we're going through in our
sustainability reports the EPA expects
that when you're reporting Emissions on
your gas system as a whole you're taking
uh miles per pipe and the kind of pipe
that is and simply doing a rithmetic on
that in other words there's an
expectation that if you have X miles of
pipe it's going to have this amount of
leaks we want to prove that out that's
why we're doing this work so we're
getting that proactive pipe work done
and what we're finding is our actual
Emissions on systems are below that of
the expectations in the EPA so we're
able to not only prove that but then
we're able to Target these leaks and
then be able to continue to do repairs
that's part of how we're getting
ourselves to
zero so that's Unitil in a nutshell I
look forward to working with all of you
I'm happy to answer any questions you
got I know I have limited time but how
can I help thank you very much
representative Summers has a question
thank you Mr chairman and thank you for
taking my question uh quick two-part
question my first one has to do with my
constituents I I represent uh three
towns that are in your district there of
uh plastow Newton and Southampton and I
know we all receive and all my
constituents at least for distribution
receive a bill from Unitil uh however
with natural gas I notice where natural
gas is in plastow I was curious to why
it goes around Newton and Southampton
that's my first part of the question yep
and the second second part of my
question is with the 5 megawatt solar
farm you built next door in Kingston uh
how many Acres of grounded that take up
to build that for the site I knew that
number off the top of my head when we
were at the groundbreaking I'm going to
say it's approximately 30 Acres I can
get you the specific number of that
particular area um I don't recall if
that's the number of the land itself or
if it's the fenced in area for the array
but I can get the number correctly but I
know that that's a good ballpark for you
um in terms of natural gas
infrastructure as a whole uh Unitil has
a a very uh pragmatic conservative
approach to Natural Gas expansion
generally speaking natural gas expansion
is something that happens uh one street
and one neighborhood at a time you look
at where the overall your backbone of
your system is your core pipelines your
Mains and then you try and see what
customers may be interested in that
sometimes you have a large anchor
customer that's a little bit further
away from that Main and then you look to
try and if that customer is interested
that means that there's a potential
opportunity for you to be able to bring
on Natural Gas customer between there
and all the way along the line uh Unitil
does expand its natural gas service I
believe them our most our newest town in
the system is eping New Hampshire uh we
expanded to eping I believe within the
last 5 years um and it's a matter of
finding the right opportunity uh and
having the numbers work out and having a
strong interest within a specific
community and having the pipeline that
can be able to serve it but it's a lot
of different individual pieces that lead
to a specific new expansion to an area
are General expansion philosophy is
looking within our existing system and
finding folks that may still be on
delivered fuels of which there are
several close to our Mains and bringing
those folks online as well we see
opportunities to not only uh reduce
their energy costs but reduce emissions
as well for those particular
customers I'd remind members we have 28
minutes left and we have two utilities
to hear from
so representative schneller thank you Mr
chairman real quick I was just wondering
where do you Source your natural gas it
might have been on the map but I missed
it so we have um our natural gas comes
in you know we're at the same issues uh
as the rest of New England in terms of
the pipelines that serve New England as
a whole um we tie into the Tennessee gas
pipeline our system also ties into the
Portland maritimes pipeline that comes
in from the north so there is gas
service available to us from the south
and from the north but um our gas
service is faces the same pipeline
constraints is the rest of New England
thank
you all right I want to thank you very
much and next call on Liberty Utilities
to give us a
presentation and I apologize for the
fact that you're going to have to be
quick but that's just the way um things
have evolved
here
yeah drag another chair up if you need
to
good good
afternoon everyone so my name is Carolyn
' Conor and I am the director of
government Affairs for Liberty Utilities
in New Hampshire I also play that role
for Liberty's east region which I can
explain or tell you at another time I am
aided in New Hampshire by jod grimus
who's here
uh who I think many of you know so she's
our lobbyist and our government Affairs
consultant and support so she's here on
a regular basis we talk on a daily basis
so anything I know this is going to be
short anything that's needed any
questions that come up you can contact
me directly I'll provide the committee
with my contact information or you can
get to Jody very quickly and we can um
respond to any questions or information
that you
need so uh I'm joined joed today by two
leaders uh from Liberties Gas and
Electric operations and so really I'm
going to turn it over to them to explain
our system and to talk about some of the
issues and challenges so we have Brad
Marx who's the manager of engineering
for Energy North which is our gas system
and Meredith Verner who is the
engineering lead for our Electric System
for Granite State Electric I just want
to say at the outset and kind of preface
it that we we our our presentation is a
little bit more streamlined we we kind
of saw that how robust this panel was
and in the time frame so we for things
that are common to the utilities like
storm response and the components of the
electric bill and some other things
they're not in our presentation but
we're happy to provide that information
Liberty specific to to the committee so
with that I'm going to turn it over to
Brad to talk about gas all right thank
you Carolyn so yeah here to talk about
an overview of the uh natural gas system
that Liberty operates in New Hampshire
uh we're comprised of about 100,000 gas
customers and that's across 32
communities in the State uh mostly
constituted along the i93 corridor uh
but we also have we go up to the Lakes
Region uh we also have a small system uh
up north in Berlin and then out west in
Keen we um operate a propane air system
we have
139 uh gas operations employees in New
Hampshire uh they reside across four gas
operations yard those are in Nashua
Manchester Tilton and
Kean so our natural gas distribution
system is primarily uh served by one
transmission line uh that is the
Tennessee gas pipeline owned and
operated by Kinder Morgan uh which
extends from the Massachusetts its
border and actually terminates in
conquered uh in addition to that
pipeline uh we um are reliant on five
LNG and propane air plants uh that are
utilized for winter support uh during
cold
weather uh lastly we also have a um 2.8
mile transmission line uh that feeds the
um so we are committed to serve our
customers and to um also expand to new
customers uh we believe natural gas
Remains the lowest cost and cleanest
solution uh for both building heat and
for industrial processed thermal energy
load uh Liberty continues to see
consistent annual customer growth in our
area uh we're committed to making
natural gas as available to as many
Granite Staters uh within our system as
possible so how does how how does the
gas get to our customers uh so we tap
off of uh like I said earlier the
transmission line um we have several
take stations in our area uh these take
stations they meter they
odorize um and uh they reduce the
pressure from the high transmission
pressure to an intermediate
pressure um and that's also where the
custody is transferred as well uh so
that immediate pressure that gets
distributed through our system most of
our customers are fed directly off of
that intermediate pressure uh via uh
customer services and then meter and
Regulators uh but in some of our more
urban areas we do have low pressure
systems and uh those are um well there's
a pressure uh regulator station District
pressure regulator station that takes
that intermediate pressure and reduces
it to the low pressure press and then
the low pressure is provided to
customers via services and uh meter sets
as
well so uh Carolyn mentioned we have
challenges and opportunities in our area
uh one is that we have aging
infrastructure uh Energy North still has
31 miles of leak prome pipe uh so that
would be our cast iron M our bare steel
main uh that's remaining in our
distribution system we do have have a
program in place to proactively replace
this leak prom pipe with modern plastic
pipe um and we've made progress uh since
uh 2007 we've replaced approximately 120
miles of leak prome pipe uh but we still
have some some ways to go here to get
that number down to
zero and our other uh challenges are
around system planning and reliability I
mentioned earlier we have our one
transmission line and we reliant on the
uh what we call our Peak shaving
facilities in the winter uh we do have
two multi-year projects uh that um are
targeted to address system capacity
concerns and ultimately reduce our
Reliance on the peak shaving facilities
so one of those projects is a supply
enhancement to the greater Manchester in
uh nashway areas that involves a new
station in about uh 10 miles of 12in
pipe crossing the maram
river and uh the other project is uh to
feed up north it's a replacement of 10
miles of critical pipe that feeds the
Tilton
area chair I don't know we'll we'll move
if representative Wendy Thomas has a
question I guess thank you very much um
quick question um regarding the plastic
pipes
um I isn't there the possibility of them
degrading and do they contain past and
is the past drawn out of the
pipe with the heat so no they do not uh
contain past they are um what we call
high density high density polyethylene
pipe um it has a uh useful life of On
The Low End 50 years but on the high end
as high as 100
years
y great we'll move on to Meredith for
Granite State hi good afternoon my name
is Meredith burner I'm the engineering
manager at Liberty Utilities and the
electric side Meredith you can move the
whole unit okay can you hear me now is
that better okay I'm loud in my ear
right here um okay so we have about
47,00 electric customers from Granite
State Electric and if you look at a map
of our service territory um we are
largely in the Salem area and that
southern portion and about half of our
customers are in that area and the other
half are about in that Northern Area um
in that purple and green territory where
we have our Lebanon area uh and our
Charles Town service area um so we have
about 15 substations throughout this
area um and 45 feeders which is what
feeds the individual customers and uh
commercial accounts um and within
Granite State we have 67 operations
employees so that includes uh
engineering our work coordinators and
our work planners our vegetation
management and of course our linemen um
and our field
technicians um so our locations we're
headquartered in londonairy uh with our
gas is where our headquarters is and out
we have operations buildings in Salem
and and Lebanon our customer walk-in
conquered so the area of focus I wanted
to highlight uh was our reliability and
so before we jump into how this is going
to how this is showing that we're
improving as it's going down I would
thought I would explain the uh indexes
that were referenced uh so we have
safety and S are our indexes that are
highlighted here and so safy stands for
system average interruption frequency
index so that is the number of times
that customers experience an outage or
an interruption and then our s is the
system average Interruption duration
index so that is the number recorded in
the number of minutes uh that an outage
uh lasts should an outage occur uh so in
the blue line we have our s which uh the
trend line is showing the 5year average
so it looks at the previous 5e and you
can see in the trend line it is going
down which means the number of when we
do an outage the duration has been
decreasing over time uh and then the
dots the blue dots on the ma uh graph
are showing like just the individual
year scores that the fiveyear average
can really show that smooth downward
Trend better uh and then our safety is
frequency and so uh same thing so we've
experienced uh a large decrease in the
number of outages that we experience uh
and this can largely be attributed to
the amount of investment that we have
made uh many years ago uh five or so
years ago and previous years uh in our
storm hardening and upgrading our
conductors from open Bare wire
conductors to hendrx covered conductor
systems as well as um installing new
automated reclosers and sectionalizers
on our system to shorten the number of
out durations and outages
uh do we have any questions on
this questions from the committee
representative Corman yeah I just want
to verify so the numbers on the left
side for the S actually are minutes yes
that's correct and also I just want to
point out you can thank me for the
increased reliability I'm one of your
customers I was out there three days
several years ago I went and bought a
again any further
questions okay now let's play the st&
version of beat the clock and ask uh the
New Hampshire Electric Co-op to come
forward thank you again I know this
probably still question so happy to work
with the group uh throughout the
you according to
my my phone my my watch it's 3:15 you
guys have 15 minutes we will do our best
to beat the clock okay thank you thank
you chairman Vose we are the New
Hampshire Electric Cooperative and our
presentation is a little bit different
than everybody else's because we are
very different than everybody else that
you've seen so far so I'm Michael
Jennings I'm the interum president and
CEO at the cooperative and alongside me
I have Peter Glenshaw he is our VP of
member engagement so government Affairs
community
everything that deals with our members
Peter is responsible for so in the
presentation today we really want to
tell you about what makes the
Cooperative different than other
utilities how that kind of started with
our mission in 1939 and why that mission
is still very important to us today and
how we continue to live that
mission so we were founded in 1939 to
bring electricity to areas of the state
that did not have power so you can see
on this map here the areas in lime green
that's our service territory in 1939
there was no electricity in those areas
for the most part and so a bunch of
citizens of New Hampshire got together
to start their own power company as a
nonprofit organization to bring power to
those areas and that's how the New
Hampshire Electric Cooperative was
founded as a result nowadays it's very
different than back then we are actually
the second largest electric utility in
this state uh the largest cooperative in
all of New England so we're we're quite
large for an Electric Co-op uh we manage
all of that through about 237 employees
86,000 M and 6,000 miles a line in the
most rural parts of New Hampshire that
today so a few ways that were different
than the other Utilities in the state
for one we're nonprofit we do everything
at cost for our membership we're a 501
C2
organization and because of that we have
some advantages as well certain grants
we have preferred access to and when we
do make a profit we return those
operating margins back to our members in
the form of capital
credits another thing is our ownership
so because we are a Cooperative we are
owned by the members we serve and I know
some of you are Cooperative members
so thank you uh we say we work for the
members because you are our our
customers but also are owners of the
company and so it's very different than
a typical customer model we have members
instead of
customers another difference because
we're member owned is our governance so
we are governed by an 11 member board of
directors that are directly elected by
our membership we have elections every
single year in which three to four
directors are up for election and our
members all get to vote in that to
determine who runs the organization and
because of that that we have a different
regulatory structure than the other
utilities we are deregulated for power
rates because our members through the
election of the board of directors
actually make the decisions on how to
run the Cooperative so that deregulation
is because we by default in our
governance structure act in the best
interest of our
membership and because of that we don't
have the same oversight as the other
utilities or
rates and like I said before and I will
say again and again and I say it every
day at the job we work for our members
so we exist to meet the needs of our
members we started doing that in 1939
through the electric business and we
still do that today um what motivates us
now is our new strategic plan that we
created in 2024 and it has five Focus
areas and if everybody on this committee
probably knows what the most important
thing is to Electric rate payers one and
two right reliability and affability if
it's just after a storm everybody
probably says reliability otherwise it's
affordability and we continue to have
that mission to promote those for our
members uh as a result we're doing very
well on the affordability side we have
some of the lowest rates in the state
both on the distribution and and power
supply side the other thing that's
important to our members is the member
experience you know we want folks when
they call in to have a really good
positive experience we want you to have
a really good member satisfaction and we
focus on that and the way we're able to
deliver all three of those things is by
focusing on our employees because
they're the ones that make those things
happen so our employee experience is
very critical to us and then the newest
mission for us is broadband and that's
our our newest business and just like we
were founded in 1939 to bring essential
services at that time electricity to
areas that didn't have it we started
that same Mission with broadband that's
one of the things we noticed during Co
when everybody was sent home you had to
do work from home you had to do school
from home and folks couldn't do it
because they didn't have the internet
that they needed that became the next
essential service and a really critical
part of our mission at that time to make
sure our members had that so we're we're
very passionate about that and it really
fits with our model of delivering that
essential service to areas that don't
have it in rural New Hampshire
right so we founded New Hampshire
Broadband LLC
um this is a for-profit but wholly owned
subsidy by NHC so the New Hampshire
Electric Cooperative is the the sole
owner of New Hampshire Broadband this
was really driven by our members
speaking out and voting in 2020 because
they went home and they didn't have the
service that they needed so that drove
us to starting the business because our
members asked for it so our service is
the state-of AR technology it's all
fiber it's highspeed we offer 100
megabits to to 2 gbits symmetrical
internet to folks but our technolog is
actually capable of higher speeds than
that although most folks equipment in
their homes can't handle that so we we
just sell the 100 to two gig right now
um and and we try to be a no gimmick
company we give you a consistent price
no special deals or hidden fees we just
want to be straightforward and honest
and deliver that good member
satisfaction so this is where we we
currently stand and I'll try to save a
couple minutes for question but we're in
the middle of a a large scale buildout
to bring those services to rural New
Hampshire uh just last year alone we
built over a th000 miles of fiber which
is a a really astonishing feat to be
building 20 30 miles of fiber a week uh
it was no small task but the thing with
bringing Broadband to areas they need it
everybody wants it yesterday as well and
unfortunately we can't do it all
tomorrow it'll take some time but we're
we're trying as hard as we can to get it
to our members as fast as we can
so today as of a few years ago we had no
broadband customers I'm proud to report
we have over 5,000 already today and and
that's 5,000 folks that probably
wouldn't have access to broadband
internet high-speed internet at their
home if it wasn't for us bringing that
service to
them so with that being said I have a
few minutes left if there's any
questions okay questions representative
Wendy Thomas thank you very easy
question can you make sure that we have
have your contact information
absolutely representative parshall thank
you and thank you for taking my question
uh what Supply options do your customers
have are you referring to default supply
for electricity not just default but I
mean do they have access to community
power third party absolutely yes so we
have competitive Supply in our service
territory just like the other utilities
uh Community power usually requires the
town's engagement in to have that
available but we like our members to be
able to choose so we offer the default
Supply service we have a very
competitive rate for it and we want to
save our members money but if our
members don't want to buy it from us as
well we're very happy with that we we
just want to facilitate whatever it's
best for them representative
partial thank you chair V the other
partial U Can you tell me um boots on
the ground line workers uh in order to
provide Rel reliability is that a
problem at all and are majority of our
line workers employed by the company or
are they contracted subl labor so the
majority of our line workers right now
are uh in-house they they always have
been we have a very good Apprentice
training program so the majority of our
line workers come in um just after Line
work school they don't have many years
experience in the industry and we work
with them to train them up we as a
Cooperative typically have very long
tenured employees uh folks like the
mission and stay a long time and we we
try to have that same approach with our
line workers and and so if we can train
them and keep them it makes for a Better
Business for
US Representative
rolds thank you Mr chair um since you
are a as you described
member um member owned and nonprofit and
run all in the interests of the best and
lowest cost service for all your members
what
is the co-op's approach to promote in
end use Energy Efficiency do you have a
systems benefits charge and do you
participate in the New Hampshire saves
program or do you operate your
own yeah that's great question so we
participate in the same New Hampshire
saves program U and we are required to
um by the same statute that the other
utilities applies to so we have the very
similar system benefits charge as the
other
utilities and the last question goes to
representative McGee thank you so much
so my question goes to technology I'm
curious about the um functionality of
the current meters that your customers
have you do you supply those meters and
if so uh are they smart enough meters to
do I think you guys are doing time of
use and you're kind of bullish on
transactive capabilities so I just want
to know a little bit about the
technology yeah absolutely uh so we have
an Ami metering system we were actually
I believe one of the first if not the
first in the state to roll it out uh
cooperatives tend to be very technology
forward and and fast adopters of
Technology uh it just happens with being
part of our Trade Organization they
really push that but because of the Ami
technology we're able to leverage more
data we have a lot of different uh
between time of use metering programs
whether it's for EVS or solar or net
metering there's there's a lot of
different options out there for our
members
followup and the so the followup would
be does that uh provide an additional
benefit as well to your customers in
terms of the value that they derive from
having that technology
available so we think so by providing
the option but we try to design our
rates so there is no cost sharing
between rate classes so when there are
there are cost attributable to one
classification we try to get that
classification to pay for it so they're
not being subsidized by other rate
classes okay so you guys have done an
excellent job of playing st& Beat the
Clock and we thank you very much for
being here and for making your
presentation and we thank all the other
utilities as well for your excellent uh
presentations now we're going to play a
new game this one's called stn runs to
the bathroom before the public hearing
on HB 106 we'll be back here in three
minutes and if you plan to testify
immediately
e
okay everyone let's get started time for
our first public hearing of the 2025
2026 bium this is on House Bill
106 establishing a commission to
determine the monetary cost of climate
change to the state of New Hampshire and
the best means of recouping such costs I
have been given 13 pink cards that means
we have a lot of people who want to
testify so I'm going to have to impose
time limits so for the prime sponsor of
the bill I'm going to allow five minutes
for everybody else the limit is three
minutes and I will be using my phone to
uh keep track of the time we have a hard
stop we have to be out of this building
before 5 o' because staff would be on
overtime if we stayed longer than that
so we have we do have a hard stop we
can't go any longer so I ask you to be
respectful of our time respectful of the
other people behind you who want to
testify so try not to run over your time
as you testify on this bill
so with that I'll turn it over to
representative Tony Kaplan to introduce
House Bill
106 yeah good afternoon uh fellow
committee members for the record I'm
representative Tony Kaplan representing
maror M8 the towns of hener Bradford and
Warner and uh I just want to thank all
the committee members for their patience
and uh hard work after two year two days
of uh listening to reports now we get to
kick off our work session with with my
bill HB 106 and so I will will not waste
any more time and just get straight into
it this bill establishes a commission to
determine the financial cost of climate
damage to New Hampshire and best methods
of recouping uh those costs as I was
thinking about how to uh present this
bill I kept seeing the news reports
about the fires in in Los Angeles and I
don't want to debate the causes of that
fire but just to for all of us to
reflect on what an environmental and
human tragedy looks like in this country
and uh I think we can all agree that we
should do all we can to make sure such a
thing never happens here and also how
foolish it would be to believe that it
could never happen here that somehow we
we are uh immune to these extreme wet
weather events that are certainly in
some degree attributable to human
causes now the problem with climate
change is that there has been a lot of
exaggeration on both sides of the aisle
and so people are rightfully confused so
you know I just want to quickly uh go
over what the science says is there is
now an extremely high level of
scientific confidence as high as it ever
gets with physical phenomenon on this
scale that human activi best explain the
observed rise in global temperatures and
also that combined Rising Global
continued Rising global temperatures
pose a significant risk to our way of
life but that individual events at a
local level are always caused by a
multitude of factors and so you can
never say that uh human caused global
warming caused that particular hurricane
or that particular fire what you can say
is that human induced warming increases
the probability of these extreme events
happening globally and regionally and
for our purposes that's definitely good
enough science has been soled for a long
time on the increased probability of
extreme weather plus a certainty of sea
level rise around the world with
greenhouse gases accumulating in the
atmosphere at the levels they are the
consensus tells us that to keep global
warming below the relatively safe 2 C
Mark emissions need to declined by
roughly 25% by 2030 and reached Net Zero
around 2070 I know we've all heard that
before but I what I think we haven't
heard is that 2024 was the first year
that we ever breached the 1.5 Celsius
warming Mark above which we can expect
significantly more extreme weather
events like heat waves droughts
wildfires and heavy precipitation
leading to Greater risks to food
security water availability and human
health this
year Munich re which is the world's
largest reinsurance company said in its
annual report that there were more than
$240 billion in insured losses around
the world and to quote from their annual
report our record breaking one record
breaking high after another the
consequences are devastating the
destructive forces of climate change are
becoming increasingly evident as backed
up by science societies need to prepare
for more severe weather
catastrophes so there's a range of
possibilities of what these changes will
cost depending on the varying emission
scenarios and what we do now versus what
we do later according to the 2022 New
Hampshire climate report expected global
warming for higher greenhous gas levels
is nearly double what we can expect for
uh if we reduce the emissions by
mid-century if we succeed in doing that
so this commission will look at the most
likely scenarios and determine the best
estimate but we don't need to debate
here our shared concern for our
constituents quality of life or the
state's economic
well-being there must be undoubtedly a
bipartisan interest in fiscal
responsibility and in the need we have
to harden our communities building
adaptation and preparing for a future in
a changing climate that we're going to
see so what are some examples of the
proactive work who's uh that the
commission might consider we need I just
wanted to read into the record a few
examples of these uh related to severe
storms remove relocate acquire or
demolish structures to minimize future
flood loss in install reroute increase
capacity or Implement uh routine
cleaning plans for storm Drainage
Systems add extra
culverts install detention or retention
basins inspect and maintain Drainage
Systems inspect bridges in order to
identify and Implement repairs resurface
roads with more permeable pavement and
concrete stabilize Bridges against
scouring protect rural communities from
flooding by installing flood control
structures Elevate roads and bridges
flood proof inside of municipal
buildings buildings by installing check
valves sump pumps or backflow prevention
devices related to hotter temperatures
Energy Efficiency retrofits in public
and private buildings increase cooling
cost for all public buildings increase
road damage due to more frequent extreme
heat events increase High albo surfaces
on buildings roads and other locations
build and manage more cooling centers
increase demand for publicly financed
air conditioning control the increase of
vector born illness using education
physical and chemical controls for tick
and
mosquitoes and finally uh sea level rise
stabilize susceptible Coastal slopes and
cliffs and shorelines using grading
techniques planting vegetation rip wrap
or geotextile Fabric or
bioengineering and remove relocate
acquire or demolish structures for
minimizing future losses so just to uh
end up I think the commission is ideally
Su suited to hearing from experts on
these uh varying scenarios and
identifying the best possible uh funding
me mechanism to meet these costs and so
I'm hoping that we can reach it by
Parson consensus and start this
conversation with this bill okay thank
you representative Kaplan for
introducing your bill I have one quick
question for you on the first page of
the bill line two finding number one it
says that uh climate damage threatens
New Hampshire with Untold billions of
dollars in Damages and adaptation costs
could you share with us the data that
you use to come to the conclusion that
this will cost us billions of
dollars yeah I mean I I read the the New
Hampshire climate assessment and I
looked at uh the center for climate
Integrity uh report for New Hampshire
and I just looked at some of the
estimates that included you know
Millions upon millions of dollars in
infrastructure costs not to mention uh
health care costs
uh damage to the economy such as maple
syrup production ski industry
agriculture uh loss of property um with
rising sea levels along the Sea Coast
millions and millions of dollars there
so um you know that's that's in the
findings it's it's not a hard figure uh
but I believe it's possibly in the in
the billions of
dollars so my follow-up question would
be this is not actually a f this is a
prediction exactly that's it's it's a
prediction of damage in the in the
coming decades so from 20 to 50 year
time frame
roughly chair recognizes representative
ner thank you Mr
chairman can you please tell me how many
of the almost 50 catastrophic climate
predictions that have been made since
1970 have come
true I I can't answer that question
because I don't know which
predictions you're referring to so all I
can tell you is that there's no question
that the likelihood of extreme weather
events due to warming of the atmosphere
is is uh is is is without a doubt uh
going to occur follow up well my whole
life there's been attempts to predict um
future Calamity from the climate and um
they've all failed so these predictions
have all failed so why should we endorse
this one
well I I just again I don't know what
predictions you're referring to I think
if you just uh you know refer back to my
my opening statement I don't think you
can point to any any particular event
and say that was definitely caused by
human uh Glo human induced global
warming but there's no doubt that the
probability of these increased extreme
events occurring on a regional level uh
is is there's more probability of those
of those events in in future years
there's no doubt the science clearly
question okay representative Wendy
Thomas has a question thank you Mr chair
thank you representative parall um thank
you for uh presenting this bill uh I'm
specifically looking at page two uh line
26 where you uh the commission would
look at the likely scope of damage to
New Hampshire can you tell me how this
Commission could financially benefit New
Hampshire's industry specifically um
some of the ones that are called out
tourism Agriculture and small business
well I I think there's a definite
benefit for State leaders uh industry
leaders
uh influence influencers so to speak to
know what these actual damages uh in
would incur to our our leading
Industries and so I think the light of
day is the best disinfectant and comes
uh with you know with knowing the actual
facts what is the scope of of what are
we looking at what is the scope of the
actual damage to the economy in terms of
uh you know actual benefits from knowing
the figures I mean uh this this
commission
would is is charged with coming up with
a list of actual recommendations for for
adaptation work and so to the extent
that those Industries depend on
infrastructure depend on uh our you know
our public resources they would
definitely benefit from uh us doing the
necessary work to harden ourselves and
to you know build resilience to to the
coming um climate damage that we're
going to incur representative Bernardi
has a
question thank you Mr chairman pivoting
right off of that answer that you just
gave the responsibility of the
commission is to propose is reports
findings and recommendations for
proposed legislation yet in your list of
all the uh activity is there to look at
and to do nothing in there is about uh
proposing legislation it's it's looking
at a bunch of different
scenarios so there's no recommendations
from that section yeah I'm talking about
Roman 3 versus Roman 5 that's a complete
disconnect are you are you referring to
the list of of uh scope of work that I
just referred to in my in my in my
speech that my testimony yeah section
Roman three lists all these
activities that you you're to study
right and scenarios and
whatnot and yet Roman five talks about
proposing
legislation it's not the it's not the
same
thing yeah I mean Roman 3 is dealing
with estimating the cost of all of all
that work right uh my proposed the
proposed legislation is more in terms of
funding mechanisms and what would be the
best means of recouping and for the
state to start setting aside the money
necessary to do that work that's the
proposed
legislation okay that's that's not what
that might not be clear and that that
might be you know need to be more
precisely worded I take that uh you know
I take that criticism on
board okay thank you representative for
introducing this bill seeing no more
question questions I'll call next on
Sebert I hope I got that right
yeah good afternoon um my name is
representative Christine cybert I am
from um Manchester's W one Hillsboro
district 21 um I signed on to sponsor
this legislation because I believe we
owe it to the people of New Hampshire to
do this study instead of waiting until
just H it'ss the fan so to speak um I
also wanted to point out that often when
the costs go up such as like for
insurance which insurance companies have
come out and estimated themselves that
this is and already said that will raise
rates and all that kind of such a thing
and we've had agricultural losses you
know a lot of those losses and those
extra costs get passed down to the
consumer we know that at the consumer
level at the small business level for
our local farms we have a lot of for the
tourist industry it directly affects
them and directly hits them um so we
really owe it to them to at least look
at this um and do the benefit cost
analysis is it's the smart pre
Preparatory thing to do we can also
identify
vulnerabilities um which and also cost
benefit analysis for mitigation and
adaption and just overall understanding
the financial
impact um and I also wanted to add that
when I was knocking doors this past
summer people were very they want
government to work they want people to
work together
and you know ultimately that's what
they're looking for they're looking for
us to do our job and so I believe that
this would help we're we're already
seeing as well with
Hampton um what just happened recently
they're having to pay a lot of money
that they weren't intending on having to
spend when it comes to the
causeway um and there are many other
examples of that where we aren't
bringing in the revenue we are or we
should be um due to this so it's
worthwhile for us to take a look at it
and see what comes out of it thank you
for your time does anyone have any
questions for me I have a any questions
representative Summers just a very quick
question I I know you're just you're a
co-sponsor of this bill but I have I
have a question of uh I know we talk
about a lot of scenarios and options and
what could happen in the future however
is there any Court findings currently
that have found mon monetary law
specifically caused by by climate change
in within New Hampshire they would
study I wouldn't know that in particular
so thank
you okay thank you very much appreciate
that next up moving right
along I'd like to call up Michael sonunu
of newfields New Hampshire representing
himself you have a very famous this last
name uh just coincidence it's just
coincidence okay uh thank you Mr
chairman thank you members of the
committee um I'm here to speak on uh HB
106 I'll try to make it
brief uh please note that I submitted
about 15 pages of more detailed
information to the chairman hopefully
that will uh provide you with additional
background uh good governance requires
that new laws are based on good data bad
law based on Good Intentions without
being grounded
real facts is still bad law I'd argue
that the underlying premise of HB 106 is
that there are scientifically based
links between fossil fuel-based
anthropogenic CO2 emissions with we
weather related damages here in New
Hampshire today and in the future and
that pre premise is actually factually
incorrect which makes HB 106 bad
legislation and bad governance um let me
take an objective approach and real
quickly go through some of the factual
information that has been provided to
this committee the most impactful
weather related damages in New Hampshire
has actually been historical flooding
the worst most recent flood was due to
the Hurricane Irene back in August
2011 given that it was the most
impactful event in recent memory we
should be able to see Trends in
Hurricane data for either frequency or
intensity of cyclones activity that
would justify CO2 man-made CO2 driving
this type of activity but it doesn't
exist information that is readily
available from people like Dr Ryan Maui
uh or take a look at the most recent
Cyclone study in nature magazine from
December 2024 indicates no Trends in
Hurricane frequency no Trends in
Hurricane intensity no F Trends in major
Hurrican hurricane occurrence and no
Trends in the Atlantic Basin whatsoever
which is the Basin that actually impacts
New Hampshire in addition I've provided
information about River Crest events
here in new New Hampshire uh along most
of the major
rivers uh I wrote about this extensively
about 10 years ago in commenting about
the coastal hazards report uh when you
look at high Crest activity over the
last 25 years it's actually down
historically from what we've seen over
the last century the worst River
floodings precipitation events that have
taken place in the state isn't in 2000
and 2010 it's in the 1920s and the 1930s
having nothing to do with CO2 if there's
if there is no direct Trend correlated
with CO2 emissions for flooding and
damage in the state it's impossible to
say that the companies that this
legislation is targeting is responsible
for these types of Damages they're not
outside the range of natural variability
I also looked at sea level rise data
over the last 100 years the one gauge
station here in New Hampshire has in uh
has the same two millimeter Pere rise in
sea level that has had has had for the
last 100 years uh Global sea level rise
has not changed appreciably over the
last 200 years since we left the little
Ice Age um clearly we have had damages
on the coast but it is impossible unless
unless there's some acceleration in sea
level to associate that with CO2
emissions again making the underlying
premise of this legislation difficult to
justify my last Point here and I'll make
it quickly uh Mr chairman is that even
the ipcc acknowledges there's no
attribution of almost any uh climate uh
impacts that they can attribute to CO2
yes temperature R is about the only
thing that's correlated but if you go to
table 1212 and working group one AR6
which is the base science the real
science that holds up all the a ipcc
reports what you'll find in that table
is that the there floods droughts uh
snowfall uh ocean activity none of this
they can attribute based on the
historical data to CO2 emissions and not
only that but they don't expect by 20 50
to be able to associate any of this with
CO2 emissions in other words the ipcc
itself acknowledges that attribution of
most of these climate impacted weather
events cannot be attributed to
CO2 given all of this given the fact
that that the economics of this
legislation I don't think has been fully
thought out when it comes to the
consumers of energy here in the state
and the uh businesses here in the state
I would strongly recommend that this
committee uh reject HB 106 I'll take any
now thank you uh Vice chair Thomas has a
question thank you Mr chair thank you
for taking my question I'm just curious
you you seem to have done a lot of
extensive research into this there have
been a lot of um reports various reports
citing increases in just about
everything having to do with atmosphere
can you tell me uh have all these
reports been over the same period of
time or are there gaps in time or are
the reports that cover a longer period
of history that would show maybe a
different Trend can you comment on that
sure the most of the alarmist type uh uh
events that are projected are really
based on what is called RCP 8.5 that's a
scenario um uh the relative climate uh
pathway that the uh ipcc uses for model
projections and if you do any extensive
if you have any extensive understanding
of the the modeling itself it is an
academic exercise it's recognized that
it should not be used as a policy tool
um that it the assumptions underlying
RCP 8.5 are unrealistic they make
assumptions that assume for example that
the world will be using 10 times more
coal in uh in 2100 than we do today
which is patently outrageous um it makes
assumpt assumptions that there's going
to be no new technology developments
between now and 2100 that will allow us
to utilize other forms of energy so RCP
8.5 which drives
almost by far the majority of the
climate science and the reports that you
see and you see the headlines on is not
based in reality and unfortunately that
drives a lot of policy decisions and yet
as I said before most scientists who
actually
look at this recognize that RCP 8.5
determinations
so when eversource was here a little
while ago to
testify or to make a presentation about
their company they stated there there
was a uh frequency and intensity of
storm increasing
trend in uh New Hampshire is that true
uh I I I can't State uh specifically to
the analysis they made but let me say
this they were basing it certainly
appeared that they were basing those
claims on dollar figures of what it
costs for a particular storm not
necessarily any weather related
intensity factors um not based on any
kind of what I would say real dollar
comparisons when you look at the worst
incidents in the state again go back to
the 1936 floods $25 million of damage in
this state in real current dollars
that's close to 600 million dollar worth
of damage which I believe is far more
than any of the events on the eversource
sheet um the floods of
1927 in the State uh $22 Million worth
of damage um these when you when you do
an Apples to Apples comparison of
current dollars what you'll find is that
the most damaging events in the state
didn't take place in the last 25 years
they took place 100 years ago um and
understand too that's despite the fact
that we have more impervious surface we
have um more development uh and
obviously you know uh more
infrastructure to damage today than we
had back then and yet dollar for dooll
the impacts were far more significant in
that time frame again I don't think
eversource looked at it in that way but
if you're going to look at the damages
associated with these events you you
really need to do it on a on a dollar
for dooll
basis representative Swanson has a
question so uh thank you Mr chair and
thank you Mr
senu um a lot of information a lot to
check on uh just to look at what ever
Source presented us on PID or slide
seven uh there's no mention of dollar
cost uh they ranked the frequency and
damage based upon the customer outage
restoration duration so there was no
mention so I didn't see the slides I was
only making assumption based on the
discussion here and follow while I have
a question yes go ahead with your
question make it quick please two
related questions number
one uh is the amount of CO2 in the
atmosphere uh actually increasing as
measured since 1950 7 when measurements
started and number two can you
guarantee that uh given the evidence of
impact of global warming throughout in
other portions of the country can you
guarantee that that will never impact
New Hampshire so with respect to CO2
yeah mon monola data which is is the
accepted uh evaluation of CO2 levels in
the in the in the in the globe uh has
been steadily increasing since the 1950s
although I will say that the the uh
tenuousness of whether that's related to
man's emissions became a real question
after 2020 when the global economy shut
down and there were massive reductions
in global CO2 emissions that Trend
didn't change one lick which which
raises the question of whether the CO2
itself is actually due to natural
variability or whether mankind is
actually having an influence because we
did if we had that strong an effect on
it and I don't question that we're we're
emitting CO2 into the atmosphere but if
we had that strong of of an effect on
co2 we should have seen some kind of
change based on that massive economic
change in global activity in 2020 as to
your other question regarding the
temperatures um again i' I'd fall back
on the data I think it's incumbent on
somebody who's going to impose costs on
companies who are doing business here
who are providing a an incredibly
important energy resource in this state
um if you're going to to basically you
know threaten their business and what's
going on the the burden of proof should
be on this committee and this
legislature to say Beyond a reasonable
doubt we think that we can
connect Co your CO2 emissions to these
damages and therefore recoup it it
shouldn't be the other way around and so
my point here is
there's no indication in the data that
the damages that we see that the the
weather activity we see has anything to
do outside of natural variability or is
at all correlated with CO2 emissions
followup question Mr chair Mr chair
time okay we we have a lot of people yes
I want to thank you for your testimony
it was excellent and we do have to move
on so thank you and if anyone has other
any other questions they certainly can
reach out to me thank you thank you okay
next I'd call on Bob
Susi who skull rather Bob Scully who
represents energy Managers Association
of New Hampshire I believe did I get
that right Mr Scully uh no uh thank you
Mr chairman members of the committee for
the record my name is Bob Scully and I
represent the energy marketers
Association of New Hampshire okay I also
represent two other groups today that
I'd like to uh present in oppos position
at HB
106 that is the um Propane Gas
Association of New England and the New
Hampshire Motor Transport Association
the the commonality between three of
them is the fossil fuels that we use um
I would just like to explain if this
bill was to move forward and pass as I
look at these legislative findings what
it would do to those three Industries in
our state of New
Hampshire so 65% of the homes and
businesses in New Hampshire are heated
either by heating oil or
propane the remaining balance most of it
is heated by natural gas which I do not
represent the trucking
industry delivers over 90% of all your
goods and services in the state of New
Hampshire there's over 5,000 companies
in our state most of them are small half
of them are single truck drivers in our
state of New Hampshire so as I read the
legislative findings on this bill and I
take a look at on on the page one here
okay line four it says Roman two a rapid
shift in energy use May prevent the
worst effects of climate change but even
under best case scenario there'll be
significant damage well what are we
going to ship from how are you going to
heat your home your business how are you
going to get your products how are you
going to drive your cars so first thing
for you all to consider the second one
is I'm going to take you right down to
line six Roman 3 under the the
legislative findings when it talks about
costly and extensive adaptations to deal
with the effects of climate change will
have to be made to New Hampshire
infrastructure and
Industry I represent three Industries
here today that if you would remove
fossil fuels you would destroy in a
state of New Hampshire that represents
state line 11 Roman 5 under the findings
says you will not be able basically
you'll not be able to pass any of these
uh additional costs onto the consumers
well you tell me how that's going to
work okay you can have an additional
cost get rid of fossil fuels and not
pass them on to the
consumer if that was to move forward and
that was to pass that these people at
least on the energy side would probably
not offer fuel in New Hampshire so you
might get what you want with no fossil
fuel but you won't heat your
house um I will tell you this state of
Vermont has passed maybe not exactly
something like this but some similar
legislation to try to recoup costs um
last year um a lawsuit was filed early
January I Believe by the American
petroleum Institute and the US Chamber
of Commerce to challenge the the law
that passed in Vermont um so you can
kindly I don't have that with me but you
can look it up um I'm not an attorney
but there are concerns with a similar
type of legislation in our border state
so I'm I'm trying to be uh respectful of
the time we just have three Industries
in New Hampshire this would damage
greatly if it was to move forward and
for that reason I uh oppose this
same representative Corman has a
question thank you Mr chair so um
understanding that you don't know the
particulars of the Vermont bill this
bill just establishes a commission did
the did the Vermont Bill do just that or
did it go beyond that no the the Vermont
the Vermont legislation went beyond
that additional
questions seeing none I want to thank
you Mr Scully and move on to the next
person who
is and I hope I get this right Dan
hberman of
Laconia is that correct
three minutes please all right I'm on
the
clock um my name's Dan huberman I'm a
resident of lonia I'm a recent retired
recently retired psychiatrist I'm
supporting this bill I'd like to discuss
the health effects of air pollution from
fossil fuels both from burning fossil
fuels and from climate induced changes
which cause wildfires and we'll begin
with the effects on my wife during the
summer of 2023 there were enormous fires
in Canada it is very likely that climate
change was the major cause of these
fires the smoke from the fire spread
into New New Hampshire my wife is an
athlete exercises 45 minutes a day but
has asthma she was forced to stay
indoors for days at a time as she had
worsening wheezing when she went out
outside on the worst days um this is not
an uncommon scenario it knew New
Hampshire our air quality has been
improving but it's not good enough and
we're also quite vulnerable to downwind
effects um from from wildfires and from
other states who whose uh air is not as
good the total costs associated with
man-made air pollution in New Hampshire
has been estimated at over $3.8 billion
dollar a year and the mortality um is
about, 1300 pre premature deaths a year
according to the um 200 17 Dees report
another study from congressman papis and
Congressman um kuster kuster in 20120
indicated that 41% of premature deaths
due to air pollution in New Hampshire
could be eliminated with reduction in
fossil fuels over 10 years exposure to
brief periods of high levels of
pollution such as these wildfires as
well as long periods of exposure to low
levels typically considered safe are not
so safe
air pollution from burning fossil fuel
produces toxic chemicals in pm2.5 pm2.5
are the very tiny particles which cannot
be filtered by the respiratory system
travel to every part of the body and
affect heart and lung function these
pollutants can both cause and worsen
lung and heart disease and are also
carcinogenic and have been linked to
very specific cancers wood bearing from
wildfires is even more toxic it's been
described as the worst form of pollution
that people are normally exposed to I'd
also like to comment on my field mental
health and air pollution Studies have
linked both short-term exposure to high
levels of these substances such as
wildfires and longterm exposure to low
levels to clinical episodes of
depression anxiety schizophrenia autism
dementia such as Alzheimer's and
suicidal behavior these um effects are
surprisingly significant and range from
about 10 to 45% increased risk in
summary fossil fuels and wildfires emit
toxin that toxins that cause multiple
diseases the statistics two more
sentences the St statistics and list of
diseases reflect real people in their
families who lives have been up ended
this is Untold Misery the fossil fuel
industry has known this for decades they
need to be held
accountable thank you sir any questions
huberman representative bney has a
question uh thank you chairman and thank
you for uh for your um testimony uh you
mentioned that pollutions coming from
Canada and other states uh would you
agree that it make more sense for some
for legislation like this to be filed at
the federal level more at the state
level because they can hold Canada as
you said and the other states more
accountable I I'm not an expert in in
you you know those
legal um events I know we're vulnerable
to wildfires here and I know there can
be uh air pollution here so I I'm not
sure okay seeing no further questions
thank you Mr huberman next up is Dr
Stephen
rlu of Bedford New Hampshire
representing
himself good afternoon
my name is Steven CLA um I passed out my
resume if you're interested in my
credentials um currently retired from a
long career as a risk assessor
evaluating impacts to human and
ecological Health speak a little bit
louder please okay yeah I'm softspoken
my job was essentially to determine the
relative risks of industrial missions on
human health and Wildlife I worked with
many states and many state federal and
federal Regulatory Agencies I also work
closely with many scientists who are
intimately familiar with climate models
and the many different forcing V
variables that were used to validate
these models I'm here to uh voice strong
opposition to HP 106 which wants to
establish a commission to determine the
monetary cost of climate damage to the
state of New Hampshire and the best
means of recouping such costs so the
first question that entered my mind upon
reading the bill was what damage I have
lived and worked in New Hampshire since
1988 and I have not seen nor heard
mention of any climate damage that
resulted from fossil fuels through any
industry nor have I heard of any climate
damage through state or federal agencies
that I have worked with I have not seen
any damage from any non-existent rising
of the ocean
levels uh along the New Hampshire coast
and though some have attempted to
illustrate a warming Trend in New
England I haven't seen any studies that
are able to link any such Trends to the
burning of fossil fuels none of the
models constructed by the i p p ipcc
have been correct nor have any realized
any outcome that they were intended to
predict to quote George box all models
are wrong but some are useful secondly
should this proposed commission assume
that any change in the local New
Hampshire climate was somehow
responsible for any purported damage to
the environment how would the commission
ascribe What proportion of the damage is
attributable to fossil fuels versus What
proportion is attributable from random
or natural variability
how would the commission go about
estimating any cost to pay for this
elusory damage how would the commission
act as a soothsayer or profit and
allocate costs needed for any future in
infrastructure adaptations this kind of
thinking would be like trying to predict
the outcome of a football game before
the ball's even kicked off not to
mention what the score might be during
any particular quarter or which players
might be involved in my experience
speaking on the basis of a regional
impact every attempt to allocate U
mitigation or adaptation costs based on
putative cause and effect scenarios
resulted in either a legal or a
political solution it was never based on
an engineered solution that could be
easily translated into objective costs
finally the bill states that the the
cost for climate damage and adaptation
must be Equitable and not place an undue
burden on citizens or the economy while
I am 70 years old and I can tell you
that should the commission get their way
and somehow a identify any damages which
really can't be attributable to fossil
fuels and B somehow allocate costs U by
seeing what estimates they have that
might stick to the wall there will be
indeed a very heavy price to pay for
both the private citizen and the economy
of New Hampshire to summarize my opinion
is that this proposed bill is a moond
doggle that is trying to hit your wagon
to the successful policies and the
failed predictions of the ipcc and I
thank you for your time my opportunity
to
speak thank you sir could you pronounce
your last name for me again CLA CLA Mr
CLA Dr CLA thank you for uh testifying
here this afternoon uh representative
schneller would like to ask you a
question yes thank you chairman V uh and
Dr CLA uh just to very simply put the uh
term consensus was used in prior
testimony um it sounds to me like
throughout your testimony you're
suggesting that consensus is something
we certainly have not arrived at and
therefore uh in your scientific opinion
we can't yet form conclusions that would
even
necessitate the objective of this
purported commission that's correct yeah
consensus is in science in my opinion
thank
you representative Summers has a
question thank you Mr chairman and thank
you doctor for taking my question I have
a I I see you have vast experience in
this and vast education along with
toxology and that as well so I'm I'm
curious on a scientific basis um in in
your educated opinion do you find
temperatures and temperature changes
climate change to be cyclical or does
you find it being still on a upward
Trend that is begin beginning at time in
my opinion I don't see an upward Trend
by my study of the data I mean cyclical
is
seasonal but um I my analysis of all of
the ipcc
reports um there's as there's as much
con as there is
pro
yep Vice chair Thomas has a question
thank you Mr chair thank you for taking
my question so um based on what you what
you said said am I uh And to clarify if
a commission was
established what would you think would
be gained by a commission uh you just
said there's enough Pros as there are
cons what would you think would be
gained by a commission and what effect
do you think it would have if one was
held well I'm I'm opposing the
commission because I don't think it
would have any effect at all I don't
think
I don't think any decisions would go
anywhere I mean the previous testimonies
that uh representative Swanson has a
question for you uh Dr CLA thank you for
your time uh Mr chair thank you for uh
allowing me a question uh I'm looking
over your resume and I see a lot of
Toxicology and water quality and uh uh
so you have considerable expertise in
chemistry yeah I presume and also
bacterial so forth uh do you have uh
training in meteorology or weather uh
you mentioned that reading the ipcc
report the intergovernmental panel on
climate uh commission or climate control
or I I'm not sure what the last SE is
but any rate uh but are you applying
your uh well you have a clear technical
background but do you have a
meteorological
background well I've taken courses of
meteorology and I worked with
meteorologists and Foresters and with
many many different types of models that
you have to use to predict um air roses
and um plumes coming out of a stack so
to speak so I'm familiar with all of the
terms and I'm not a meteorologist
but you don't you don't have to be a
plumber to fix your own Plumbing so to
speak okay thank you seeing no further
questions we'll move along here next up
is thank you laara
right thank you Mr chairman committee
members and fellow citizens my name is
Laura Magus and I have have lived in
conquered here since
1997 in 1990 I moved from Atlanta
Georgia to Kean New Hampshire largely
because I loved snow and uh cross
country
skiing I dreamt of skiing
outside uh my door in
Winter once I got here I find there was
not quite as much snow as I had had
Atlanta however for several years there
was enough snow for me to
enjoy uh some healthy exercise fun and
ability to connect with others who had a
Winters I recall being disturbed a few
years uh after I moved here by
predictions that in not too long New
Hampshire wi Winters would resemble
those in Atlanta which I had found very
boring I will say uh that the recent
Winters here have to some extent
reminded me of those in in uh my time in
Atlanta which was more than a
decade the predictions began to seem
increasingly accurate as the winter grew
Winters grew noticeably shorter and
milder often snowy days were followed by
rain or warm weather which turned
beautiful skiable snow to slush or
ice while I am able to adjust to these
changes I am sad to have to do
so the world seems to me to be out of
joint to borrow a phrase from William
Shakespeare I am also seriously
frustrated that New Hampshire has done
so little to mitigate our contribution
uh to climate change in this we are an
outlaw outlier among our fellow States
here in New
England another frustration is that the
creator of creators of these changes
have not only caused climate disruption
but have also covered up what they knew
about it and what they know about it
currently and of course many people like
those in uh Los Angeles now are
experiencing much more serious changes
than I am here and it would appear that
fossil fuel companies are promulgating
disasters without being held to account
for them and this is in my opinion a
grave
Injustice thank you chairman Bose thank
you uh I think at this point we're going
to have to forego questions because we
still have seven people who want to
speak and only 20 minutes for that to
happen so we'll move along next to
margerie Pim from Main Street in eeping
welcome
marjerie one of my constituents yes
hello and thank you for serving um and
thank you all to for letting me speak my
name is margerie
PIM uh from eping and I am a retired
public school
teacher when I first started teaching in
New Hampshire on the second floor of my
building which was a brand new building
at the time there was no air
conditioning and it got to the point
after 17 years the district decided to
put air conditioning units in because it
was becoming
unbearable um when the floods happened
on in the Sea Coast Area a few years
ago that caused several of my colleagues
to have difficulties with their commute
I don't I didn't teach in the district
on the Sea Coast but
nearby and um that has cost also if
where access is not possible due to
flooding um that can cause the districts
to have to reschedule there are costs to
the entire Community when that has to
happen um outside of the public school
system now I continue to teach I teach
knitting workshops and I rely on local
farms for supply of local
fiber wool in
particular and Shepherds here in New
Hampshire have told me that the window
the time frame for the breeding
season is tightening
with extreme heat being the cause of
when sheep are able to um
conceive and the increase in days with
extreme heat harms not only sheep but
produce
um I also am involved um with fiber
through strawberry Bank um where I I
sell products in their gift shop
strawberry bank is also destination for
our dear school children for field trips
in addition to tourists from other
states strawberry bank has had trouble
recently with water in um coming into
their property and causing damage and
increasing the financial burden of
history um which saddens
me I believe that HB 106
is designed to help us better understand
the financial impacts that we don't
exactly fully understand at this point
because we haven't had such a
commission um and I hope that that
better understanding that would result
from the studies of this proposed
commission will help us to preserve our
history our produce and our snow um so
that we can all continue to enjoy what
New Hampshire has to offer thank
you wow perfect way to go marjerie
okay next up is Barb seed of Mountain
Road I'm not sure what town but Barb is
herself it's Barb soued and that's
Bradford at row Mountain
Road and I am a retired Health
researcher and my husband and I live on
a a a really rural area where we have
about 100 acres of
forest and within that Forest we've
created two 3 Acre Wildlife areas which
is very nice and it's really helping for
the Wildlife to come in and have a place
to do whatever they do lots of different
niches and we did that several years ago
um but last
year we started to notice that we having
these plants that come in and they just
cover all the other you know bushes and
trees and stuff and just start killing
them and we were told those are
invasives and then invasiv are be
invasives are becoming more and more
common because of the shorter Summers
and because the summers are hotter and
drier and so we had to call in the big
equipment and uh get the poison
specialist to come and uh and and work
with us and that's
expensive but uh that's nothing compared
to the cost that New Hampshire is facing
centers for climate Integrity estimate
that is going to be a down payment just
the minimum down payment of a billion
dollars to get prepared for rising sea
levels
and also for damages to
flooding and to protect human health $1
billion that's the down payment and if
we don't do that the costs are going to
be even higher as the time goes on
because it's not going to get better and
it's going to be it's going to cause
Devastation to uh Public Health to the
environment to Farmers and to New
Hampshire's economy
and so you know this happened has
happened before in another realm and
that's
tobacco and tobacco was brought to
Justice because they knew they they had
a harmful
product and they were made to pay for
those
harms and I don't see why we can't take
big
oil and and litigate and get some of the
uh recoup some of these costs
well why not let's do
it otherwise we're really going to be
pay paying for
it so I support this commission and
thank you Tony
for proposing
it and thank you for listening and thank
you for your service any questions thank
you Barb for uh coming to see us we
appreciate
it okay next up is EMT Pim from eeping
and Mr Pim I would like you to uh
please give us new information don't
say hello my name is EMT Pim I'm a
student at un and I study engineering
physics um climate change is real um and
it causes problems that's basically a
given if you'd like to know what the
scientific consensus is go to nasa.gov
and in the search bar type climate
change scientific consensus you'll find
a page with a list of all of the VAR of
a lot of various sources that have all
change since I I think we can all agree
that climate change is a
problem the wise thing to do would be to
assess the potential damages and impacts
of our local
area um and that's what this bill does I
support this bill uh and you should too
thank
you thank you appreciate you coming down
today and talking to us next up is Susan
Richmond who I believe is from
Durham and um she's speaking for herself
and for someone who could not attend
correct yes so I'm Susan Richmond of
Durham I've lived there 38 uh 36 years
and I'm also going to be speaking for
Julia Steed mosson of pelum um so I'm a
mother grandmother taught public school
for 33 years so the reason I'm here is
because my life has been dedicated to
Preparing young people for the world and
I hope that we are caring for the world
that we're living leaving for our
children um clearly people in this room
and people testifying today have very
different ideas about attribution and
the reliability of models and predicting
and with this random assortment of
people that have decided to turn up
today I hope that is not the end of your
investigation of this issue and that you
will more systematically say you know
investigate H how can we trust a model
how can we trust predictions but I'm
going to talk today just about um what
the insurance industry has to say
because they compute a price for weather
events that have happened um not putting
any kind of uh determination on whether
or not it was anthropogenic but just
simply this is the cost and my
understanding of 106 is that the outcome
is not determined it's just an
opportunity to really investigate what's
the data what's out there what has been
happening with weather and then
hopefully you can do more work to
investigate can we attribute it um can
we ask for recompense from One Source or
another anyhow um insurance premiums
we're hearing in coastal regions have
gone up as flooding becomes more
frequent and
extreme oh I'm sorry backing up I was
driving to visit a friend in in adnoc uh
and had to do two years ago when there
were those terrible floods in the summer
and I had to do a 45-minute detour
because floods had destroyed the roads
and then I heard about other where roads
were destroyed rebuilt and then
destroyed again and I knew well there's
a cost to that and I began to wonder
what was the cost for Connecticut Valley
Farmers whose crops were lost in the
flooding and whose soil was made unfit
who paid for those losses what do they
amount to and is our food supply then
threatened with last year's flooding
throughought this summer so the insur I
asked my insurance broker about rates in
New Hampshire and was sent a wonderful
article from new Hampshire Business
Review June 19th 2024 which asks why are
insurance rates climbing even in New
Hampshire and and ours are climbing less
than in other states yay but the answer
in term of homeowners insurance
realtor.com cites climate change
affected weather as a primary reason for
increases everywhere climate risk is a
big deal it can impact home values
Insurance costs and the overall
stability of a housing market the
greatest risk for New Hampshire is
flooding related to heavy rain and or
melting snow events and to flooding
along the coast as sea level rise
continues so that's my testimony and now
this is from Julia Steed mosson of pelum
New Hampshire and hers is
regarding Inland flooding and I think uh
reading hers will take about 20 seconds
so my new home Lo quick please yeah my
new home loan required me to get flood
insurance though my family started Ed
living here on the lake in
1947 and it was never a requirement a
few years ago FEMA re-evaluated flood
issues and because New Hampshire slated
for more intense storms and greater rain
events FEMA has remapped areas of
potential flooding given the Myriad of
climate related disasters FEMA is
running out of money and so to be
proactive and get more money to handle
these
tragedies last year I was required to
pay $860 in flood insurance that I never
had to buy before okay and thank you so
much for your time everyone and and for
the work you're doing on this important
topic thank you for coming over from
Durham to talk to us today next up will
herself hi I'm Katherine um I'm from
Windom and I'm a junior at Bowden
College studying Earth and ocean graphic
science um and it's quite clear that
human burning of fossil fuels is causing
increase in greenhouse gases which is
causing increased temperature and a lot
of um climate related disasters all over
the world and in New Hampshire too and
the New Hampshire climate assessment
report found that New Hampshire is
facing infrastructure damage um from
flooding and severe storms and sea level
rise um and agricultural losses and
public health expenses attributed to um
fossil fuels and climate change um so I
think it's really important that we are
looking into the extent of these damages
and charging the fossil fuel industry
for them because they're responsible
instead of putting the burden on the
state and the taxpayers um and I know
there's been some questions about the
extent of these damages among committee
members so I think it really makes sense
to do this study so we can find out what
they are um and chairman bza is
wondering if you have the tallies of
like people who've submitted testimony
bill okay thank you very much appreciate
you
testifying do you oh sorry do you have
the tallies for um what people have
submitted online for this bill like the
online
testimonies I'm sorry I don't understand
your question
for
shair remote testimony thing would you
be able to like do you have the numbers
yeah those numbers are uh support 160
oppose five and neutral zero total to
testify
zero great thank you so much so yeah I
also support this bill along with most
of the people who have testified and I
hope you all will too thank you so much
for considering it thank you one second
chairman Vos could I please ask a
question uh representative Wendy Thomas
thank you very much um thank you for
being here and um it's wonderful to see
youth involved in this um
on related to that in your opinion
because you you are a lot younger than
many of the people in this room myself
included why do you think so many people
are afraid to recognize climate change
is happening and that it is a threat to
our lives health and economy what's your
perspective on that I think that the
fossil fuel industry has put a lot of
money and Research into confusing people
and following the similar tactics that
the tobacco IND is she used to like
confuse the message of the harms of
smoking and they've been very effective
in confusing the public and the policy
makers thank you very much thank you so
much okay thank you next up is Nick
hey good afternoon nice to see you today
I'm Nick coff I'm a senior attorney with
the conservation law Foundation um I
appreciate the opportunity to be here
today uh I'm here in support of HP
106 um because climate damage is and
will continue to cause significant
financial costs to the state the
committee should pass HP 106 and
establish a commission to study the
issue already environmental change is
harming New Hampshire's economy in a lot
of ways and you know we can witness it
very easily um it's harming our winter
tourism and Recreation
Industries um average winter
temperatures have increased several
degrees over the past Century which has
resulted in fewer snow cover days and
earlier ice out you know I'm I'm 38
years old I grew up in nearby Maine and
I witnessed it with my own eyes just
shorter Winters warmer Winters you know
fewer days to enjoy the the snow and the
winter here um these shorter and warmer
Winters have major financial
implications for our ski and
snowmobiling Industries um for those
enjoy ice fish fishing um it's it's big
detriment to them um you know we also
witnessed climate damage on the Sea
Coast um sea level rises increases the
frequency of coastal flooding which
causes infrastructure property damage um
we already have seen this a lot over the
past few years last year and um in
Hampton there was severe flooding in
Hampton which caused a lot of damage to
properties and businesses um you know
we've also seen climate damage our
Public Health in many ways um increased
temperature increases the risk of vector
born illnesses like Lyme disease um West
now virus
Etc you know given all these costs that
we're already experiencing that we're
expected to experience over the next few
years we need a commission to start
studying and quantifying these costs and
to determine how to adapt to them um I
don't think it hurts to to at least
study the issue there's no there's no
harm in doing that and uh you know if we
start if we don't plan for this issue
we're only going to make the problem
worse by leading to even higher costs um
for the state's economy and and public
health down the road um you know and
additionally to reduce costs to
taxpayers from this this major issue we
need to study the best means to recoup
those costs um and you know I think
exploring different ways to recoup those
costs it's really in line with New
Hampshire's fiscal conservatism I mean
it's not just focusing on on uh legal
damages it focuses on insurance bonding
you know any ways to save money for
taxpayers from these costs uh they're
damaging the economy um so in conclusion
you know I urge the commission to vote
for HP 106 uh we need to study this
issue to study the financial cost of
climate damage uh to help us adapt and
and please out to pass for this bill uh
thank you for your time and happy to
answer your
questions thank
you representative parshall has
one thank you chair and thank you for
being here tonight um Can Can you
estimate any uh potential uh hazards to
our our native agriculture such as our
Maple industry and would you consider
it's a general threat to our starability
feed ourselves if we do not take any
action yeah absolutely I mean um you
know with with our maple syrup industry
in particular I mean we we're seeing
much shorter sugaring Seasons um you
know I actually when I was when I was a
kid I worked on a maple sugar farm you
know in high school and we would tap the
trees you know March April you know now
we're now they're doing it in February
even January because you know the the
the winters are so much warmer so yeah
we're seeing that impact our uh Maple
sugaring industry and you know it's it's
impacting other agriculture Industries
as
well all right thank you very much and
our last speaker of the day is John Gage
from
Windam and like all other speakers Mr
Gage you have three minutes okay thank
you
thank you chairman and committee for
listening to my testimony I support this
bill um I think we should look at this
similar to what the state did for pasas
we had an industry come in that polluted
um it knew that pollution was going to
cause a problem and the state has taken
action and we're we're getting money
from the industry to help cover the cost
to taxpayers and families from that
dangerous pollution um
we have climate pollution from fossil
fuels and this is exactly the same
scenario we need to hold the business an
industry accountable for a pollution
that it knew was going to cause problems
in the future and is now costing us so
there is scientific consensus about this
issue um the ipcc report was quoted a
couple times
but uh the the P things that were pulled
out of it were not given the proper
context uh the summary of the six
assessment report from the ipcc is says
the conclusions are
incontrovertible greenhouse gases from
fossil fuel pollution are changing the
climate this is leading to Major costs
damages and losses across the world
including in New Hampshire um even the
oil and
gas industry agrees with this uh the
side of the sheet that I handed out has
exons climate models from 1982
they estimated the CO2 rise and the
subsequent temperature rise from that um
passed from now into the future and
they're within about 5% of uh where we
are today they knew decades ago their
pollution would continue to increase
under their policy scenarios around the
world and that it was going to cause
damages these are costing us
now the thing that irks me is this was a
two-faced game by an industry
because if you look at the back of that
sheet you'll see the major oil and gas
players all agree with the scientific
consensus about the problem of
greenhouse gas pollution from fossil
fuels and the threat to uh many aspects
of the way we live and nature and yet
they also played a two-face game because
in addition to accepting the science
they funded front groups and
misinformation which has manipulated the
conversation about climate change in our
society for over a
decade so we're being tricked and I'm
irked by being tricked and this is not
just a small trick this is changing the
chemical and physical properties of the
earth that we live on in ways that will
that are unrecoverable and are we are
losing
things they knew this was going to
happen economists call these external
costs their costs of producing or using
a good that are not reflected in the
good okay I want to thank you I have one
more point I there's three states that
have passed legislation in the last year
to do this um New York Vermont and Maine
and the Supreme Court just ruled
yesterday that Hawaii can go forward
with its lawsuits against the fossil
fuel industry for the damages that it
has recently incurred other states are
collecting money they're going to be
getting compensated and helping their
voters um shoulder the burden of these
damages and if New Hampshire doesn't get
its fair share of money we're going to
be paying not only for the damages but
we're going to help other states recover
and getting nothing for ourselves so
please support this Bill thank you very
much we have run up against
our uh time limit for the use of this
room so we have to call this to a close
so I just want report that he put in
good testimony that's it okay so uh I
recognize Vice chair Thomas yeah thank
you Mr chair uh just for the record
although he did he wasn't here verbally
to testify uh representative Julius soti
gave a written um testimony uh in
opposition to this
bill so with that we will question
representative part
Mar thank you uh is it possible get
copies of the this um uh letter and also
somebody earlier referenced was a sonunu
oh thank you senu referenced a bunch of
information that he submitted will that
be available
correct oh 15 pages that might be too
much never
mind representative F thank you chair
have have this committee heard of all
the pink sheets that were submitted or
yes
okay yes we absolutely heard everybody
and we thank everybody for testifying on
this bill and I'm going to close the
public hearing on House Bill
106 thank you all and um keep your eye
on the calendar for the next meeting of
st& it'll be next Tuesday the
21st of January it will probably start
at 10 o'clock not 9:00 because I've been
informed that this room has been booked
for the rest of the year on Tuesdays
from 9:00 to 10:00 so we're going to be
starting at 10:00 on Tuesdays henceforth
so we will see you next Tuesday at 10
o'clock have a safe ride home thanks
everybody